TO GO AHEAD AND START
OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING-
THIS AFTERNOON SO I'M GONNA SAY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME WATER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN THE CAP
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATE THE
HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WARNING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM CREDIT VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT FOR WITNESS TEST
TODAY. THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
TODAY HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY.
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTENTION OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX WEEK WAS BASING. THEIR ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING PRO
GROWTH PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC
TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I WILL BE. ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE TO CHURCH
OBSERVERS DISTANCE IN A POND
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. LIMITED
LIVE LIMITING. L. USE TO PER AT
A TIME. TODAY'S WILL BE TAKEN
UP IN THE FOR LIST. IN ON THE
AGENDA AND IN THE DAILY FILE
WITH ONE EXCEPTION- FOLLOWING
THE PRESENTATION OF BILLS BY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. WE WILL BE
HEARING- MR GRAYSON PRESENTING
AB HELLO THREE EIGHTY NINE SO
THAT THERE IS THERE IS A THERE
IS A CHANGE TO THAT- AS WE
PROCEED WITH WITNESSES AND
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO
ENSURE WE MAINTAIN. ORDER AND
RUN AN EFFICIENT AND FAIR
HEARING. WE WILL NOT PERMIT
COULD THE CONTACT THAT DISRUPTS.
OR OTHER IMPEDE SEAPORT KINDA
OF LET'S PER. AND VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY BE SUBJECT TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT.
PROCESS IN ADDITION TO BEING A
TO TEST FROM INSIDE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE TO. BILL WITNESSES
MAKING OF OUR- WHEN I OUR
WITNESSES VIDEOCON. ROOM WHICH
ARE. HERE IN THE CAP. IN OUR
REMOTE TESTER STATION LOCATED
ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBER CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY
LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO.
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HO COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AND IN THE DAILY FILE. AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. FOR
CALLING IN. PLEASE TO DO SO AS
AUTHOR THE BILL YOU'RE TESTED
ON IS BEING THEIR PRESENTATION
OF THEIR BILL THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE- BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOUR
MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A BILL
YOU WERE MADE ON A LIFELINE AND
WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED UPON TO
SPEAK. OR HAVE ANY PROBLEMS THE
MODERATE PHONE. YOU CAN CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2097
AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH. THE
POSITION PORTAL WHICH- POSITION
LETTER PORTAL WHICH WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN FINDTHE
EMAIL FOR THEIR COMMITTEE THERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
IN THE CHAMBER MEANWHILE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL
CAL ASK A QUESTION PROVIDE A
COMMENT JUST RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE. SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU'RE AND- WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK.
ALSO PLEASE STAND UP IF YOU'RE
OFFERING TESTIMONY FACED A
MICROPHONE WAS SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE. I
THINK CAN BE RECORDED. IN
FAIRNESS TO EVERYONE WE WILL
NEED TO BE ESPECIALLY STRICT ON
THE TIME LIMITS TODAY. WILL WE
WILL HEAR FROM UP TO TWO
WITNESSES FOR THREE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. AFTER THE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES FOR EACH SIDE
TESTABLE TESTIFIED. IF THERE
ARE ANY WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES AND COMBINE THE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATIONS THEY REPRESENT.
ONE IN POSITION ON THE BILL.
THERE ARE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
PROPOSED CONSENT FOR TODAY
HEARING ANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE A BILL
FROM CONSENT. POSTER CONSENT
OUR ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE
ZERO NINE FOUR BY DR ARAMBULA.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
TEN FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO. ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A SUBSTITUTE MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU WILL
SUBSTITUTE FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS RIVAS TODAY FOR TODAY'S
HEARING- PULLED FROM THE
HEARING ALSO AB TWELVE FIFTY
ONE WHERE SU CHI HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE HEARING.
TODAY'S HEARING AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. THAT MIGHT NEED
A BREAK HERE BUT NO WE WON'T DO
THAT SO WE'LL JUST GO STRAIGHT
TO DOCTOR ARAMBULA. AND YOU
HAVE TO BILLS BEFORE US. SOME
AND YOUR THIRD BILLING CONSENTS
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY SIR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN CANDAMAGE HAS MADE A
COOLEY CLEAR THAT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA MUST HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS. WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE
ARE EXCLUDED FROM MEDICAL
SERVICES COBIT NINETEEN HAS
IMMERSED MERCILESSLY HIT OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO WORK IN OUR FIELDS
AND OTHER ESSENTIAL JOBS TO
KEEP OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
GOING DURING THIS CRISIS. WE
KNOW THAT THOSE WHO LACK
INSURANCE GET SICKER AND DIE
SOONER WE NOTE THAT THE LARGEST
SEGMENT OF THE UNINSURED IS OUR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY. I WAS
ON THE FRONT LINESOF HEALTH
CARE AND FEEL THE URGENCY TO
FIX THIS CURRENT HEALTHCARE
CRISIS INSTEAD OF BEING ABLE TO
RECEIVE CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER
TO PREVENT ILLNESS FROM
DETERIORATING MANY UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ONLY ACCESS HEALTH
CARE IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
WHERE MANY TIMES PHYSICIANS
LIKE MYSELF ARE NO LONGER ABLE
TO HELP DUE TO THE
EXACERBATIONS. OF THEIR ILLNESS.
I HAVE SEEN CAN CASE WHO HAVE
COME IN MY MERGING ROOM IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN OUR COUNTRY'S
BREADBASKET WHERE THE
FARMWORKERS WHO HELPED TO
PRODUCE THE FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES WHICH BILL OUR
TABLES AND FEED OUR FAMILIES.
ARE UNABLE TO DO THE SAME FOR
THEIR OWN FAMILIES DUE TO THEIR
DIRE HEALTH CIRCUMSTANCES. NOT
ONLY IS THIS CURRENT STATE OF
AFFAIRS DETRIMENTAL TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BUT IT ALSO
INCREASES THE DEMAND ON
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES AND
INCREASES COSTS IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM OVERALL. IN A
MANNER THAT COULD BE PREVENTED.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LEGACY OF
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
AB FOUR WILL CONTINUE IN THIS
VEIN. I AM CONFIDENT THAT THIS
BILL WILL HELP US MEET OUR GOAL
TO EXPAND FULL SCOPE MEDICAL TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. BY REMOVING
IMMIGRATION STATUS AS AN
ELIGIBILITY BARRIER TO MEDIC.
CALIFORNIA CAN BUILD A MORE
UNIVERSAL. EQUITABLE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM FOR ALL WHO CALL
THIS STATE HOME. NOW IS THE
TIME TO ACHIEVE EQUITY AND
HEALTH CARE ACCESS BECAUSE
WHILE WE KNOW THAT TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE WE ALSO NOTE THAT
THE HELP OF EACH OF US IS
DEPENDENT ON THE HELP OF ALL OF
US. HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS DELORES WORK OUT AS WELL AS
IS A BILL GARCIA A COMMUNITY
MEMBER WHO WILL SHARE THEIR
STORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER OPERATOR ARE MADAM
OPERATOR I DON'T KNOW. COOPER
WE HAVE TODAY. PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR THE FOR OUR
PRIME OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE NEW. YEAH DOLLAR CLASS HERE.
WELL YES BUT ON THE LEFT IF I
GET UP YES ON THE YOUR. I'M
GONNA BE- TRANCE AND READ-
FRONT AND BACK YES. TESTIMONY
FINISH IS BADLY BECAUSE FROM
AND HAVE PROBLEMS. I DON'T GET
ON THE END OF THE NEXT YEAR I
WOULD BUILD BIT IF YOU LET HIM
KNOW WHAT I MEAN NOT BASEBALL
CONSIDERED ALTOGETHER BE BACK
YEAH I GUESS THE WAY TO HANDLE
BATES THE PEOPLE WHO BE ABLE TO
BUT I OPENED FOR HAVE YOU. IT
LOS RESIDENTES THE F. ONE THE
OF MORE DEFEAT. CARE ACT. WHAT
THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD HAVE MY-
IMPORTANCE MORE. LOCALLY AND
THE THOUGHT EMAIL THE RECORD ON
PHONE AND MAKE YOUR PEOPLE AND
ALL THAT YOU'LL- WITH SEVENTY
THREE THE SENATE. ON PAR YOU
SEE THE- THEY SET UP AND THEN
YEAH. NO I FOR THE BUT NOT
QUITE ENOUGH WE NEED TO. ME
THEM. OR UP THAT- FEET ARE YOU
CANNOT. THAT FOR ME THAT'S- THE
MOST ISSUE ON IT IF THE SENIOR
SO YOU'RE NOT. IF YOU DON'T NOT
UNTIL HAD MULTIPLE THEM YOU
HAVE. WELL MY MEDICAL. FOUND
WHAT MOTHER TERESA FOUR AND
PEOPLE BENEFIT YOUR AN EXAMPLE
BASED ON HE SAID SAYS THAT
WOULD HAVE. ENDED ME THAT I'VE
ACTUALLY. THAT THINK. I OH YES
BY. ROTEM ISSUE THE HOME APPLE.
APPLE VEHICLE BEGAN PEOPLE BUT
ARE NOT. INMATE SEAT ON FROM
OUR FLORIDA. LEVEL THAT'S NOT
YOU REPEATED. MY NAME IS THE
SEVEN THIRTY I AM A MEMBER OF
THE ORGANIZATION PHOTIC. IN I
LIVE IN THE CITY OF KERR
CALIFORNIA. I AM SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD. FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL IN THE VIRGIN
OF GUADALUPE FOR ALLOWING YOU
TO LIVE ANOTHER DAY. I AM A
SURVIVOR. I BUT I FEEL.
STRUGGLING WITH QUOTA BY IRAN-
NEED TO DATE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
ME. I DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICAL COVERAGE. IN BECAUSE OF
FEAR I DID NOT SEEK MEDICAL
ATTENTION. I HAD- TAKING CARE
OF MYSELF WITH HOME REMEDIES.
AND BY THE BY GODS WILL. MANY
OF MY FRIENDS HAVE. DIED DUE TO
COLD IT. IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO. DO THREE BECAUSE I FEAR
BECAUSE I TOO HAVE PROP READ.
AND LYFT NOT WAIT FOR TO SLEEP
IN WAKING. BECAUSE OF MY AGE I
THANK FOR THE FOR CHRONIC
ILLNESSES. I HAVE NO AT
ANYTHING FROM THE GOVERNMENT I
HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED MY KIDS.
I CAN THINK OF MOTHER WORKING
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN
THE FIELD. OF HARVESTING
DIFFERENT BEDS BETTY'S. I GAVE
MY LIFE IN MY WORK TO THE STATE
INTO THIS COUNTRY BUT NOW. I
FEEL LIKE AN OLD RAG. BECAUSE I
AM ABLE TO WORK. ANYMORE AND
I'M THROWN AWAY LIKE TRASH. I
AM NOT SURE IF I WILL PROVIDE
THIS SCOLDED TO FIND FEEL HAPPY
A LOT OF DIFFICULTY BREATHING I
DON'T HAVE MONEY TO PAY
HOSPITAL BUT IF I DIE I WANT TO
LEAVE WITH MY CONSCIENCE CLEAN
KNOWING THAT I ADVOCATED FOR
THE REST OF ELDERS LIKE MYSELF.
THAT HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES TO
THIS COUNTRY I ASKED FOR A
PHOTO CONSCIOUS FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF ELDERS MY GREAT
ELDERS WHO LIKE MYSELF HAD
GIVEN THEIR WORK TO THE STATE.
I ASK FOR YOU TO AND TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF MEDICAL EXPANSION. FOR
ELDERS SB FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT WITNESS ON THE
TELEPHONE PLEASE. AT A LOT OF.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK LOW THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
TO WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE LINE UP
FOR TAKING ON THIS- INCREDIBLE
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGE OF A
CONTINUING OF THE GOOD WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN
CALIFORNIA A TO REALLY PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL. AND IF
YOU'RE A GIRL WHO THREE HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL REMAIN EVERYBODY
WE KNOW THAT WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE AS WE
JUST HEARD THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY THAT HAVE GIVEN THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES A YEAR A TO MAKE
LIFE BETTER FOR EVERYONE IF WE
GET ESPECIALLY ONE THAT
MENTIONED THE FARM WORKERS.
BECAUSE OF COURSE THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT I KEEP THIS UP AND TO
KEEP EXTEND. OTHER OTHER
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS THAT KEEP
US. BY KEEPING UP THE GOING. TO
CARE OF OUR TO COULDN'T. OF
OURSELVES. AND IT IS REALLY.
ONLY TWO TREAT A PEOPLE THAT
COULD. ALL OF THEIR LIFE. AND
HAVE THESE HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT ARE NOT TAKE CARE OF. I
RECENTLY SAW. THAT THE DOME
THAT I. AT AND IT NEVER DID
HEAR FROM DOCTOR BUT- HE HAD A
LINK TO THE BECAUSE THE TYPE.
AND BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE A
CAR OF PREVENT CARE. THE COULD
APPROVED THAT HAPPENING TO THE-
SO WE WILL OUGHT TO THESE INTO.
WERE AS WE KNOW IT COULD OVER
TO. OF DOLLARS. A YEAR AND
JACKSON OVER. BILLION DOLLARS
IN INCOME A TO A- COMMUNITY BY
ALL BECAUSE SPENDING THAT THEY
DO. SO WE WILL ALL OF THEM I
TO. MAKE MAKE SURE THAT MAKES
THE HELP TO EVERYONE. ONE OF
THE EVERY SIX CALIFORNIA CHILL.
ONE OF SIX CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A LEAST ONE
PARENT WHO THE DOCTOR. WE KNOW
THAT OPTIMALLY I DO HAVE A TWO.
REALLY HELPED. GET TERRIBLE
CONDITIONS TO GO TO EMERGENCY
ROOM. AND THE DOCTOR ABOUT THE
SAID THAT IT REALLY CONSERVE
MUCH MONEY WHEN PEOPLE DO TO GO
TO GET MY- ROOM. THEY ARE NOT
GETTING THE KIND OF A PRINT
PREVENTATIVE. AND PRIMARY CARE
THE THEY NEED TO IT REALLY ENDS
UP. HELLO MORE MONEY EACH SO
IT'S KIND TO DO THE RIGHT. BUT
EXPAND HEALTH CARE. FOR ALL OF
UNDER. PEOPLE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SO. BECAUSE READER.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE- A OF
HELPING TO KEEP US CLEAN THE TO
PER SE. AND TIME THAT WE EXTRA.
THE- MEDICAL COVERAGE TO ALL OF.
IN THIS NOT ONLY JUST ABOUT
THEM AT ABOUT ALL OF US MONTHS.
BECAUSE WE CANNOT BE HEALTHY.
AND ANOTHER PROTECT BY
NEIGHBORS ARE NOT. I WOULD HAVE
ALREADY BEEN THE WAY AND THAT
EXTEND. OF THE MANY TERM TO.
INTO THE ADULT WELL NOW
CALIFORNIANS AS WE KNOW ALL A
LEADER. NINE ATTEMPTS THE JOB
IT'S TIME TO EXIT. HEALTHCARE
TO. AND ESPECIALLY AROUND DIA
PEOPLE SO WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY. AND- I DO URGE PLEASE
GIVE GIVE THIS AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TO- AT THIS POINT WE WILL
I WE DON'T HAVE AN RED. WITNESS
IN OFFICE. SO WILL TO THE J. OR
ANYONE THE CHAMBER LIKE TO ON
THIS IS JUST YOUR AND POSITION.
ON ANY ORGANISED MIGHT RUN.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE EMILY
HUGHES CAL MEDI ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL GO TO THE
OPERATOR AND ASK THEM THE PHONE
LINES BE OPEN FOR. PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
JUST ASK OR OPPOSITION JUST
ASKING FOR YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. TO OUR MODERATOR.
MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS THAT YET AND HELP
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS LED THE WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY JOHN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PAGE NOT THAT LONG AGO. ONE ONE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER THEIR
BRIDGE ON THE HELP WITH THE
INVESTIGATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CONICAL TRIAL HEARS REPORT FOR
TWO POINT THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HAVING BREAKFAST BEHALF
OF. NATIONAL PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
IN MY COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
ALL IN SUPPORT. YOU KNOW THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DIDN'T EVEN THAT I GOT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWO ZERO ONE TWO
HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOURNALIST
CATHY BUSTED ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL PLANTS OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
IMPORTANT AB FOUR THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RAMBLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OVERTURE NUMBERS CALLS WORSE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN AND GIRLFRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
YOUR REMEMBERS GRANT MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO HUNDRED
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SALLY
CHAIN WITH THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE NEED FY AND
WHAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
COLLABORATIVE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE ONE FIFTY ONE FIVE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ANGIE THE ACT ON BEHALF OF
NPA CALIFORNIA WE ARE INTO
QUITE A POLICY FOR NOT MAKING
IT INTO THAT NOW. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. ONE ONE ONE PLEASE
AHEAD. HI- DR ROBERT THE NEW OF
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES- IN
STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE WHEN
KIDS GET SICK- OR PARENTS COULD
SIX ZERO- KIDS ARE REALLY COOK
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND JUST
YOUR NAME POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE
MEMBERS NO EQUITABLE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THERE ARE FLOCKS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK THE PENSION
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE TO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TO
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVN FRESNO COUNTY OF RESIDENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
TRACK WITH EACH WITH EACH MAC
THAT CALIFORNIA FROM PART THANK
YOU SIX CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BETTY TALK
ABOUT WHAT WENT CALIFORNIA'S
ALLIANCE CALLING YOU FROM LOS
ANGELES INSTRUCT THE PORT AT
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN GO AHEAD. HI
DOCTOR TONY RAMIREZ CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT FROM SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM WORKING WITH PARENTS
SERVICES IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
EDUCATION NETWORKING STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXTCODE
PLEASE. ONE TWO HUNDRED
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARIA
THIS WHEN ASKED TWENTY INSTRUCT
THE COR AN APOLOGY NOT MAKING
THAT YEAH NOT THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH
DIRECTION YOU TURN MEMBERS
IRTHLINGBOROUGH IN BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN YOUR SHIFT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS BUREAUCRATS
PORT. THANK YOU NEXTCODE PLEASE.
ONE ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JIM AND REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EMILY HELLO ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE YELLOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BARBARA
PLAYED THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY FELL ON
BEHALF OF ST JOHN'S WELL CHILD
AND FAMILY CENTRE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE TWO TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES THANK YOU. HI HI MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RACHAEL K. ON THE-
FORMER POLITICAL BOARD MEMBER
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
FORTY PLEASE. SH HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATIE AND
I LOOKED OVER THE LINES FOR A
BETTER COMMUNITY I'M CALLING
AND SUPPORT STRUCK THE PORT
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I THINK. THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KARINA I'M
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH THE
LONG TERM ICR RIGHT COALITION
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE I'M HAPPY TO BE
ALIVE THE CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING
HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF BLUE
SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
OPERATOR KEEP TELL ME ROUGHLY
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE.
WE HAVE ELEVEN STILL IN THE
QUEUE OKAY THAT'S FINE I'M JUST
CURIOUS THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD NEXT CALLER. ONE TWO
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS THAILAND MORATORIUM
WAY CALIFORNIA PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE CALLING FROM L. A. AND%
FROM BOREDOM BILL AB FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WANT TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
ANN DONNELLY AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ORGANIZATION THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION AND
THE EPIDEMIC CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA HEPATITIS ALLIANCE
AND OUR APOLOGIES FOR NOT
GETTING THE AMOUNT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO. HI JENNIFER MY
LEGALLY CEO OF CALLING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. AT THANK YOU
FORTY FIVE HE'S GOT. YEAH
MARIANA MORE OPPORTUNITY
CAMPAIGN AND CONTRA COSTA
INCOME SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEDICARE
MEMBER ROB PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL BE ACCOUNT
THEY JUST DIDN'T STOP SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE TWO FIFTY SIX PLEASE. THANK
MEDIA BRANDPOINT WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA CRYING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE COULD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO WATSON AND THE DAMAGE TO
THE SENATE SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWO FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS REALLY INTERESTING THAT THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND FROM SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS LEILANI THURMOND NURSE
PRACTITIONER FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER REGISTERED NURSE
WORKING IN SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
ONE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. YES YOU'RE RIGHT IS OPEN
PLEASE. I FORGOT TO LOOK AT.
THE CONDITIONS CANNELLA PUBLIC
CALIFORNIA COMPETITION BROKE
THE RECORD THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LYING TO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN I
MAKE A QUEEN CALIFORNIA THE
PARK DIRECTOR FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO. GOOD AFTERNOON
PROTESTED AFTER TELLING
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG AND STRONG SUPPORTER
CULTURAL. YOU NEXTCODE PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LOVE THAT MENTAL SIDE WITH
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE CALLING FROM SAN
BERNARD DINO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE TO
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THAT THE COMPANY DISAPPOINTED
YOU KNOW CONSTRUCT SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HI NINE TWO SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO. HELLO KELLY NAME
WOULD HELP NOT IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SERVING
ALMOST THREE MILLION MEDICARE
MEMBERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOR HELP FOR ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO. THANK YOU
TWENTY PER WALL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE CALL. THAT
ACTION NUMBER OF THAT TRUCK
BLOCKING. AND OCCUPIED AND
GENDER JUSTIFIED IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF COMPOUND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO. ONE
TWO HUNDRED YOU WIND UP. HELLO
OKAY MAYBE. PART. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN I AM
A MEMBER OUT OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND. COACHELLA VALLEY.
EXACTLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
JUST SO WE'RE GONNA- LIMIT OUR
PUBLIC TEST OF FOR WILL GO MORE
MINUTES- AND LESS THAN THE Q.
IS EX- THE THAT SO WE WILL STOP
OUR PUBLIC COMMENTED TO FIFTEEN
SO THANK YOU- PLEASE GO AHEAD
NEXT CALLER. MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM MY NAME. I REMEMBER AND I AM
CALLING IN FIRST SUPPORT FOR
HELP GIRL BROWN'S. YOU THINK
YOU NEXTCODE PLEASE. NINE TO
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
WELL I'M A MEMBER OF. AND IN IN
THE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
COACHELLA VALLEY I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF FOLK ROCK
THANK YOU FOR ELDERS THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERTO AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THAT I. THANK
YOUNG REPORTERS HELP PRODUCTS
MANAGERS FOR ELDERS. THANK YOU.
MEXICO OR PLEASE. ONE ONE
SEVENTY YOUR OPEN. HI I AM MY
NAME IS TO BE DONE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF TOTEMIC- I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF PUNK ROCKER
ELDERS. THANK YOU FOR ALL THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. ONE ONE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME.
NUMBER IN THE NAME AND
COACHELLA VALLEY AND I'M
CALLING. FOR ALL SPECIAL THE
OTHER THE GO THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. ONE ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL WELL. I'M
NOT. NUMBER OF THE ONE PART OF
THE AND CALLING SOFT LOOK ABOUT
DRUGS OF THESE EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS GARY I'M MEMBER OF THE OTHER
IN THE EVENT AND COULD STILL
VALLEY I AM YOU SHOW TO PORT
UPHELD FOR ALL EXPANSION. FOR
YOU NEXTCODE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER OH FIVE THREE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MIKE I AM A OF
AND THEN I AM ON SUPPORT FOR
THANK YOU FOR BUILDERS BEING
HERE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND LASTLY LINE WHY
THIRTY PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS OSCAR SANDOVAL I'M WITH
YOU UP YOU KNOW COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
OTHER CO CHAIR WE DO HAVE. ONE
MORE QUEUING UP. HERE OKAY ONE
TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY MARKETS WITH INNOVATIVE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORT OF THE
BEFORE THANK YOU. IN ONE ONE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETY SIX YOU WANT IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BENEFITTED ON WITH ANY STATE
GOING TO CONNECT ME TO THE
ORGANIZING PROJECT CALLING FROM
OXNARD IN STRONG SUPPORTER NAY
BEFORE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
OTHER COMMENTERS IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL BRING IT BACK-TO THE COMMITTEE NOW FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
QUESTIONS. I'M SORRY. WE GET
YEAH YEAH YEAH SO IT'S ALL
BLENDED SO- SO- BRING IT BACK
TO THE NORTH KNOW THE COMMENTS
I JUST WANT TO SAY- PERSONAL A
DOCTOR I MEAN WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE CAN'T ACCEPT A
MOTION AT THIS POINT BUT I'M
CONFIDENT THAT SOME POINT
DURING THE DAY WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND SO LET'S SAY THE BILL DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ABOUT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR YOU AND I SHARE
THE SAME PHILOSOPHY THAT
EVERYONE IN THE SYSTEM IS
BETTER FOR THE SYSTEM AND
BETTER FOR EVERYBODY- IF WE
CAN'T HEALTH CARE TO PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY PREVENTIVE CARE HOW
TO PREVENT THE DISEASE WE KNOW
HAPPENS- AND THE HIGH COST CARE
THEY CAN BE PREVENTED SO I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER IN WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR HEALTHCARE IS
A HUMAN RIGHT AND AS SUCH I
HOPE WE RECOGNIZE THAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD BE TREATED WITH THE SAME
DIGNITY AND GIVEN THIS RIGHT
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE ON TO NEXT BILL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TO CAP THE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES TO BE LICENSED
PURSUANT TO THIS BILL AT FIFTY
AND TO PROVIDE A TEN YEAR
SUNSET. MEMBERS AB THREE
SEVENTY EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE
BY ALLOWING MEDICARE CERTIFIED
AMBULATORY SURGICAL CENTERS
ASC'S TO PERFORM ELECTIVE
PERCUTANEOUS CORONARY
INTERVENTION PCI PROCEDURES
SUCH AS ANGIOPLASTY SINCE
STENTING AND CARDIAC
CATHETERIZATION PROCEDURES.
EXPANDING THESE SPECIFIC
CARDIAC PROCEDURES AND ASC'S
WILL REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS
OVERALL WITHOUT COMPROMISING
PATIENT SAFETY. ASC'S HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY PERFORMING THESE
PROCEDURES AND WELL OVER HALF
THE COUNTRY FOR YEARS SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND PCI PROCEDURES HAVE
BEEN PERFORMED IN THEIR CITIES
WITH A COMPLICATION RATE WELL
UNDER 1% HOWEVER BECAUSE OF AN
OUTDATED STATUTE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF ONLY ELEVEN STATES THAT
EXPLICITLY AND LIMIT THE SITE
OF SERVICE WHERE THESE
CARDIOLOGY PROCEDURES CAN BE
PERFORMED. CALIFORNIANS
RESTRICTION ON SUCH PROCEDURES
IS OUT OF STEP WITH OTHER
STATES AND IS OUTDATED. THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES RECOGNIZE THE
BENEFITS OF PERFORMING SEVERAL
LOW RISK CARDIAC PROCEDURES
SAFELY AND EFFICIENTLY IN AN
ASC SETTING. AB THREE SEVENTY
WILL AUTHORIZE MEDICARE
CERTIFIED AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO PERFORM ELECTIVE
CARDIOLOGY PROCEDURES. WITHOUT
THE STATUTORY UPDATE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND PATIENTS
ENROLLED IN COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURANCE ARE NOT ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INCREASED ACCESS
TO CARE OPTIONS AND THE
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS
QUALITY OF CARE AND CONVENIENCE
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS STRAINED
THE ENTIRE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
AND IS EXACERBATED MANY ISSUES
AROUND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT WERE ALREADY
PRESENT. AB THREE SEVENTY
PROVIDES ANOTHER OPTION FOR LOW
RISK PATIENTS TO RECEIVE CARE
AB THREE SEVENTY PRIORITIZES
HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND PATIENT
SAFETY THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
GREATER ACCESS TO THE SPECIFIED
ELECTIVE CARDIAC PROCEDURES
WHILE REDUCING OVERALL HEALTH
CARE COSTS AND DEMAND ON
SERVICES. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
PROPOSING THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL WHICH WILL FURTHER ENSURE
PATIENT SAFETY BY REQUIRING
THAT AGENCIES COMPLY WITH THE
SKY RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PATIENT
CARE. MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THESE AMENDMENTS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
SPONSORS TO PROTECT PATIENTS
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE SEVENTY OUR PRICE
DOUGHERTY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
AMPLE OF AMBULATORY SURGERY
ASSOCIATION AND DR KYLE MCCARTY
LIST WITH THE SACRAMENTO HEART
AMBULATORY SURGERY CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
MARK MISTER OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR OUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PRICE DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOTTERY'S
SURGERY SO SHE SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED BABY THREE SEVEN. DR
ARABIA MENTIONED THIS BILL
ALLOWS AN AFC CERTIFIED BY CMS
TO PERFORM DIAGNOSTIC
INTERVENTIONAL CARDIOLOGY
PROCEDURES SUCH AS DYE
INJECTIONS TO DETECT ARCHER OF
BLOCKAGES AT THEIR PEAK
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS
ANGIOPLASTY AND STENTING UPON
APPROVAL. BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND CONSISTENT
WITH JOINT CLINICAL GUIDELINES
PUBLISHED BY THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY. SOCIETY
FOR CARDIOVASCULAR ANGIOGRAPHY
AND INTERVENTIONS. AND THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION.
THESE COMPARATIVE CHARCOAL GUY
OF ISSUE OF PAGE SELECTION
STAFFING EQUIPMENT NEEDS AND
VARIOUS OTHER SAFETY CRITERIA.
FURTHERMORE THE VACANCIES WILL
BE REQUIRED TO REPORT QUALITY
OUTCOMES TO THE NATIONAL
CARDIOVASCULAR REGISTRIES AND
USING THE DATA ACQUIRED FROM
THESE NATIONAL REGISTRIES. THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
BUT EIGHTY ONLY DEVELOP AND
MAKE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
REPORTS REGARDING EACH
CERTIFIED ANTES PERFORMANCE
RATE OF MORTALITY AND STROKE.
FURTHER TRANSPARENCY REQUIRES
ANY POSITION WITHIN EQUITY
INTEREST IN ONE OF THESE
NANCY'S TO DISCLOSE TO THE
PATIENT IN WRITING HAT FINAL
FINANCIAL INTEREST BURKE
OWNERSHIP IN THAT THEY
ACTUALLY. THESE PROCEDURES ARE
PREVENTED IN THE NATURE LOW
RISK LIFESAVING AND ALREADY
BEING DONE IN A ISSUES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AFC'S ARE
ROUTINELY AND SAFELY PERFORMING
PROCEDURES SUCH AS TOTAL HIP
REPLACEMENT TOTAL JOINT
REPLACEMENT AND SPINE SURGERY.
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES AT A MUCH LOWER
COST TO THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE. IN
PATIENTS STARTS OF SERVICE.
APPLE ARE ON YOU SEE BURKE
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT EVERY.
BEING IN A- SAVE THE MEDICARE
FORTY PER. AND SAFETY
BENEFICIARIES 56% AND THEIR
COPAYMENTS. RICKLY CMS PAGE
TWENTY MILLION COST SAVINGS
FROM THE MEDICARE PROGRAM FIVE
MILLION AND PATIENT CO PAY COST
SAVINGS IF JUST 5% OF THESE
CARDIOLOGY PROCEDURES SHIFT
TODAY A FEW STATIC. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB THREE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
DOCTOR CARL MAKAYLA. I'M A
BOARD CERTIFIED CARDIOLOGISTS
PROVIDING CARE TO PATIENTS THAT
ARE SACRAMENTO HEART AMATORY
SURGERY CENTER. OUR DISEASE
REMAINS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE NATION MANY OF
THESE DEATHS CAN BE PREVENTED
PATIENTS ARE GIVEN MORE OPTIONS
TO SEE DIAGNOSTIC AND
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS FOR
LOW RISK CARDIAC PROCEDURES IN
THE ASC SETTING. THIS IS
EXACTLY WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED BY
AB THREE SEVENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
THERE'S A 20% DELAYED CARDIAC
CARE TO COPE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ENOUGH PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITIES IF HE COULD HELP
ADDRESS THE BACKLOG AND OFTEN
LONG WAIT TIMES PATIENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING TRYING TO GET INTO
A HOSPITAL CARDIAC
CATHETERIZATION LAB OR CATH LAB.
CURRENTLY I PROVIDE PACEMAKER
IMPLANTATION INTO FOR BELLATOR
IMPLANTATION PROCEDURES SAFELY
IN MY INVENTORY SURGERY CENTER.
IN THESE PROCEDURES SPECIALIZED
WIRES OR LEADS ARE IMPLANTED
DIRECTLY INTO THE HEART MUSCLE.
THROUGH THE PAIN JUST BELOW THE
COLLARBONE. AB THREE SEVENTY
WOULD FURTHER ALLOW
PERCUTANEOUS CORONARY
INTERVENTIONS OR PCI ALSO KNOWN
AS CORONARY ANGIOGRAPHY IN MY
A. S. THE- PCI THE NON SURGICAL
PROCEDURE THAT IMPROVES BLOOD
FLOW TO THE HEART BY USING A
CATHETER. CLEAR NARROWED OR
BLOCKED ARTERIES UNDER AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHTH SEASON
CARDIOLOGISTS LIKE MYSELF WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO ABIDE BY THE
SAME QUALITY STANDARDS AND
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT AS TO THE
CURRENTLY APPROVED TWENTY TWO
HOSPITALS PERFORMING PCI
PROCEDURES IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT SURGICAL BACKUP. LASTLY
EITHER LIFESAVING TREATMENTS
AND INTERVENTIONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIRTY NINE OTHER
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY CAN
PERFORM ON PATIENTS IN THE AFC
SETTING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION HIM FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB THREE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY PRIME PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T WE DON'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED SO. THE
THIRD FACTOR WITH THIS IS THAT
WAS A WITH A PAIN CALIFORNIA
OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
OKAY WITH THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA ABOUT HALF OF THAT
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS-
IN RESPECTFUL- OPPOSING US
AMENDED TO EIGHTY. THREE
SEVENTY IN FIRST RESPOND
RECOGNIZE THE AUTHORS STAFF FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
BILL AND APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
LOOKS A DONE- ALSO JUST WANNA
RECOMMEND TO SHARING A LOT OF
WILL GO BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RANDALL AT TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
CARE. HOWEVER IN OUR NEW EP
THREE SEVENTY BRINGS WITH IT
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS PRIMARILY
THE RICHEST IN THE NATION DUE
TO BOXNATION. CARE REQUIREMENTS.
UNKNOWN COSTS TO THE NEW STATE.
REGULATIONS THEY CONTINUED LACK
OF EVIDENCE OF ACCESS TO CARE
ISSUE PARTICULARLY FOR RURAL
AND UNDERSERVED POPULATION AND
LASTLY CONCERNS ABOUT PATIENT
REFERRALS AND THE POTENTIAL
FOR- FINANCIAL SELF DEALING-
SO. YOU KNOW I WAS THE PREVIOUS
WITNESSES CHAD CARDIAC
CATHETERIZATION EVEN DIAGNOSTIC
ONES ARE IMPORTANT PART OF CARE
HOWEVER THEY ALSO CARRY WITH
THEM SIGNIFICANT RISKS
INCLUDING STROKE HEART ATTACK
UNCONTROLLED BLEEDING AND
KIDNEY FAILURE MANY OF THESE
COMPLICATIONS CAN SHOW UP AFTER
THE PROCEDURE WHILE THE PATIENT
IS RECOVERING. WHEN A PHYSICIAN.
MAY NO LONGER BE OUTSIDE. ASIAN
SAFETY PRIMARY CONCERN HERE FOR
ALLOWING THESE- CENTER SUPPORTS
PRETTY THAT TYPICALLY DONE AND
HOW. WITHOUT THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT SERVICES- NOW
IMPORTANTLY BACK WHILE WE SHARE
THE GOAL THIS GOAL OF IMPROVING
ACCESS TO CARE WE HAVE NOT SEEN
THE EVIDENCE. THAT PATIENTS ARE
BEING DENIED ACCESS TO CARE
YOUR DIAGNOSTIC PROCEDURES AND-
CARDIAC CATH- WE WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR WOULD APPRECIATE SEEING
THAT DATA AND CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR- LOCKED. WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE BUT
THAT FINANCE STUFF DEALING-
ALTHOUGH THERE IS A REQUIREMENT
FOR DISCLOSURE IN OUR VIEW THAT
DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH TO
PREVENT- PATIENTS FROM MAKING
SURE THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS
GETTING THE RIGHT CARE ABOUT
LIKE RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT
CAR- IN. WALL YOU FEEL LIKE
IT'S AN AREA THAT NEEDS TO GO
FURTHER. SO IN SUMMARY OUR
CONCERNS ARE BASED ON PATIENT
SAFETY BLOCK EVIDENCE OF ACCESS
TO CARE AND MOXLEY HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS ARE
GETTING CARE IN A CORPORATE
SETTING ALL TIME- ONCE AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE AUTHORED AND STOP
INTENT AND- APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH A SPONSOR AND CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL- HOWEVER AT
THIS TIME RESPECTFULLY ARE IN
OPPOSING THE- MINUTE THE DISH
AND- FOR THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
TODAY AND. EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
IS THERE A WITNESS IN OFFICE.
HEARING NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE ACTUALLY WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR A- MEMBER
OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC EITHER
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME AND POSITION ONLY BUT
WE DO HAVE A WITNESS IN THE
GALLERY SO ALLOW THE WITNESS IN
THE GALLERY TO. TESTIFY FIRST-
PLEASE- THANK YOU EMILY HUGHES
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO MR
OPPORTUNITY MAY OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WE'RE JUST GOING TO
ASK FOR THE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. IN MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS TO BATON REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICARE'S SHARE
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWO EIGHTY TWO TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER MEMBER
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OUT THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ADVAMED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE TWO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JOHN PENA ON BEHALF OF LOCAL
THAT THE ACCOUNT THAT YOU KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA THE SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMIE MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IT WE HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WHAT YOU DO NOT MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AMULET THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
EXPANDING ACCESS AND OPTIONS
FOR THESE PROCEDURES FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND I LIKE TO BE OUT
OF THE OFFICE. ANYONE ELSE-
THANK YOU I WANNA THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR- FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- HI. I REALLY
LIKE THIS BILL I REALLY LIKE
AMBULATORY SURGERY CENTERS AND
WHAT THEY REPRESENT A
MEANINGFUL COST. REDUCTIONS IN
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY CARE TO
PATIENTS IN AN APPROPRIATE
SETTING AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT- THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION AND- WHEN
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WEAK AND-
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. AND VOTE ON
THE BILL BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE WHEN APPROPRIATE VERY
WELL THANK YOU. SO AS WE
MENTIONED IN OUR- OPENING
COMMENTS WE ARE A LINE OF
MISTER GRAYSON TO PRESENT A. B.
THREE EIGHTY NINE THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN OUT OF ORDER. AND
THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO THE FILE
ORDER- WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SERVICE GRAYSON PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY NINE. WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW A COUNTY TO
CONTRACT FOR EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES. WITH A FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT. AND TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES THREE
BRITONS CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE
AMBULANCE SERVICE. WITHIN MY
DISTRICT IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THE FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
PROVIDES NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES. TO NEARLY
ONE MILLION COUNTY RESIDENTS.
UNDER A LONG TERM EXCLUSIVE
OPERATING CONTRACT WITH THE
COUNTY. UNDER THIS CONTRACT THE
FIRE DISTRICT PROVIDES
AMBULANCE SERVICES. THROUGH A
SUBCONTRACT WITH AMERICAN
MEDICAL RESPONSE WEST A MRO.
THIS PARTNERSHIP IS KNOWN AS
THE FIRE EMS ALLIANCE. SIMPLY
UTILIZATION FOR A COMBINED FIRE
EMS DISPATCH AND COMMUNICATIONS
CENTER MANAGED BY THE FIRE
DISTRICT. THE OVERALL LEVEL AND
EFFICIENCY IN OPERATIONS
CLINICAL QUALITY AND RESPONSE
TIMES HAVE IMPROVED
pEFFECTIVE MODEL HOWEVER FOR THE
PAST FEW YEARS. THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY HAS
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE EMS
SYSTEM REGULATIONS. THAT
ATTEMPT TO PRECLUDE ANY LOCAL
EMS AGENCY FROM UTILIZING A
SUBCONTRACTOR MODEL SIMILAR TO
THE FIRE EMS ALLIANCE. WHICH
WILL WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY
RESTRICT A COUNTIES ABILITY TO
PROVIDE EFFICIENT AND QUALITY
CARE TO ITS RESIDENTS. AB THREE
EIGHTY NINE WILL GUARANTEE THAT
COUNTIES RETAIN THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTRACT FOR EMERGENCY
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES THROUGH
A SUBCONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE
AMBULANCE SERVICE. THIS WILL
ALSO ENSURE THAT THIS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE SUBCONTRACTING MODEL
FOR EMERGENCY EVERYONE'S
DEPLOYMENT SYSTEMS WERE
CONTINUE TO BE A OPTION. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT I AM AWARE OF CONCERNS AND
I HAVE MADE COMMITMENTS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IMPACTED BY AB
THREE EIGHTY NINE THAT MY STAFF
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK. ON
THE BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT WE INCLUDE
AMENDMENTS THAT AL PARTIES CAN
LIVE WITH WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY TWO
WITNESSES. SUPERVISOR DIANE
BURGESS CHAIR OF THE COPS
BECAUSE THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND CHEAP LOUIS
BOUCHARD OF THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR GRAYSON
MISTRUST RATING THEY OPEN THE
LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND THEY MAY GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED WHEN THEY'RE
READY. ONE NUMBER TWO NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M PROVIDED BY AND
FORGET THEN SHARED THE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I'M CALLING IT
TODAY TO OFFER OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB THREE EIGHT NINE
I WILL PRODUCE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON I HOPE AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
UNDERSTAND. THE CHALLENGES IN
THE OBLIGATIONS AND REALLY WHAT
I REALLY THE SACRED DUTY THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES SUCH AS OUR
STATE WITH DELIVERING HIGH
QUALITY AFFORDABLE EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
IT PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY NET
ALWAYS BE A TOP PRIORITY. I
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED THE
WEIGHT WHEN SOMEBODY I LOVE HAD
A LIFE THREATENING MEDICAL
EMERGENCY AND NEEDED AN
AMBULANCE AND I KNOW THOSE
MINUTES BRUSHING EXCRUCIATING
AND GARY CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
ONE AMBULANCE SERVICES TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND IMMEDIATELY FOR
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS WE CANNOT
CONTRACT WE ENTER INTO
AMBULANCE SERVICE. AND WE NEED
TO HAVE OPTIONS THIS BILL IS
ESSENTIALLY ABOUT PROTECTING
AND PRESERVING OPTIONS AND
CHOICES FOR COUNTIES LIKE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO DELIVERING
THESE VITAL SERVICES HERE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WAS CHOSEN
TO CONTACTED OUR LARGEST BUYER
AGENCY. SUBCONTRACTED TO
PRIVATE PROVIDE OUR FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT PROVIDE
NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICE NEARLY ONE
MILLION RESIDENTS UNDER A LONG
TERM CONTRACT WITH THE COUNTY
AND THE COUNTY AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT ENTERED INTO THIS
CONTRACT IN TWENTY FIFTH
NOVEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN. AT THE
CONCLUSION OF A COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS IT WAS
CONDUCTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE EMS ACT AND WAS APPROVED BY
THE NSA SINCE THE COUNTY FIRE
DISTRICT CONTRACT WENT INTO
EFFECT MORE THAN FIVE YEARS AGO
THE PUBLIC HAS SEEN INCREASED
EFFICIENCY IN OPERATIONS. AND
AN IMPROVED RESPONSE IT'S
WORKING FOR OUR FIRE. EMS
ALLIANCE THE NEW HAMPSHIRE
CLINICAL FOLLOW IMPROVEMENT IN
THE NUMBER AND- DEPLOYED TO
IMPROVE OVERALL LEVEL
INEFFICIENCY IN ONE ONE.
EMERGENCY SERVICE. STREAMLINED
COMMUNICATION REPORT. ON THE
PROPERTY FINE IN REDUCE BY ALL
A MINUTE TO A COMBINED
COMMUNITY CENTER MAN BY OUR
DISTRICT JUST THINK ABOUT THAT
KIND LIKE. WHAT IT MEANS
MEDICALLY AND SOME OF THE TWO.
ARTHUR WITH A SYSTEM THAT HAS
REMAINED. AUTHORIZED BYIT
DIFFICULT TO CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THE EFFECTIVE FIRE EMS
A LINE MODEL THAT WE USE IN THE
FUTURE AS WELL AS TO PROVIDE
THAT OPTION EITHER COUNTY FIRE
AGENCIES TO USE THEIR OWN
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE THE PLANE
THAT LED TO DELIVER THE FINAL
SERVICES IN THE WAY THAT WORKS
BEST FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND CAN
WORK FOR OTHERS. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE SUPPORT. OF
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
REPRESENT THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY OUR
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE OPERATIONS
THE ALLIANCE JUST TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE AND
OPERATIONALLY EFFICIENT
AMBULANCE SUBCONTRACTING MODEL.
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
DISCONCERTED OVER ONE MILLION
RESIDENTS THIS MODEL A FIRST OF
ITS KIND IN CALIFORNIA HAS
PROVEN THAT THE COMBINED
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE IN
SERVICE OF THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTORS WHEN BROUGHT
TOGETHER UNDER ONE SYSTEM
BRINGS A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE AND FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY. AND ONE FIRE
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
DURING THE PUBLIC IN THEIR
SEPARATE SILENCE. EIGHT THREE
EIGHTY NINE IS NOW. TO SECURE
THE FUTURE SUBCONTRACTING NOT
ONLY CONTRA COSTA COUNTY BUT AS
AN OPTION FOR OTHER COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THE
DELIVERY OF THEIR EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES. WITH A
MODEL THAT HAS PROVEN ITS VALUE
AND ABILITY TO IMPROVE RESPONSE
TIMES INCREASED DEPLOYMENT OF
AMBULANCE RESOURCES INCREASE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT INTO THE MS
SYSTEM. PARTICIPATE IN
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS TO SHAPE
THE FUTURE OF EMS DELIVERY. AND
CONSISTENTLY EXCEED COMPLIANCE
WITH CONTRACTUAL RESPONSE TIME
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR OVER
FIVE STRAIGHT YEARS THERE
SHOULD BE LITTLE DOUBT THE
SUBCONTRACTING SHOULD BE
SUSTAINED AS A MODEL FOR OUR
COUNTY. AND THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER COUNTIES
AFFECTED TO THEIR NEEDS.
SUBCONTRACTING BEEN. IT IS NO
AN EXPERIMENT. RESPONSE TIMES
ARE REDUCED THROUGH INCREASED
DEPLOYMENT OF AMBULANCES
COUPLED WITH REDUCED NINE ONE
ONE CALL PROCESSING TIMES WHEN
THE FIRE AND EMS DISPATCH
SYSTEMS ARE COMBINED.
COMMUNICATION AND WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS AMONGST THE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTOR FIRST
RESPONDERS IMPROVED CLINICAL
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS CAN
BE JOINED STRENGTHENED. REDUCE
REDUNDANCY IN RESPONSES BETWEEN
FIRE AND EMS RESOURCES CAN BE
ACHIEVED INVESTMENT IN CAPITAL
AND THE ABILITY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INNOVATIVE
DELIVERY SERVICE MODELS
POSSIBLE. ALL THESE ATTRIBUTES
OF A SUCCESSFUL SUBCONTRACTING
MODEL HELP TO IMPROVE SERVICE
TO THE PUBLIC CAN TRANSLATE
INTO SAVING LIVES IN THIS FIELD
AND REATING AN EFFICIENT
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SYSTEM. AS
YOU PART THE MSA HAVE
REPEATEDLY MADE ATTEMPTS TO BAN
THIS DELIVERY MODEL AND
CONTINUES OUR EFFORTS TO THE
CHAPTER THIRTEEN WILL MAKING
PROCESS TODAY. CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY HAVE BEEN UNDER CONSTANT
STATE OF THREAT FROM THE NSA
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CULMINATING IN
THEIR OVER TO TIMES TO PROHIBIT
SUBCONTRACTING TO THEIR CHAPTER
THIRTEEN WILL MAKING PROCESS.
THE REASONS FOR THEIR ACTIONS
HAVE NEVER BEEN MADE CLEAR AB
THREE NINE WILL ENSURE THIS
MODEL CAN CONTINUE AND BE
PURSUED BY OTHER COUNTIES
DESPITE EMSA THE PARENT.
BECAUSE THAT POSITION TO THE
CONTRARY. EIGHT THREE NINE IS
NOT OF. FOR COUNTY TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES WITH THE STOCK. MODEL
IS SOLIDIFIED. THROUGH STATUTE
AS AN OPTION THAT REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR ANY COUNTY TO
CONSIDER AND EVALUATE IN
RELATION TO THEIR NEEDS UNDER
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES. WE NEED
YOUR SUPPORT TO MOVE EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY NINE FORWARD IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE
SUBCONTRACTING OF AN OPTION FOR
THE DELIVERY OF HIGH QUALITY.
FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE IN THE
BUSINESS PROVIDING. SERVICES TO
THE PUBLIC WE NEED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INNOVATE AND TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE F DELIVERY
MODEL THAT ENHANCE OUR ABILITY.
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND GIVE
THEM THE CARE THEY NEED WHEN
THEY NEED IT. WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
SYSTEMS AND SUBCONTRACTING HAS
PROVEN ITSELF AS A VIABLE
OPTION IN THE DELIVERY OF
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB THREE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF WILL GO I MOVE ON
TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTER UPGRADER. I'M NOT
SURE OF ANY ERA ONLINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SCHERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMY SKAGGS
AND I'M THE CHIEF SHOP STEWARD
FOR UNITED EMS WORKERS AFTER A
LOCAL FORTY NINE ELEVEN. I WORK
AS A PARAMEDIC FOR AMERICAN
MEDICAL RESPONSE IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND I'VE BEEN A
PARAMEDIC FOR TWENTY SIX YEARS
AND CONTRA COSTA AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING UNDER THIS A LINE MODEL
FOR THE PAST FIVE PLUS YEARS.
YOU EMS W. AND ASKED ME ARE
OPPOSE TO THIS BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. BUT WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF WORKING WITH DOCTORS
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. TICKLER
LAYER AROUND RETAINING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS.
AND ABILITY TO BARGAIN THE
IMPACT OF UNILATERAL DECISION.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THAT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO STAYING
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS AND
CONTINUING CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY TO
TESTIFY THIS WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE. I WILL
BE ASKING FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. JUST TO STATE THEIR
NAME M. POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION ON THE BILL. AS
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
ROBERTS- ANYWAY YOU'D WISH TO
ADD A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND JUST
SMOKE AT THE LINE.
I NUMBER TWO
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CAN MEMBERS
SANTANGELO ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE OF
THE ADJOINING ARE ASKING
WORKFORCE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE QUEUED UP OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. THIS
WILL. THIS JUST GO AHEAD AND
SPEAK AT THE. WELL PAYING
ATTENTION DISTRICTS. THERE GO
MY LOCAL FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICTS RELY ON BEING ABLE
TO. DO SUB CONTRACTING AND
CONTRACTING OF THE SPECIALLY
AMBULANCE SERVICES- SO YOU KNOW
ANY ATTEMPT BY- THE M. SIDE TO
CHANGE THAT OR NOT ALLOW THEM
TO DO IT WOULD AFFECT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF MY COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM. COMMITTEE
SCENE NUMBER BRING IT BACK-
ACTUALLY DID BRING IT BACK- THE
BILL DOES ENJOY IT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WE CANNOT
ENTERTAIN A MOTION- WE FLIRTED
WITH A QUORUM MULTIPLE TIMES
NOW BUT WE'RE STILL FLIRTING
AND WAITING SO- SO- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER GRACE YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH ALL PARTIES TO MAKE SURE
WE GET A AND A GOOD LANDING
SPOT AND- WITH HAT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU.
BLOWBACK WILL BACK INTO FILE
ORDER NOW TO MISTER RUN THINGS.
WITH AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TODAY I AM PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL. FIFTY SEVEN AND
I WANT TO FIRST START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
BILL. READY TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH ONE IN
FIVE CALIFORNIA WOMEN WHO
RECENTLY GAVE BIRTH EXPERIENCE
SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION DURING
OR AFTER PREGNANCY. THIS MEANS
THAT APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE ISSUES WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
PERINATAL MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
OFTEN REMAIN UNDER DIAGNOSED
AND TREATED AND ALTHOUGH OBGYN
PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED TO
SCREEN FOR MATERNAL DEPRESSION
THERE ARE STILL BARRIERS TO
SCREENING AND REFERRALS. DUE TO
THE SCARCITY OF AVAILABLE
RESOURCES REFERRAL RESOURCES
AND THE NEED FOR COLLABORATIVE
CARE MEETING PATIENTS WHERE
THEY ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE
SUCCESS. FOR SCREENING
MANAGEMENT AND APPROPRIATE
TIMELY REFERRALS A PERINATAL
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN ON ITS INTERNET WEB
SITE REFERRAL NETWORK A
COMMUNITY BASED MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND SUPPORT
SERVICES OF ALSO INCREASED
PATIENT DRIVEN ACCESS TO CARE.
IT WILL HELP CLOSE THE
SIGNIFICANT ACCESS GAP FACED BY
MOTHERS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND RURAL COMMUNITIES BY
STRENGTHENING OUR MATERNAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO IMPROVE ITS
CAPACITY FOR ACCESS TO
FACILITATE REFERRALS FOR
TREATMENT AND SUPPORT SERVICES.
THIS BILL WILL MEET THE PUBLIC
HEALTH NEEDS OF WOMEN SEEKING
MATERNAL HEALTH SERVICES BY
PROVIDING CENTRALIZED
COLLABORATIVE RESOURCES IN
IMPROVING ACCESS TO CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND WELL TRAINED
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
REDUCE RACIAL DISPARITIES. THIS
BILL WILL HELP MAKE IMPORTANT
PROGRESS TOWARD ENSURING THAT
WOMAN WITH MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS AND IN NEED OF
A PERINATAL SERVICES RETREAT
RECEIVE THE TREATMENT THAT
THEY- SO RIGHTFULLY DESERVE. DR
ABELLANA MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS AND A PRACTICING
SPECIALIST AND UP UP TO- SKEWS
ME THAT OBG RAN FOR THE PAST
NINETEEN YEARS CAN CLARIFY ANY
COMMITTEE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TODAY. AS IN HER STATEMENT SHE
IS AVAILABLE AT ANY MOMENT
COLLEAGUES I DO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES- WE
NOTE THAT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO
WILL LAST THE- OPERATOR IN
THERE ARE NONE IN REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WELL AS THE
OPERATOR TO PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR. A PUBLIC COMMENT- IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THE BILL
AND WILL JUST BE ASKING FOR
YOUR NAME- ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISREPRESENT.
I'M NOT. I
NOTHING ANY WITNESSES OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
UNTIL YOU HAVE A CHILD YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH IS GOING TO BE AND YOU
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE AS
STRONG AS ANYONE COULD. BE THE
STRONGEST PERSON EVER. AND IT'S
REALLY HEART WRENCHING WHEN
SOMEBODY THAT YOU'VE HEARD.
THIS COMMITTED SUICIDE OR HAS
HAD SOME DIFFICULTIES WITH THE
NEW NEW BOARD. SO I WANT TO I
WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE I
THINK WE DO NEED A CENTRAL
PLACE FOR FAMILIES TO- I HAVE
GOT SOME NEW COULD THEY CAN
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES- I
REALLY LIKE YOUR BILL I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. AND I'D
LIKE TO COOPER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WELL- ARE QUORUM
SITUATION HASN'T CHANGED MUCH
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THAT- THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION SO
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM AND HAVE
A MOTION WILL VOTE ON THE BILL-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER ABOUT
THIS. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND HAPPY TO ADDRESS
SOMEBODY MEMBER CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY TO OUR- OUR LIST
OF- CO AUTHORS APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT
AND FOR AGAIN RESPECTFULLY I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. GREAT THANK YOU-
WE ARE WAITING FOR AUTHORS-
SAYING IT WOULD YOU BE READY TO
DO YOUR BILL THE SECRETARY. I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER AUTHORS WE
WOULD GO TO A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS YOUR CURRY TO
PRESENT AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE YOU
COULD DO IT FROM YOUR DESK
THERE. MEMBERS AB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE. ESTABLISHES A CLEAR
GUIDELINES FOR WHEN ALL OF OIL
PRODUCERS CAN USE THE TERM.
CALIFORNIA IN THEIR LABELING.
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS EXISTING
LAW BY PROHIBITING THE
REPRESENTATION THAT IN ALL OF
OIL IS MADE ENTIRELY FROM
CALIFORNIA ALL OF THE LIST THAT
IS TRUE. EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS
THE USE OF THE TERM CALIFORNIA
ALL OF WORLD ON A LABEL ON THE
FIFTH ALL OF WILL IS A 100%
FROM CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER IF YOU
USE A LABEL THE SAYS CALIFORNIA
ALL OF FORM FOR CALIFORNIA
OLIVE RANCH OR ANYTHING THAT
INCLUDES CALIFORNIA. AND ALL OF
THIS BUT NOT OIL. YOU ARE
TECHNICALLY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LANGUAGE OF THE CURRENT
LAW. BUT DEFINITELY NOT THE
SPIRIT OF THE LAW. IF EITHER
NAME INCLUDED THE WORD OIL IT
WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION. THIS IS WHAT IS
WHAT E KNOW AS A LOOPHOLE THIS
LAW HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS SINCE
THE MID NINETIES. THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL DID NOT
ORIGINALLY INTEND TO DECEIVE.
BECAUSE THEY ALL STARTED BY
PRODUCING HOW 2% CALIFORNIA ALL
OF WELL. IF THE INTENTIONAL
DECISION OF THESE COMPANIES TO
CREATE THE LOOPHOLE THE FLOOD
TO MY BILL. JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO MY OPPONENTS PRODUCED A
PRODUCT WITH A 100% CALIFORNIA
ALL OF POLYPS. THAT PRODUCT WAS
CHANGED SHORTLY AFTER TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WERE
INVESTED BY AN EAST COAST AND
DOWN WITH. I FELT I FULLY
SUPPORT THEIR RIGHT TO PRODUCE
A PRODUCT AS THEY CHOOSE. BUT
USING CALIFORNIA ON A LABEL
WITH THE BLEND USING AS LOW AS
14% OF THE CALIFORNIA FALLS IS
NOT A FAIR REPRESENTATION OF
THE PRODUCT. AND BY THE WAY
THAT NUMBER COMES DIRECTLY FROM
THEM. WELL THEY DISCLOSE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW THE
PRODUCT IS BLENDED MOST
CONSUMERS ARE NOT AWARE.
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS NOT EXCUSE
ME CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS ONLY
APPLY 21100% CALIFORNIA OLIVE
OIL. THE USE OF THE TERM IS NOT
AN INNOCENT MARKETING OF A
BRAND IT DECEIVES THOSE WHO
THINK THEY'RE GETTING A 100%
CALIFORNIA OIL. WITH ALL THE
STANDARDS WE MAKE OUR FARMERS
LEVINE. THIS INACCURATE
LABELING HAS NOT ONLY CAUSED
CONSUMER CONFUSION BUT IT ALSO
LED TO A DEPRESSION IN THE
PRICE OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF OIL.
IN PLACE CALIFORNIA GROWERS AT
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE. IN
FACT I'VE HEARD FROM OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SMALL GROWERS EMPLOYEES
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
ASKING TO CLARIFY THE
CALIFORNIA BRED FOR THIS REASON.
AND WHILE THIS PRACTICE
CONCERNS ME WHAT CONCERNS ME
MORE IS THIS RECENT DEVELOPMENT
IS A HUGE INCENTIVE FOR OTHER
COMPANIES AND COUNTRIES TO DO
THE SAME THING. AND SOME HAVE.
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE DOES NOT
REINVENT THE WHEEL FOR
CLARIFYING THE STANDARD OF WHAT
SHOULD BE PROPERLY- CALIFORNIA
BRANDED. THIS BILL TIGHTENS
EXISTING LAW THAT HAS BEEN ON
THE BOOKS FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES. IT'S MODELED AFTER
APPELLATIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
WINE INDUSTRY. EFFORT
ORIGINALLY OPPOSED AS THE DEATH
KNELL FOR THE NON NAPA AND
SONOMA COUNTY. HIS BIGGEST
CINEMA CALIFORNIA WINE
INDUSTRY. FOR ONE WHICH IS
FOSTERED THE INTERNATIONAL
KNOWLEDGE EMIT A WARNING
QUALITY WINES FROM SUCH PLACES
OF CLARKSBURG LODI INTO MACULA.
BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD TO HAVE THE HIGHEST
ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR AND
CONSUMER STANDARDS IN THE WORLD.
CONSUMERS LOOK FOR CALIFORNIA
AG PRODUCTS BECAUSE THEY
ASSOCIATE CALIFORNIA WITH
QUALITY AND SAFETY.
ESTABLISHING STRONGER LABELING
GUIDELINES FOR ALL OF OIL
PRODUCERS AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
WILL ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
BRAND IS PROTECTED IN CONSUMERS
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE BUYING.
PASSING AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
WILL PREVENT FOR CALIFORNIA
BEST FROM BEING UNDERCUT BY
BUSINESSES THAT MISREPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA NAME. AS A
FARMER I HOPE TO PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA NAY AND FELLOW
GROWERS I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME
IN DOING THE SAME. TODAY I HAVE
A HOPE- TWO PEOPLE TO TESTIFY
SAMANTHA DORSEY. YEAH CAROLINE
BEALE HUNTER. THANK YOU WE
WILL- WILL HOLD OFF ON OUR
WITNESSES BECAUSE WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND LIKE THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT HERE. MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW BONTA
BURKE. CARILLO LARA MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN. TO RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE ARE POOR
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO THANK YOU
AND NOW WILL GO- MISTER ROBERT
OR WE CAN GO TO OUR- PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MOTION BY. MISTER
NAZARIAN SECOND BY MR MCCARTY.
SO GO AHEAD WITH THEIR
WITNESSES PLEASE. CAN YOU
HANDLE. OKAY ONE COME OUT OF
HER. MATADORS HERE PRESIDENT OF
MCEVOY RANCH. PLEASE GO AHEAD
MISTER CHAIRMAN PROCEED GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WAS
AGUIAR-CURRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND SAMANTHA.
PRESIDENT MCEVOY RANCH AS WITH
AGUIAR-CURRY JUST SAID THE BILL
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU IT ISN'T
GROUNDBREAKING. IT DOESN'T
ATTEND OR REVERSE ANY CURRENT
LAW AND IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
REALLY THAT CONTROVERSIAL.
EIGHTY FIVE THREE FIVE SIMPLY
STRENGTHENS THE CURRENT LAW AND
ALLOWS THE OLIVE OIL INDUSTRY
TO CATCH UP TO THE REGULATIONS
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE SET IN PLACE
TO PROTECT TRUTH IN LABELING.
IN THE WINE INDUSTRY OVER TEN
YEARS AGO. ELECTION EXCUSE ME
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE WINE
INDUSTRY WERE BOTH AWARE OF-
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES THAT
OCCURRED WHEN SPECIFIC HIGH
VALUE REGIONAL NAMES ARE BEING
USED ON PRODUCT LABELS THAT
DIDN'T ORIGINATE FROM THOSE
EGIONS. AND NOW THE SAME
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES ARE BEING
USED IN ALL OF OIL AND THESE
COMPANIES ARE USING THE
ILLUSTRIOUS REPUTATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA IN NAPA VALLEY ON
THE ROLE OF OIL LABELS EVEN
THOUGH THE OIL INSIDE THE
BOTTLE. DOESN'T ORIGINATE FROM
THOSE REGIONS. SO THE EXTRA
VIRGIN OLIVE OIL THAT WE
PRODUCE AND- ACTIVELY RANCH
LIMON. WIFE WORKED FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS IT'S SUBJECT TO
AGRICULTURAL AND PRODUCTION
REGULATIONS. THAT ARE MUCH MORE
EXACTING THAN THE REGULATIONS
FOR PRODUCERS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES AND OF LEGISLATORS.
YOU GUYS HAVE DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB. OF SETTING THE BAR
HIGH WITH LABOR STANDARDS
EMISSION REGULATIONS WATER
USAGE CONTROLS FOOD QUALITY
STANDARDS INSPECTIONS. PAYROLL
TAXES QUITMAN TAXES- PROPERTY
TAXES. AND I COMMEND YOU GUYS
I'M ACTUALLY REALLY THRILLED
AND GRATEFUL THAT YOU'VE
ENACTED ALL THESE POLICIES
BECAUSE I REALLY LIKE LIVING IN
OUR STATE AND I LIKE TAKING
GOOD CARE OF OUR LABOR FORCE.
IN OUR LAND. BUT TO BE
COMPLIANT IN CALIFORNIA I HAVE
TO CHARGE A PREMIUM PRICE FOR
MY PRODUCT. BECAUSE IT'S
PRODUCED IN A PREMIUM REGION.
AND SO IT'S SUPER DISRUPTIVE TO
MY BUSINESS AND EVERY OTHER
REAL CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH OIL
PRODUCER. WHEN WE HAVE TO
COMPETE AGAINST THE FOREIGN OIL
THAT IS PRODUCED WITH FEWER
REGULATIONS. AT A SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER COST STRUCTURE. BUT THEN
AS BRAZENLY LABELED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NAME OR THE NAPA
VALLEY NAMES. NONE OF US ARE
OBJECTING TO IMPORTED OLIVE OIL
I HAVE NO DESIRE TO RESTRICT
THE FREE TRADE OF ALL OF OIL.
I'M JUST ASKING THAT THE THAT
THE LABEL IS ACCURATE SO. AS I
MENTIONED AT THE START THIS
ISN'T UNUSUAL OR
GROUNDBREAKING. LEGISLATION IT
JUST BRINGS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE UP TO DATE THE SAME
PARAMETERS THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
ALREADY PUT IN PLACE. FOR OTHER
FOOD INDUSTRIES. SO THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FOR AB FIVE
THREE FIVE. THANK YOU- WE
THERE'S A SECOND WITNESS. YES
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WHAT A
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE TODAY MY NAME IS CAROLYN
BIEL HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE-
TODAY HE WENT TO NATION A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE IN
YOLO COUNTY AND COSPONSORED AB
FIVE THREE FIVE ALL OF OIL
LATELY. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
YO TODAY HE OPENED UP A SMALL
BINGO HALL WHICH IS SIX
TRANSFORM IN TO WHAT IS NOW
KNOWN AS CACHE CREEK CASINO
RESORT. IN THE TRI IS WORKED.
MISLEAD AND WHAT WE'RE ONCE
THEY TRY WITHOUT BASICALLY.
LIKE WATER INTO. IS NOW I
THOUGHT TO WORK OF THEIR AND-
LAND. GROWING A Y. VARIETY OF
CAREFULLY CROP. ONE OF WHICH IS
ALL OF TREES. THE TRIBE OF
MIDDLE NAME FACT HILLS THE ROLE
BLUE HILL IT IS. BY IS HIGHLY
WORLD. MOST RECENTLY A AWARD AT
THE TWENTY TWENTY NEW YORK.
INTERNATIONAL OLIVE OIL
COMPETITION. I THE TRIBE OF THE
PRODUCER OF ALL OIL MAY BY LAW
100% GROWN ALL OF AND MAKES ALL
DIFFERENCE. A FEW DETAILS MAKE
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL UNIQUE
INVEST OUR THE CLIMATE THE
UNIQUE MEDITERRANEAN LIKE
CLIMATE MAKES THE REGION AN
IDEAL PLACE TO GROW OLIVE
TREES. AND THE TRIBE HAS
INVESTED A LOT OF TIME AND
RESOURCES INTO BUILDING A STATE
OF THE ART ALL OF MAIL TO SERVE
GROWERS IN THE REGION. NEXT
TECHNIQUE AT SECOND HILL TO TRY
TO USE THE MOST MODERN GROWING
AND HARVESTING TECHNIQUES SUCH
AS MECHANIZED HARVESTERS.
MEDIUM DENSITY VARIETY GIVING
ALL OF GIVING CUSTOMERS MORE
FLAVOR PROFILE TO ENJOY. AND
FINALLY LOCATION SECOND HILDA
STRATEGICALLY LOCATED. IT'S
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE LOCAL
ORCHARD ENABLE ALL OF TO BE
MAILED IMMEDIATELY AFTER HARPER
TO PRESERVE THE FRESHNESS
NEEDED TO PRODUCE A HIGH
QUALITY VIRGIN OLIVE OIL. THIS
ATTENTION TO DETAIL MATTERS.
OBVIOUSLY AN APPEAL TO MAKE
CHEAPER IMPORTED OILS WITH SOME
CALIFORNIA OIL TO USE THE
GOLDEN STATE'S REPUTATION BY
PLACING IT ON THE LOCAL TO
IMPROVE PROFIT MARGINS. BUT IT
IS UNETHICAL AND UNSAFE TO PULL
CONSUMERS JUST WAIT AND UNFAIR
TO PRODUCERS LIKE TO TRY. TO
PUT IN THE EXTRA TIME EFFORT
AND RESOURCES TO PRODUCE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL.
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE PROTECTS
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL. FIVE
YEARS AGO YOUR TD HE WORKED
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER WALKED
TO ESTABLISH LABELING
REGULATIONS IN EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE FIFTY CLARIFIES
WHAT THE BILL ORIGINALLY
INTENDED TO DO. ACCURATELY
LABEL CALIFORNIA GROWN OLIVE
OIL I URGE YEARS I VOTE FOR A
BI FIVE THIRTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO
A- OR SAY WE HAVE SOME IN THE
CASE. THE WILL THAT THE GALA GO
FIRST AND THEN WE'LL HAVE THE
KIND OF THE ONE ON THE- SO GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR- HELLO. YOU'RE
A I HAVE BEEN HEARING YES GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NAME IS A FONG AND I'M
THE CEO OF HEALTH. ALL OF RANCH
THE. VIRGIN OLIVE OIL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM AS FIFTY
FAMILY FARMERS ACROSS THE STATE
OUR COMPANY ACCOUNTS FOR ALMOST
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S ANNUAL ALL
OF WILL PRODUCTION. OUR
NAMESAKE BRAND IS THE NUMBER
ONE BRAND OF 100% EXTRA VIRGIN
OLIVE OIL IN THE UNITED STATES
RETAIL MARKET. WE'RE ALSO
QUANTIFIABLE HE ONE OF THE
STRONGEST IF NOT THE STRONGEST
BRANDS. IN THE MARKET AND I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT OUR
COMPANY IS A PIONEER IN INTO
INTRODUCING INNOVATIVE FARMING
PRACTICES THAT HELP BRING HIGH
QUALITY. CALIFORNIA GROWN OLIVE
OIL THE US CONSUMERS HAVE AN
ACCESSIBLE PRICE POINT. OF THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS WE'VE
INVESTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN OUR FARMING OPERATIONS AND
OUR BRAND AND ARE NOW SOLD IN
OVER TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
STORES ACROSS AMERICA. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO HELP US
BETTER MANAGE FLUCTUATIONS IN A
PRODUCT SUPPLY. WE LAUNCH NEW
NEWLINE BLENDED WITH ARC THAT
BLENDER CALIFORNIA ALL OF OIL
WITH HIGH QUALITY OLIVE OIL
FROM. HER PARTNERS IN ARGENTINA
PORTUGAL AND CHILE. TODAY THIS
LIKE COMPLIMENTS OUR FLAGSHIP
PRODUCTS THAT CALIFORNIA LINES
AS WELL AS A CULINARY LINES OF
ALL OF THE LOAN VEGETABLE OIL
BLENDS. ACCURATELY LABELED ALL
AVAILABLE WITH WHEELS FOR
MULTIPLE REGIONS OR OTHER
VEGETABLE OILS IS A COMMON
PRACTICE IN OUR INDUSTRY AND IS
ALLOWED UNDER CURRENT FEDERAL
AND STATE LAWS. SUPPORTERS OF
AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE ARGUE THAT
NEW LAWS ARE NEEDED BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE CONSUMERS ARE
QUOTE. BEING TRICKED BY
PRODUCTS LIKE OUR GLOBAL PLAN
SINCE OUR TWENTY THREE ALL
TRADEMARK. HAS A WORD
CALIFORNIA AND IT. FURTHER THEY
ARGUE THE LOWER PRICE OF OUR
GLOBAL BY MINUS DEPRESSING THE
VALUE OF A 100% CALIFORNIA
MARKET. AND MAKING IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO COMPETE. THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT TRUE IN HERE THE
FACTS. FIRST OUR LABELS DO NOT
CONFUSE CONSUMERS. WE WORK HARD
TO DIFFERENTIATE OUR LINES
CALLING UP THE COUNTRIES OF
ORIGIN ON THE FRONT OF OUR
LABELS IN LARGE FONTS WE ALSO
HAVE A GLOBAL PLAN CALL OUT. ON
THE FRONT OF OUR LABELS. AN
INDEPENDENT CONSUMER RESEARCH
TEST 90% OF CONSUMERS COULD
TELL THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR
HOW TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA LINE.
AND OUR GLOBAL LAND. ANY CLAIM
BY SUPPORTERS OF THE OF THIS
BILL THAT OUR COMPANIES TRYING
TO TRICK PEOPLE IS OFFENSIVE TO
ME IN OUR COMPANY. SECOND THE
AVERAGE PRICE OF A 100%
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL ARE UP
SINCE THE LAUNCH OF OUR GLOBAL
PLAN. IN THE TWO YEARS TO
LAUNCH A GLOBAL BRAND OUR NEW
PRICING STRATEGIES AND HELP
DRIVE THE AVERAGE PRICE PER
LITRE A 100% CALIFORNIA ITEMS
UP 28% THIRD THE 100% OF THE
MARKET IS THRIVING SINCE THE
LAUNCH OF GLOBAL PLANT. TODAY
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS
ARE SELLING A HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE PERCENT. MORE LEADERS AN
AGGREGATE THAT THEY DIDN'T
EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN. WITH A
GLOBAL PLAN LAUNCHED. R. OLIVE
OIL IS THE HIGHEST QUALITY IN
OUR LABELS ARE TRUTHFUL AND
MORE TRANSPARENT THAN ANY
BLENDED ALL WILL TODAY. AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE WILL VIOLATE OUR
COMMERCIAL SPEECH RIGHTS AND
THE RIGHTS OF OTHER
LONGSTANDING BRANDS WITH
WILLIAM SANOMA. BY LIMITING THE
USE OF OUR VALUABLE TRADEMARKS.
FURTHER ANY ARGUMENT THAT THIS
IS COMPATIBLE LEVINE LAWS
AROUND THE USE OF THE WORD
NAPA. IN A TRADEMARK FAILS TO
CONSIDER. FEDERAL PREEMPTION
EXISTING FOOD LAW THE COULD
OVERRULE A STATE MEASURE LIKE
THIS. WE SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY
IN LABELING. BUT CANNOT SUPPORT
MEASURES THAT SEEK TO PENALIZE
OURS IN OUR GROWTH YEARS
INVESTMENT IN OUR BRAND SIMPLY
BECAUSE OUR COMPETITORS. HAVE A
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENT WITH
A BUSINESS STRATEGY. IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS THAT I OPPOSE
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE AND ASK
FOR NO VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OVER TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
OUR SECOND WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YEAH MY NAME
IS DAN KENNEDY MY WIFE LISA AND
I- COMMITTEE RANTS PARTNERSHIP.
I'VE BEEN A GROWTH PARTNER
CALIFORNIA. OLIVE RANCH.
THOUSAND AND- CAN I GROW RIGHT
WALLACE AND OUR FOUR OR AND
PLAN AND TWENTY AREA I AM ALSO
HERE IS A MAN OF THE COUNTY
BUREAU REPRESENTING THEIR EIGHT
FARMS AND WE FAMILY WHERE WE
OPPOSE PAID P. THIRTY FIVE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE WORKING
PROTECT. AND BENEFIT OUR
MEMBERS OUR GOAL TO INCREASE
RETURN IN FIVE. OF OUR PRIME
FAMILY. THE COW ALL THE WORLD
IS. ALL NATURE LOVERS ARE STILL
SOLICITING PROGRAMS TO A THE
GROWING. WE NEED A CREDIT MARK.
DETAILS NEW CAN THE NEW MORE.
WE OPPOSE AB THIRTY FIVE
CURRENTLY DROPPED. AB THIRTY
FIVE FOUR WEEKS HONEST AND FAIR.
AND THEN FAIRLY THE TRADEMARK
BRANDING AND OLIVER OKAY
COMPANY IS. CAN YOU. CALIFORNIA
RANCH'S A TRADING BRANDING THE
COMPANY IS USING FOR OVER
TWENTY TWO YEAR. AT THE PAR
PARTNER OF. ALI FOR WE SUPPORT
THERE'S FOR ALL LINE. INCLUDING
THE GLOBAL PLAN. WE LIKE TO
THEY'RE FINDING MARKETS FOR.
ALL OIL SEARCH'S CIRCLE LAW.
CHEAT ALIGN AND WITH ALMOND AND
ARGAN OIL. AS A GROWER OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE HAS BEEN THE
FACT THAT ALWAYS ARE ALL
BEARING WHICH MAY IT HARD FOR
MARK ARE. ON I CAN LEVEL
WITHOUT BRING IN THE OTHER TO
HELP SET UP BY HERE. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE. I WOULD NOT FIND
A CURRENT WITH THE COMPANY I TO
WAS TRAINED. TO DECEIVE THE
CONSUMER- CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
ELEVATE TO HELP OUR FARMERS AND
PROCESSORS INCREASE THERE WE-
THE LINE IS THE COW OLIVE RANCH.
THIS TRIMS. AND THEY ARE ABLE
TO SELL BLENDED CALIFORNIA
OLIVE OIL TO CONSUMERS WE HAVE
NOT PREVIOUSLY ATTRACTED AND
ALL THOSE WHO BENEFITING ALL.
THESE THREE THINGS. THE
PHARMACY PARTNERS WITH CORE IN
THE MEMBERS CLAIM CAL FARM
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE OPERATOR FOR WILL TAKE-
PUBLIC COMMENT- FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL JUST THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTER OPERATOR- WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER TO NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY OUR- A
LINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTEEN. THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
I THINK MY NUMBER THREE THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE IN. MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON THAT THE ONLY MAC
MILLER AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ORDERS IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- MR BIGELOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND QUESTIONS TO
THE AUTHOR PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU- IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S A LOT OF AGREEMENT ON
BOTH SIDES. WITH RESPECT TO
THIS THEY ALL WANT TO PROTECT.
THE BRAND THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE CALIFORNIA IS TRULY BEING
CALIFORNIA OIL. THE REAL ISSUE
COMES DOWN TO THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT TRADEMARK AND THERE'S ONE
THAT HAS. IN PARTICULAR THAT
HAS A TRADEMARK NAME AND IT
MAKES IT REAL CHALLENGING SO
THE REALITY IS IT COMES DOWN TO.
FOR THE QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
HOW DOES YOUR BILL PLAN TO GET
AROUND THE PREEMPTION OF THE
FEDERAL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION FOR LABOR WITH.
AND THE FEDERAL TRADEMARK
PROTECTIONS. THAT ARE GRANTED
TO THAT. BUSINESS. THANK YOU-
FRAZIER WOULD YOU HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS MAYBE I CAN DO IN MY
IN MY CLOTHES AS WELL. IF I
HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS SO. ALL
RESPECT THAT INTERNAL WORK WITH
THAT- IF WE LOOK DAD MAYBE SOME
OF THE CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MODEL LIST SIMILAR TO
LET'S SAY THE NAPA MODEL WHERE
THE WINE INDUSTRY. REGULATED
ITSELF TO MAKE SURE THAT IT HAD.
AT LEAST A MINIMUM PERCENTAGE
OF. ORIGIN FROM CALIFORNIA FOR
A REGIONAL AREA SUCH AS IT IS
TODAY WITH 85% THAT'S WHAT
YOU'VE MODEL HERE IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT- WHAT
THE DIFFICULTY IS WITH WINE
WINE IS PROTECTED UNDER THE
TWENTY FIRST AMENDMENT TO THE
CONSTITUTION BUT OLIVE OIL IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE IT'S IN FACT
IT WOULD EVEN BE IN THIS
COMMITTEE IF IT WAS WHITE IT
WOULD BE SOMEPLACE ELSE BUT
BECAUSE THIS IS A FOOD AND
THERE ARE FEDERAL LAWS
REGULATING FOOD LABELING HOW DO
YOU PROPOSE. THAT THIS BILL
AVOID. THE VERY REGULATIONS
IT'S GOING TO NOW BE CHARGED
WITH VIOLATING. THE COUPLE OF
THE THINGS THAT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR IS THAT- THE
CALIFORNIA- FORMS- CALIFORNIA
OIL. THEY LAUNCH THEIR NEW LINE
WITH BALLOONS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AND THEY COMPILE AND-
THEY COMPLIED WITH A HUNDRED
PERCENT- REQUIREMENT BEFORE
THEN. THEY WERE PURCHASED BY
ENDOWMENT AND SO THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN DOING THIS FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS JUST FOR STARTERS.
THEY LEAD THE WAY ON CREATING
CALIFORNIA BRAND WE NEED TO
GIVE THEM A GOOD THEY DID A
GREAT THING UNFORTUNATE ALL
THEY'VE BEEN THEY'VE NOW LEAD
THE WAY TO GO AROUND IT. AND
THAT'S WHERE MY CONCERN IS WITH
THIS. THEY WERE DOING THE RIGHT
THING THE LABELING WAS FINE AT
THAT TIME AND THEN NOW IT'S NOT
THE LABELING IT WAS THE PRODUCT
THE CHANGE IN THE PRODUCT
CHANGE FROM 1100% ALL
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL. TO A
BLEND. AND THAT'S WHERE BUT
THAT'S WHAT THE ISSUE IS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- ANSWER I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALL
FIND. DIFFICULT HERE BECAUSE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT
ARE REALLY BEFORE US MISTER
CHAIRMAN. WHEN WE START TALKING
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES. IT GETS
INTO THE CHALLENGES OF DO WE
WANT TO TAKE ON OTHER THINGS TO
SAY CALIFORNIA. BY CALIFORNIA
PIZZA. DO WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
OTHER IN THE ENTITIES THAT.
ANDERSON VALLEY- BREWERY WERE
PICKING UPON REGIONAL AREAS.
THIS GETS REALLY DOWN PRETTY
WEEDY AND DIFFICULT FOR US TO
REGULATE BECAUSE IT OPENS A
SLIPPERY SLOPE TO A LOT OF
ISSUES. IN THE STATE. I THINK
IN RESPECT FOR THE TWO PARTIES
HERE THERE'S STILL ROOM FOR US
TO HAVE THEM COME TOGETHER AND
WORK ON AN ANSWER. OF
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF- TEAK.
OIL PRODUCERS IN THIS STATE AND
THEY'RE BLENDING. THE QUESTION
IS HOW DO THEY PLAN AND USE THE
WORD CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S MY
REAL CONCERN BECAUSE I THINK
THE TRADEMARK. IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE THAT I
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE THE COMPROMISING
SITUATION BECAUSE ACROSS THE
LINE INTO PROTECTIONS UNDER THE
FEDERAL LAW SO I THINK THIS
BILL IS A LITTLE BIT PREMATURE
AND IT'S WORKING BECAUSE AS THE
AUTHOR JUST ADDRESSED. TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF BRINGING
DIFFERENT BLAND'S FORD. THEY'VE
ACTUALLY ALREADY COVERED AND
STAYED WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF
THIS WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO
DO OR WHAT THE AUTHORS TRYING
TO DO YOU SEE IT ALL LABELS ON
EVERY BOTTLE. THAT'S PRESENTED.
SO IT'S ALREADY IDENTIFIED SO
THEY'RE MEETING THE NEEDS SO
NOW COMES DOWN TO REALLY.
SOMEONE OR SOMEONES ARE
CONTESTING THE USE OF THE NAME.
CALIFORNIA RANCH. CALIFORNIA
OLIVE RANCH CALIFORNIA FARM
SOMEBODY'S REALLY JUST TRYING
TO ADDRESS. THAT TRADEMARK NAME
THAT'S WHAT THIS DEBATE IS
REALLY ABOUT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE LABELING. IS BIG
PEOPLE FIGHTING EACH OTHER. I
DON'T THINK THIS BILL I'M SORRY
I RESPECT THE AUTHOR AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT SHE'S TRYING TO
DO HERE BUT I THINK IT'S
PREMATURE FOR US TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND MOVE IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU. YOU CAN RESPOND SO LET'S
REMEMBER THAT- THIS IS ALREADY
EXISTING LAW THAT REQUIRES THAT
ALL OF THE OIL LABELED WITH
TERM CALIFORNIA MUST CONSIST OF
A 100% CALIFORNIA GROWN FOLLOWS
AND SO THAT'S BEEN THERE- FOR
YEARS AND SO THERE'S NOTHING
THAT THIS CHANGE HERE- I DO AND
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT IF YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TO GO ON AMAZON
THE NEW WORLD CUP OLIVE OIL AND
YOU SEE THIS BRAND. PEOPLE
ACCIDENTALLY GET THE WRONG ONE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T READ THE-
THE LABEL ON THE- SO I YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM BUT I GOTTA TELL
YOU IS THAT WE HAVE PUT. OUR
CALIFORNIA FARMERS ARE HELD TO
SOME OF THE HIGHEST.
ENVIRONMENTALLY QUALITY
STANDARDS IN THE NATION AND
THEY GIVE THEY DEPEND ON US
GETTING ON GETTING PREMIUM
PRICE. FOR A PREMIUM PRODUCT.
AND I'M JUST GOING TO ALWAYS
FIGHT FOR MY FARMERS AND I'M
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT. WE
CONTINUE IN USE THAT HERE. WE
CONTINUE TO BEAT HIM UP. AND
I'M NOT GOING TO BEAT HIM UP
AND I WANT THEM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND THE CALIFORNIA
BRAND TO CONTINUE TO BE IS
KNOWN. THROUGHOUT THE NATION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. IN THE NUMBER. THANK
YOU- MR MACE. IT I THINK INTO
IT TO THE AUTHOR WHEN USED IN
YOUR OPENING YOU UP AND I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S CLEAR I'M LOOKING
IN THE ANALYSIS NOW THAT UNDER
EXISTING LAW- BEFORE THIS THAT-
BED YOU CAN'T SAY YOU'RE
CALIFORNIA ALL OF OIL- AND THAT
IF THE CURRENT. BRAND NAME WAS
CALIFORNIA ALL OF OIL BRANCH
FOR INSTANCE THAT WOULD ALREADY
BE- WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
ILLEGAL TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
UNDER EXISTING LAW DID I HEAR
THAT CORRECTLY. SO WHEN BUT IN
THE PAST AS I SAID THEY HAD
GOTTEN THEY WERE CALIFORNIA ALL
OF OIL THEY WERE A HUNDRED
PERCENT. THEY WERE PURCHASED.
WHEN THEY'RE PURCHASED. THE NEW
OWNERS- CONTINUE TO USE THE
LABEL AND THEY HAVE OTHER
BLENDED PRODUCT I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE PRODUCT THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY FINE. WHEN YOU MIL
ALL OF WALES IN CALIFORNIA IT
IS AN ART IT IS AN ART AND
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING IT
OUR FARMERS AND OUR MIDDLE
MIDDLE PEOPLE- HAVE HIGH
QUALITY EQUIPMENT. AND WE HAVE
TO I THINK WE SHOULD HONOR THAT
SO WHERE I'MGOING WITH THIS IS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REALIZE THAT ADDITIONALLY THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT THEY HAD THE
WHEN THEY ARE PURCHASED BY
SOMEONE ELSE I FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE UNDERMINE OUR FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA ALL FARMERS. OKAY I
AM- I HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION
LAST WEEK WITH THAT THE COMPANY
IN QUESTION. I ACTUALLY WENT
THROUGH THEIR LABELING- AND- I
THINK OF ANYBODY THAT LOOKED AT
AND I THINK THEY'VE COME A LONG
WAY IN MAKING SURE THAT TO
SEPARATE- THE CALIFORNIA. BRAND
TO THE OTHER BLENDED FROM UP
FROM- THAT WITH OILS THAT ARE
THAT ARE GLOBAL I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS- TODAY AND IN MY
LINE OF THINKING FOR SUPPORTING
IT TODAY. IS THAT IF WE COULD
GO BACK ON THEM IT TABULAR ROSS
SAID IF WE KNEW. IN THE FUTURE-
WHAT WHAT WHAT DID THE MARKET
PLACE WAS GOING TO LOOK LIKE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA. OF FOR US AS
CALIFORNIANS TO PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA BRAND NOT JUST IN
REGARDS TO ALL OF OIL- BUT FOR
ALL THINGS AND IT WAS. DOWN MY-
MY OTHER COLLEAGUE SPOKE ABOUT
THE STEVEN KING OF QUEBEC
CALIFORNIA PIZZA KITCHEN. AND
IF YOU GO THROUGH A GROCERY
STORE NOW YOU CAN SEE A BUNCH
OF BRANDS SO NOT. PRODUCTS
DESCRIBING PRODUCTS BUT THEIR
ACTUAL BRAND USING THE
CALIFORNIA NAME AND I THINK
THERE'S A QUESTION. ABOUT MAKE
THE ABOUT ABOUT WHETHER WE
SHOULD PROTECT AND WHO OWNS-
THAT THAT THAT NAME I NOW WE
CAN START TO GO DOWN TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND- WE GO
DOWN TO CITIES AND ALL OF THAT
DOES WELL BUT- I DO THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT QUESTION.
AND IF THIS HAD COME BEFORE US-
I WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED IT- AND
KNOWING THAT- THERE WASN'T A
COMPANY THAT HAD A TWENTY THREE
YEAR OLD TRADEMARKS ALL BE
SUPPORTING IT. TODAY AND ALSO
JUST MY AFFECTION FOR THE
AUTHORED KNOWING THAT- SHE'S A
GOOD LEGISLATOR AND SHE'S GONNA
BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH- SOME
OF THESE THINGS WORK IT AND
WORK IT OUT AS IT WORKS TO THE
PROCESS- SO AGAIN I'LL BE
SUPPORTING US TODAY. MISS FOR.
MR FLOOR AND THEN THE BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
KIND OF WHAT I'VE WAS GONNA SAY
IS ALREADY BEEN STE STATED BUT
I DON'T REALLY WANT TO
REITERATE IT BECAUSE I AM IN
THE SUPPORT THIS BILL. BUT I DO
ACTUALLY THINK THAT. THE
COMPANY IN QUESTION- IS DOING
WHAT IS REQUIRED OF THEM. WE
CAN HAVE THE CONVERSATION IS
THAT ENOUGH MAYBE NOT. BUT I
JUST PULLED UP THEIR WEBSITE
RIGHT HERE. AND. THE TOP ROCKER
THAT ABSOLUTELY SAYS CALIFORNIA
OLIVE RANCH. AND THIS IS ON THE
GLOBAL SERIES. BUT AT THE
BOTTOM. IT TALKS ABOUT WHERE
SOME OF THE OTHER OILS ARE
COMING FROM. THEN YOU GO TO THE
HOW 2% CALIFORNIA PART OF IT.
IT'S LABELED A 100% CALIFORNIA.
I AM SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
BECAUSE AS A GUY THAT CAME FROM
AG. ANY AMOUNT OF REGULATORY
BURDEN AND WHAT IT MEANS TO DO
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PROTECTING THE
CALIFORNIA BRAND. IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME. IT'S
INCREDIBLY- FRUSTRATING AT
TIMES QUITE FRANKLY WHEN YOU
SEE OTHER PRODUCTS IMPORTED
UNDER OUR NAME KNOWING WHAT IT
COSTS OUR GROWERS TO PRODUCE
THAT COMMODITY. BUT I DO FIND
IT SOMEWHAT INTERESTING THAT
THIS PARTICULAR ALL OF OIL IS
BECOMING KIND THE NEXUS FOR
THIS FIGHT. IT'S KIND OF THE
TIP OF THE SPEAR AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
UNFORTUNATE. BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE. THAT THEY ARE
FOLLOWING THE LAW. THAT THEY
ARE PROPERLY LABELING THINGS
MAYBE THE FONT SIZE CHANGE
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
THAT WE CAN DO WE CAN HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. BUT I THINK
AS A INSTITUTION. IF THE TOP
ROCKER ON YOUR NAME IS GOING TO
BE CALIFORNIA IN THE BIGGEST
FATHER WE HAVE. IT NEEDS TO
COME FROM CALIFORNIA. I
FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THAT. SO
I AM SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I DO TRUST THE AUTHOR
AND SHE'S VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS AS WELL. BUT I DO THINK
THERE'S SOME WORK TO BE DONE
HERE AND THERE IS A HAPPY
MEDIUM TO BE FOUND BECAUSE-
WHAT I CARE ABOUT. IS
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA AG AND
OUR CALIFORNIA BRAND THANK YOU.
MR BONTA. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I JUST WANT TO SAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES I DO I KNOW THIS IS
THE FIRST THE HOUSE THE FIRST
COMMITTEE I AM GONNA BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY I
THINK OUR DIALOGUE AND
INCLUDING SOME OF THE IDEAS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE UP LIFTED SOME
PATHWAYS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
PERHAPS SPRING FROM THE BILL AS
AS YOU GO FORWARD AND KNOWING
YOU O BE THOUGHTFUL OPEN
MINDED AUTHOR THAT YOU ARE. I
HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER
OPPORTUNITIES TO STRENGTHEN THE
BILL GOING FORWARD BUT- I WILL
BE VOTING IN SUPPORT TODAY AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR ON
GOING. STEWARDSHIP OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU- ANYONE ELSE. GO
AHEAD IF YOU'D LIKE YOU MISTER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ONE. ONE
MOMENT AND THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR INDULGING BUT- I KNOW I'VE
ASKED FOR US TO NOT MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD BUT- I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S PROBABLY GOING TO
BE ENOUGH VOTES FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN BUT WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO. OFFER IS TO THE AUTHOR. I'M
WILLING TO LAY OFF AND TAKE
BACK THAT REQUEST. IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH IF. YOU
AND I COULD WORK OUT ON THIS A
LITTLE CLOSE. LIKE I'VE- I KNOW.
YOU AND I ARE VERY GOOD FRIENDS
AND SO THIS IS AN ODD PLACE FOR
US TO BE. BECAUSE WE BOTH
REPRESENT LOVE AGRICULTURE BUT
IF WE CAN WORK TOGETHER AND WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY THIS IS
BILL MOOS FOR MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE I
DO THINK WE HEARD ENOUGH FROM
ENOUGH MEMBERS HERE. THAT THERE
ARE SOME COMMON GROUND TO MAYBE
MAKE. ALL THE PARTIES COME
TOGETHER BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYBODY HERE IS. WILLING TO
WORK IT OUT. OPTIMISTIC. FIRST
OF ALL LET ME JUST REMIND YOU
THAT CALIFORNIA PIZZA THE
KITCHEN IS A- NOT OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IT'S A WAY OF LIFE IT'S A
LOT OF THAT SOME PEOPLE MIGHT
THINK. HEY I'M NOT. MOST OF THE
PER. I APPRECIATE THAT LED IT I
DO WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE CALL
THAT AND I I I AM I AM HAS FOR
AND I MY BOYS TO GO CRAZY
BECAUSE I KNOW MEET. MS
ASSEMBLY BIG AND WE'VE THIS IS
OF OUR FARMERS AND I JUST THINK
THAT- I AM PROUD THAT I BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD AND I'M REALLY
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT OUR OUR
STATE HAS THE BEST QUALITY FOR
FOOD. IN THE WORLD AND PEOPLE
APPRECIATE THAT SO AGAIN I JUST
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. AND I
THINK- I TO WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY- I- I FIND THE WHOLE
DISCUSSION REALLY REALLY
INTERESTING AND SO I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW AS AS MISTER BIGELOW SAID
THIS IS A- A LOT OF THIS FEELS
LIKE IT'S A TRADEMARK ISSUE
HERE. SO YOU DON'T HAVE IT JUST
WOULD PROVIDE SERVER MY FEEBLE
BRAIN BECAUSE THIS IS NOT THE
STUFF WE USUALLY DEAL WITH I
MEAN THIS IS I KNOW YOU THOUGHT
I WAS GOING TO AGRO THIS IS A
SLIPPERY SLOPE HERE I MEAN NINE
I MEAN. NEVER MIND I WILL WILL
WILL STAY AWAY FROM ALL OF WILL.
BUT BUT- SO YOU HAVE NO
OBJECTION TO WIN IT THE BRENT
THE TRADEMARK CALIFORNIA OLIVE
BRANCH IS HAS A 100% OLIVE OIL
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL IN IT
THAT'S THERE IS NO OBJECTION TO
THAT THIS CALIFORNIA CENTER
PERCENT ALL OF WELL JUST LIKE
THE EXISTING LOSSES RIGHT OKAY
ALL RIGHT AND THEN SO YOU SAID
AND THEN YOU ALSO SAID THAT IF
YOU'RE ON AMAZON AND LOOKING AT
THIS IT GETS CONFUSING I WOULD
JUST SAY MAYBE WE OUGHT TO BE
BUYING THESE IN THE STORE YEAH
THE MAYBE ON AMAZON IN YOUR
FRONT AND EVERYBODY WOULD BE
BETTER OFF FOR THAT. BECAUSE I
CAN'T READ WEBSITE BUT I SEE ON
AMAZON EITHER UNLESS I BLOW IT
UP AND I DO ON MY PHONE DOESN'T
WORK SO GOOD SO- SO I DO
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE WHERE
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE BETTER I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT- AS WITH
MISTER FLORA. IT'S PRETTY IT IS
OBVIOUS ON THEIR LABEL THAT
IT'S TO ME AS A CONSUMER OF I'M
LOOKING AT IT WHEN IT SAYS
GLOBAL I'M THINKING OKAY THIS
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL AND THEN I
LOOK FURTHER TO FIND OUT WHAT
THAT MEANS AND I SEE WITH THAT
I UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT THAT
MEANS SO. I'M I'M I MOVED THE
BILL FOR TODAY AND HOPE THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO TALK WITH- WITH
THE OPPOSITION HERE AND- AND
JUST SAY I'M NOT. SUPER ANXIOUS
TO HAVE ANOTHER FOOD. HEY FRANK.
SO- THAT WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CALL CARE THE THEY'LL
GO TO THE ALL OF WHILE AND
START AT LOUTH HERE TO YOU THAT
IF NOT YOUR SPOUSE OR WHOEVER
WILL START LOOKING AT THE- YOU
KNOW I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
I- EDUCATE MY COLLEAGUES. AND I
TOOK ABOUT TWENTY WOMEN OUT TO
ALL OF OIL LANDED AND THE MAIL.
AND EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENCES
AND- YOU KNOW THE BEST I CAN DO
IS EDUCATE OUR MARKET
COLLEAGUES BUT ANYWAY WITHOUT I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND I APPRECIATE WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE THEY'VE TRIED TO
CHANGE YOUR LABELS THEY'VE DONE
FOUR DIFFERENT. LABELS AND FOR
DIFFERENT YEARS- IN THE- FACE
OF DEATH WE ARE BOTH. THANK YOU
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
NAZARIAN I BELIEVE THE SEGWAY
ESTIMATES. I THINK IT WAS-
MCCARTY- MISTER MCCARTY THAT'S
RIGHT THE OTHER M. SS WAS THE
SECOND BY MR MCCARTY THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WHAT I MAYES MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NONVOTING
BONTA. BURKE WELL LARA LAURA HI
MAIENSCHEIN THIRTY NAZARIAN.
CHU CHU AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
SIX ZERO OKAY WE WILL LEAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL AND WE'LL
MOVE BACK TO FILE ORDER- ITEM
NUMBER SIX. EIGHTY SIX SIX SIX
MISTER CHIU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
EIGHTY SIX SIX SIX A NUMBER I
DID NOT SELECT. THIS IS A BILL.
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE
AND LACK OF DIVERSITY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE TO TREAT SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. THANK YOU- WE'LL KNOW
BEFORE THE CURRENT PANDEMIC RAN
AS WELL AS DURING THIS PANDEMIC
OUR COUNTRY HAS GRAPPLED WITH
AN OPIOID EPIDEMIC. IN OUR
STATE WHILE TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION HAVE HAD A DIAGNOSABLE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER THIS
PAST YEAR ONLY ONE IN TEN HAVE
RECEIVED TREATMENT. IN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WORKFORCE WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS DEVOTED
RESOURCES FOR MENTAL HEALTH THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER
TREATMENT SYSTEM HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY LACKING. DUE TO A
CHRONIC SHORTAGE IN OUR
WORKFORCE. OUR WORKFORCE IS
ALSO FAILED TO REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY AND LINGUISTIC
BACKGROUNDS OF OUR STATE'S
POPULATION. THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS A SHORTAGE LACK OF
DIVERSITY BY PROVIDING TUITION
ASSISTANCE FOR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING EXPENSES AND
INCREASING LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
EDUCATION MATERIALS. AS WELL AS
CONDUCT A STATEWIDE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT OF THE CURRENT
WORKFORCE. BY ADDING OVER A
THOUSAND CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WORKERS AND LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR RE BUSTS AND
COVER CULTURALLY COMPETENT
FIELD. THIS BILL WILL HELP
MILLION SUFFERING FROM
ADDICTION AND PUT PEOPLE TO
WORK WITH ALEXA TURN OVER TO
OUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY-
BY THE PHONE SO PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY- MISREPRESENT
CAN OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR-
GRETCHEN BERGMAN. FROM A NEW
PATH. YES HI. I'M GRETCHEN
BURNS BERGMAN AND I'M THE
MOTHER OF TWO SONS WHO
STRUGGLED FOR DECADES WITH
OPIOID ADDICTION. THEY'RE NOW
BOTH IN LONG TERM RECOVERY WORK
IS DRUG AND ALCOHOL
COUNSELLORS. BUT WE'RE ALL
CONCERNED THAT THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF DIVERSITY WITHIN
THE STATE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE TO TREAT SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE I CO FOUNDED A NEW
PASSCODE WHICH STANDS FOR
PARENTS PROTECTION TREATMENT
AND HEALING. THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
REDUCE THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED
WITH DRUG USE AND ADDICTION. I
SERVE AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WE
ADVOCATE FOR THERAPEUTIC RATHER
THAN PUNITIVE DRUG POLICIES
EVERY COUPLE. HUNDRED OPTION
STRATEGY. DRUG USE AND DRUG
OVER DEATH CAN TO RISE MORE
DRAMATICALLY SO BECAUSE OF THE
ISOLATION AND SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS OF COVERT NINETEEN
AND ECONOMIC HARDSHIP. HAVE
RISEN BY 13% UNITED STATES WE
KNOW THAT THIS IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
POVERTY DISPROPORTIONATELY
HOMELESS POPULATIONS ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE. OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN WORKING
TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS BY
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
INTERRELATIONSHIP OF COVERT
NINETEEN OPIOID OVERDOSE AND
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND ADVOCATING
FOR PATHWAYS JERRY KAPLAN MANY
PATHWAYS TO RECOVERY. THE NEED
FOR SERVICES IS DRAMATIC
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER IN THE PAST YEAR AND
MILLIONS MORE ARE LIVING WITH
AN UNDIAGNOSED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. YET THE WORK FORCE TO
TREAT THIS DISORDER IS GROSSLY
UNDERFUNDED. CALIFORNIA'S
BEHIND THE NATIONAL PERCENTAGE
QUALIFIED COUNSELORS IN
ADDICTION TREATMENT PROVIDERS
WE HAVE A LACK OF QUALIFIED
STAFF TO ADDRESS THIS MOUNTING
CRISIS. IN ADDITION WE DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO ADDRESS
THE DIVERSE CULTURAL
BACKGROUNDS AND LANGUAGES THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED SERVICES.
ARE SUBSTANTIVE DISORDER
COUNSELORS REMAIN PREDOMINANTLY
WHITE. POSING A BARRIER TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES MOST AT RISK.
AB SIX SIXTY SIX WHAT ADDRESS A
SHORTAGE BY PROVIDING ACCESS TO
EDUCATION ALLOCATE THE WAIVERS
FOR CERTIFICATION EXPENSES AND
NEEDS ASSESSMENT. PLEASE
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY
SIX AS THIS WILL EASE THIS
HEALTH CRISIS BY ADDING AT
LEAST ONE THOUSAND URGENTLY
NEEDED CERTIFIED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKERS. IT WILL ALSO
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF BUILDING A
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE WORKFORCE
FOR CALIFORNIA IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MOVE WE HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS
FOR THE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX
SIX. OKAY I WAS OKAY FIND GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS HEATHER
SLATTERY AND I PREVIOUSLY
WORKED ON THE TREATMENT TEAM
FOR GRANT WILL NOT CENTERS OF
PROGRAMMING GRASS VALLEY THAT
PROVIDE INPATIENT TREATMENT
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT DELIGHT
SERVICES ADOLESCENT TREATMENT
AND RECOVERY SERVICES.
CURRENTLY THE RECOVERY RESIDENT
COORDINATOR OVERSEEING MORE
THAN TWENTY RESIDENTS SPEAK
THROUGHOUT THE REGION I'M HERE
TODAY TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
THE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX SIX
TWO EXPAND THE ADDICTION
TREATMENT WORKFORCE.
EDUCATIONAL GRANTS AND. OTHER
ACTIVITIES FOR PEOPLE JUST LIKE
ME. MY USED. WELL CLEAR IN
HELPING DID NOT COME ALL MY
LIFE I STRUGGLED WITH ADDICTION
AT FIFTEEN NOW IS AN IDEAL
METHOD STUDY USER WITH LITTLE
HOPE FOR ANYTHING OTHER THAN A
LIGHT THE PAIN AND SUFFERING
WHEN I GAVE BIRTH TO MY
EXTREMELY PREMATURE DAUGHTER
WAIT AND TO POUNDS NINE OUNCES.
HI NEED BODY. WHY WHAT THE
GOODBYE TO FIGHT WITH AND-
WHICH IMPACT ME AWAY THAT I
NEVER AND- HAVING TRIED TO GET
WATER TIMES THE BY TO TRY MORE.
TIME I GRANT WILL CENTER BEGAN
THEIR MOTHERS IN RECOVERY. A
WHEN YOU'RE IN A VERY TREATMENT.
WHEN I GOT CLEAN REUNITED WITH
MY BABY LEARN WAYS TO LEAD TO
INCLUDE MY DIY RECORD. AFTER
THAT CARE I RECEIVED I CAN
THINK OF NOTHING BUT JOINING
THAT DEDICATED COMPASSIONATE
PEOPLE. AT GRANITE WELLNESS. TO
GET BACK OTHERS. BUT HOW I
WONDER I HAVE NO SKILL NOT EVEN
A HIGH DIPLOMA. THERE COULD NOT
BE JOURNEY I TAKE THEM FOR A
JOB AND THAT WOULD KEEP ME BUT
THE TEAM SHORTLY AFTER
COMPLETING MY TREATMENT. I
BECAME THE HAPPIEST WOMAN
SCRUBBING URINALS IN THE WORLD.
AND I DO NOT GIVE UP ON HELPING
OTHERS AND GET AWAY WITH THE
HELP OF THE SCHOLARSHIP FOR
MORE THAN A WORTH I WAS ABLE TO
ATTEND C. CAPITANI. COMPLETE MY
CORE EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
TO BECOME A LOCAL DRUG
COUNSELOR. I LEARNED SO MUCH
THROUGH HOW TO HANDLE CLIENT.
ABOUT ETHICS IN ABOUT
COUNSELING. WITHOUT THE
EDUCATION I KNOW I COULD HAVE
DONE HARM RATHER THAN GOOD AT
MY JOB. WHILE WORKING FULL TIME
AND RAISING MY FAMILY I WORKED
HARD GOING TO CLASSES EVERY
SATURDAY TO COMPLETE MY
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS. I'M
THANKFUL EVERY DAY FOR MY JOB
I'M ALLOWED TO DO AND I KNOW
THAT WITHOUT THE KIND OF
SCHOLARSHIP. OPPORTUNITIES I
RECEIVED I WOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
JUST LIKE ME OUT THERE PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO GET BACK YOU JUST.
GIVE THEM A CHANCE WITH SOME
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. TO NOT GIVE
UP ON THEIR DREAMS AS I LOOK AT
MY BEAUTIFUL MIRACLE THAT IS MY
DAUGHTER EACH AND EVERY DAY.
I'M REMINDED THAT THERE ARE
NUMERICAL WAITING TO HAPPEN IN
AN ARMY OF PEOPLE I. THAT YOU.
JUST HAVE THE CHANCE TO HELP.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL SIX SIX SIX
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE
ALREADY WE ACTUALLY A MOTION A
SECOND THANK YOU. SO OF
WITNESSES IN OP. TO OR A THE
THERE IS A WITNESS IN A. PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR THE WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF THAT WITNESS COMES ON
IN OUR- PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
ALLOW HIM TO TESTIFY AT THIS TO
IS POINT WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE SOMEONE IN THE
GALLERY TO OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EMILY HUGHES
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU ERY MUCH MR
OPERATOR CAN OPEN THE LINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT- FOR- SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL JUST TO
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION AND
IF. THE OPPOSITION WITNESS DOES
COME ON WILL ALLOW HIM TO
TESTIFY SO PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR. IN ONE NUMBER
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER TWO SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO SIX ZERO.
ZERO OKAY. SIX ONE ONE FIVE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAJOR TURN MEMBERS ROB LANE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES UPON
COSPONSORED THE STILL. IN
SUPPORT I GUESS SO THANK YOU.
AND MY NUMBER THREE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ENSURE A
DAILY WITH A CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS-
PROD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHEN NUMBER TWO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
ROBERT HARRIS ON THE ETHNICITY
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NOT OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THEN FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS WALDRON. THANK
YOU- I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THE BILL I WAS EXCITED
ENOUGH TO BE A CO AUTHOR WHICH
I THINK IS HAPPENING SO- BUT
YOU KNOW IT GOES BACK. A LONG
WAY BECAUSE IN OUR SYSTEM HE
WHEN I SAW THE BILL REMINDED ME
OF EVEN LEGISLATION I HAD DONE-
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH FOUR BACK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- REQUIRED DHS
TO PERFORM. THE STATE WIDE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT REPORT
EVALUATING IN THE STATE OF THE
S. U. D. WORKFORCE. IN EACH
COUNTY AND THEN HAD AN EMPHASIS
ON USE AS WELL AS- CONDUCTING A
QUALITY ASSESSMENT FOR
ADDICTION TREATMENT PREVENTION
AND INTEGRATED WORKFORCES. SO
IN THAT BUILT IMMENSELY DIED IN
APPROPRIATIONS. AND THEN WE GO
TO ANOTHER BILL THAT- I ALSO
AUTHORED AB NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE. WHICH WOULD INCENTIVIZE
PROVIDERS FOR MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT AND- AS WE
KNOW WE ONLY HAVE 2% OF
PROVIDERS THAT EVEN CAN DO MATH-
ARE CERTIFIED TO DO IT. SO YOU
KNOW WHAT POINT ARE WE GONNA
STOP THE RHETORIC AND ACTUALLY
START TO FUND THESE THINGS
BECAUSE IT IS A PARTY AND THIS
BILL IS A PRIORITY SO WE REALLY
NEED TO YOU KNOW SAY IS A STATE
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE
GONNA FUNDED MORE FINALLY GOING
TO GET THESE THINGS DONE SO.
YEAH I- JUST STRONG I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THE BILL DOES ENJOY
TO PASS RECOMMENDATION- MR CHU
WHICH I CLOSE JUST WANTED
APPRECIATE THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND- WE WILL BE ADDING
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER TO OUR
BILLS A CO AUTHOR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE BUT THERE IS
A MOTION BEFORE US- MOTION BY
MISTER FLORES SECOND BY MISTER
MASON NEW THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES. MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW. BONTA BURKE AREA.
FLORA FOR AYE MAIENSCHEIN RT.
NAZARIANNAZARIAN I TO ARRIVE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON HIGH. HAS EIGHT
AS EIGHT BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERSTO ADD
ON CONGRATULATIONS MISTER CHU
THE NEXT BILL IS NOT A NUMBER
SEVEN AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISIONS.
MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER FOR THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE INCLUDING FOLKS ON
THEIR SPOUSES PLANS FOR YOUNG
ADULTS WHO ARE ON THEIR PARENTS
PLAN UNTIL THE AGE OF TWENTY
SIX. IN THESE INSTANCES THE
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER MAY
RECEIVE INFORMATION ABOUT CARE
THAT THE PATIENT WILL NOT WANT
REVEALED. IN SOME CASES IT
COULD EVEN BE DANGEROUS. IT
TRANS YOUTH MAY NOT WANT THEIR
PARENTS KNOW THEY'RE
TRANSITIONING OR ACCESSING
GENDER AFFIRMING HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. A WOMAN ACCESSING
REPRODUCTIVE CARE OR CARE
RELATED TO A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCIDENT MAY NOT WANT HER
PARTNER JANELLE. CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS THE PATIENT TO REQUEST
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
SERVICES NOT BE SENT TO THE
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER. THROUGH
A CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
REQUEST. HOWEVER THERE IS NO
STANDARDIZED PROCESS SO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THESE REQUESTS HAS
BEEN HAPHAZARD. YOU CAN FOLLOW
THE LINK WITH THE STATE IF
INSURANCE COMPANIES FAIL O
ACCOMMODATE THE REQUEST BUT BY
THAT TIME THE DAMAGE IS DONE.
THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE ON
EXISTING PROTECTIONS IN TWO
WAYS. IT ESTABLISHES AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS FOR
SENSITIVE SERVICES ENSURING
THAT PRIVACY IS NOT VIOLATED.
AND IT WOULD EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF SENSITIVE
SERVICES TO INCLUDE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AND TRANSGENDER HEALTH
CARE. TO ENSURE MORE PEOPLE
HAVE PRIVACY PROTECTED. MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN A CONVERSATION
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
ANY CONCERNS AS WE ALL AGREE
THAT WE DON'T WANT SOMEONE TO
AVOID CRITICAL CARE IN ORDER TO
PREVENT A POLICY HOLDER FOR
FINDING OUT ABOUT THAT CARE.
AND WITH THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR FIRST
WITNESS PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. GO TO OUR FIRST WITNESS.
ACTUALLY OPEN OF THE LINE FOR
ACTUALLY OF TWO WITNESSES WHO
MUST OPEN THE LINE FOR BOTH
WITNESSES PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTRUST RAIDER
WHEN THE WITNESSES ARE ON
PLEASE- START WITH THE LISA
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD. THE
SAILING CARE MEMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
WITH THE MOB ARAMBULA PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SEVEN FIVE HUNDRED
AFFILIATES WHO COLLECTIVELY
PROVIDE NEARLY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION VISITS ANNUALLY TO
PATIENTS ACROSS THE STATE I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TO CONTINUE-THE IMPORTANT WORK ADVOCATES
AND LAWMAKERS UNDERTOOK WHEN
THEY PASSED. SB ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SPECIAL HEALTH WILL SPEAK LATER
PATIENTS CONTINUE TO FIND IT
DIFFICULT TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW. FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S CALL
CENTERS CONFIDENTIALITY THAT
THE CORE OF ITS ROLE AS A
TRUSTED HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
PATIENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS OF THE SERVICES THAT
LIKE REPRODUCTIVE CARE GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ARE AT THE I. CARE
WITHOUT HERE AND HAVING THEIR
PRIVATE INFORMATION EXPOSED.
SOME PATIENTS SEEK CARE THEY
MAY NOT REALIZE THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CARE THEY
RECEIVE MAY BE DISCLOSED BY
REACHING NOTICES FROM THEIR
HEALTH INSURER. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR MINORS
AND YOUNG ADULTS WHO ARE ON
THEIR PARENTS PLAN. ANYONE WHO
HAS HAD TO NAVIGATE COVERAGE
ISSUES WITH OUR HEALTH
INSURANCE NO THAT IS NOT A
SIMPLE OR EASY PROCESS. MANY OF
US CAN RELATE THAT AS TEENAGERS
AND YOUNG ADULTS WE HAD NO IDEA
WHO ARE HOPING SURE WAS WHAT
INFORMATION LED TO THE HEALTH
INSURER. LET ALONE KNOW WHAT
RIGHT ONE WOULD HAVE UNDER THE
LAW OR HER PARENTS PLAN TO
REQUEST CONFIDENTIALITY. ASIAN
TO RELY ON OTHER PEOPLE FOR
THEIR HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PLAN IN
ADVANCE. AND THEN WITH THE HELP
OF CONSUMER RIGHTS ADVOCATES
AND ATTORNEYS. TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN GET THE MEDICAL CARE
THEY NEED CONFIDENTIALLY. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL SHIFT
THE DEFAULT POSITION TO THE ONE
WHERE PARENTS. PLANNED DIRECT
COMMUNICATION FOR THE PATIENT
RATHER THAN THE PRIMARY
SUBSCRIBER OTHER PLANS. WHEN
NOT PATIENT REDUCE EATING
CERTAIN SENSITIVE SERVICES.
INSTABILITY OF PROTECTING THAT
PATIENT CONFIDENTIALITY SHOULD
NOT LIE WITH THE PATIENT'S
REQUEST PROTECTION IN A SYSTEM
THAT IS NOTORIOUSLY DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE. HEALTH CARE IS
PERSONAL AND CONFIDENTIALITY IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT ALL
PATIENTS CAN CONTINUE TO ACCESS
NEEDED SERVICES WITHOUT FEAR OR
JUDGMENT FOR THEIR HEALTHCARE
DECISIONS. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT PATIENTS
AND THEIR INFORMATION OUR CAP
SPACE. FOR THESE REASONS
LANTERN HEAD IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
CELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WAS- WITNESS. THE SOVIET
CASTILLO ESSENTIAL HEALTH ACT
ACCESS HELP EXCUSE ME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SYLVIA CASTEEL AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS ASCENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH. WE PROBABLY
SPONSORED SB ONE THIRTY EIGHT A
CONFIDENTIAL HEALTH INFORMATION
ACT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE GAINED
HEALTH COVERAGE UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WE FELT
SAFE ENOUGH TO USE THEIR NEW
FOUND COVERAGE. ACCESS
SENSITIVE SERVICES LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH OR SEXUAL HEALTH CARE.
UNDER SB ONE THIRTY EIGHT
HEALTH PLAN DEPENDENT THANK
YOUNG PEOPLE COVERED BY THEIR
PARENTS PLAN WOULD HAVE TO BE
AWARE THAT THEIR INFORMATION
COULD BE DISCLOSED AND THEN
TAKE STEPS TO PROTECT.
THEMSELVES THE FOURTEENTH WE
WORK DIRECTLY WITH PATIENTS TO
SUBMIT CONFIDENTIALITY REQUESTS
TO HELP THEIR PLANS. BUT THEY
HAVE NOT WORKED WELL BECAUSE IT
PLACES THE ONUS ON THE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND OTHER PATIENTS TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEX WORLD OF
INSURANCE OF HEALTH INSURANCE.
HERE JUST A FEW OF THE STORIES
OF ISSUES AND ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS THAT PATIENTS HAVE
ENCOUNTERED MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE CALLED THEIR INSURANCE
PLAN DIRECTLY BUT ONLY TO HAVE
UNTRAINED STAFF. WHO HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW TO PROCESS THE
PRIVACY REQUEST OR WERE GIVEN
INCORRECT INFORMATION ONE
PATIENT WAS EVEN TOLD THAT NO
SUCH LAW EXISTED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHEN IN FACT IT
ALREADY DID. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
A FEMALE PATIENT WANTED
CAMPAIGN BIRTH CONTROL AND FILE
THE PRIVACY REQUEST SHE WANTED
TO CONFIRM THE REQUEST WAS IN
PLACE BEFORE EVEN MAKING THE
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE UNDER SB
ONE THIRTY EIGHT HEALTH PLANS
HAD SEVEN TO FOURTEEN DAYS TO
IMPLEMENT THE INFORMATION
BLOCK. THE HEALTH PLAN REJECTED
THE REQUEST SO SHE CONTACTED US
FOR HELP SHE WAITED TO MAKE THE
APPOINTMENT UNTIL THE ISSUE WAS
RESOLVED FOR THE HER PRIVACY
WAS PROTECTED WHICH MEANT THAT
HE DID NOT RECEIVE THE CARE SHE
NEEDED FOR AN ADDITIONAL THREE
WEEKS. MANY PATIENTS ARE NOT
AWARE THAT THEIR INFORMATION
COULD BE DISCLOSED UNTIL
THEY'RE ALREADY AT THE HEALTH
CENTER THERE IS NO GUARANTEE
THAT THE PRIVACY REQUEST WILL
BE PROCESSED IN TIME TO STOP
DISCLOSURE OF THOSE SERVICES
ALREADY OPTING. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE RECEIVED TWENTY FIVE
REQUESTS FROM PATIENTS SAYING I
GOT BIRTH CONTROL FROM MY
DOCTOR I DON'T WANT MY PARENTS
TO FIND OUT TO THE INSURANCE IN
EACH OF THESE CASES ATTORNEYS
FROM THE ACLU AND THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW CONTACTED
THE HEALTH PLANS TO ENSURE THE
INFORMATION BLOCK WITH IN
PLACE. TO PREVENT THE MEDICAL
CARE FROM BEING DISCLOSED THAT
WAS ALREADY OPTIONED- IT SHOULD
SPEAK UP OVER THE ACTUALLY OVER
THE YEARS MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE CONTACTED US
ASKING FOR HELP TO GET THROUGH
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE AREAS TO
PROTECT THEIR INFORMATION IN
ABOUT SIXTY OF THESE CASES
LEGAL PARTNER STEPPED IN TO
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES DIRECTLY.
WITH HEALTH INSURERS ON BEHALF
OF THE PATIENT. IT SHOULD NOT
TAKE THE HELP OF THE ATTORNEY
AT. ARE RIGHT HAVE PRIVACY
ATTACK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND A I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
YESGOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT JET
HAN BEEN HERE AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS
REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR I'D LIKE TO DEMAND IT-
FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO
SINCERELY THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE AUTHOR STACKING THE
SPONSORS- FOR WORKING WITH US
IN GOOD FAITH TO RESOLVE SOME
OF OUR CONCERNS. WITH THE SPELL
HI WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOOD CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD TO
DATE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR I TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. HOWEVER AS DRAFTED-
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL ATHLETICALLY WE ARE
ARE I RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING.
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT TO THE
BILL. THAT WOULD PROVIDE THAT A
PLANE ARE YOU SURE HAS RISK A
COPY COMMUNICATION REQUIRE.
FROM THE ROLE OR THE ENSURE.
THAT THE PLAINTIFF. TO THAT. TO
THE KERN ADDRESS ON FILE. AND
ONE OF THE COMMUNICATION IS A
TRACK RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
ENROLLEE OR SURE WHO'S RECEIVED
THE SERVICE. AND WE BELIEVE
THIS CLARIFICATION IS CRITICAL
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH MANAGERS.
NEED TO MEET THEIR STATUTORY
LEGAL OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
VITAL HEALTH INFORMATION TO
THEIR MEMBERS. WHILE ALSO
ENSURING. THAT THE PRIVACY AND
INDIVIDUAL ROLE THE ORCHARD IS
PROTECTED- WE ARE ALSO
UNDERSTAND. THAT THE BILL HAS.
A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATE
THAT WE CAN UPDATE OUR INTERNAL
SYSTEMS AND APPROPRIATELY
TRAINED STAFF TO IDENTIFY. AND
PROCESS THESE NEW REQUEST. FOR
THESE REASONS- WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR ELECTED AMENDED I BELIEVE
THAT HE TO LOOK FOR TO FRUITFUL
AND PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YA. AUTHORS OFFICE- ON ON
THESE ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WITH THAT WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OTHERS IN. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ADDRESS NOT YOUR ADDRESS HE'S
GOT A ONE KNOW YOUR ADDRESS.
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION. AND
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE. A
WEEK THE LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRENT SPENCE
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NECKLINE TO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXTCODE PLEASE. MY
NUMBER ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I GET AFTERNOON WILLIAM
MARTIN BURKE ON BEHALF OF NARAL
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SANTIAGO
JOCULAR ON BEHALF OF- JUNE
EIGHTH REPRODUCTIVE AND GENDER
EQUITY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHENEVER THREE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEPHANIE
WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURNCE COMPANIES
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR WILL WORKING WITH
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THEM IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME VERY WELL THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. C. NONE THE
BILL DOESN'T DO I DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND CAN I
THOUGHT WE DID THAT WE DON'T ON
THIS ONE- WE DO. THAT WAS THE
LAST BILL I THINK- IT ANYWAY
WELL LET MR CHU CLOSE AND WE'LL
FIGURE OUT. WHO'S GOING TO MOVE
IN SECOND THE BILL. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE- THE COMMENTS BY THE
PLANTS AND- WE'VE BEEN AND
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM AND- AND LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS TO
HOPEFULLY RESOLVE THESE ISSUES-
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY ONCE
HEALTHCARE IS A PRIVATE MATTER.
AND THIS BILL WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT IT WITH THAT-
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHIU- WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTAKE YOUR CURRY
A SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIRTY PASSED TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
SORRY I WAS YEAH I'M SORRY MY
NOTES WERE DIFFERENT SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PRIVACY
PROTECTION MY APOLOGIES SO
PLEASE. PROCEED WHAT HI WHAT I
MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BONTA. BURKE BURKE
FIVE CORREO FLORA. LARA NOW
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY THE I IN
THIS AREA. NAZARIAN I TO. CHU
HI RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON. HAS SEVEN
IT'S ONE MORE SEVEN ONE SO
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL AND MY
APOLOGIES TO. OUR SECRETARY I
JUST DIDN'T I READ THE WRONG
NOPE SO- THE ERROR WAS MINE SO.
MR DALY YOU HAVE A. B. TEN
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I'LL BE AS
BRIEF AS I CAN THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
STATE TO DEVELOP. CONSENSUS
BASED STANDARDS FOR SAFE
RESPONSIBLE RECOVERY RESIDENTS
HOUSING. CURRENTLY THERE ARE O
RULES FOR ENSURING THAT
RECOVERY RESIDENCES ARE SAFE.
NOT ONLY FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE THERE BUT FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORS AS WELL. THIS BILL
BILL WILL BRING TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A SET
OF STANDARDS THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTRAST. CALIFORNIA CAN AND
MUST DEVELOP THESE STANDARDS TO
SAVE LIVES CONSERVE BADLY
NEEDED RESOURCES AND PRESERVE
HARMONY IN COMMUNITIES THAT MAY
BE MORE RECEPTIVE TO RECOVERY
HOUSING. THAT IS TRULY SAFE.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WILL BE SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF THE
VICTIM ADDICTION FOR PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS. AND JESSE
HAYNER WITH YOUNG PEOPLE IN
RECOVERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL OPEN THE PHONE LINES. WERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIR NUMBER
SURE DAVID WAS CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND COUNSELORS MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED MILLIGRAMS
ENTERTAINER TO RECOVERY
RESIDENCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE ALL KNOW THAT THREE DAYS OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT OR MONTHS ABOUT
PATIENT TREATMENT OF NOT CURE
ADDICTION WE ALSO KNOW THAT
ENTRY SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER IS
HIGHLY RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE PAST
TWO DECADES OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER IS A CHRONIC DISEASE
WITH A HIGH POTENTIAL THREE
LAPS WITH EARLY RECOVERY BEING
MOST SUSCEPTIBLE FOR FAILURE TO
MAINTAIN SOBRIETY AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SPENDING
MILLIONS OF SENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA FOR
TREATMENT OR RECOVERY SERVICES.
FOR COUNTIES WILL BE INCREASING
THEIR CONTRACTING FOR THIS
RESOURCE IT IS TIME TO ADDRESS
RESULT REVOLVING DOORS
TREATMENT IS TRYING TO EXAMINE
WHAT ARE THE FACTORS THAT LEAD
TO STRONG TRIP LONG TERM
SUCCESS AND HOW THEY CAN BE
IMPROVED IN CALIFORNIA. STABLE
HOUSING AND A DRUG AND ALCOHOL
FREE ENVIRONMENT HAS LONG SINCE
BEEN PROVEN AS AN EFFICACIOUS
WAY TO SUPPORT EARLY RECOVERY.
AND IMPROVE LASTING SOBRIETY.
HOW THERE ARE NO STANDARDS WITH
WHICH- SHE RELATE OUTCOME TO WE
DON'T ALSO KNOW HOW. RECALL
RESIDENTS BETTER CAL. WHAT THE
SOLDIER FROM SIXTEEN CONSUMER.
OR THEY'RE ALLOW SIX.
SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN. ASSISTED
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE
TO LIVE IN THEM. AB TEN NINETY
EIGHT SIMPLY A SEPARATE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. TO BEGIN
THE PROCESS BY WHICH CALIFORNIA
CAN RECOGNIZE THE SET OF
QUALITY STANDARDS. AND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES CAN FIND ANSWERS TO
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE QUALITY. AND AVAILABILITY
OF THIS TYPE OF HOUSING. THE
BILL CREATES NO CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM NO CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS OR STANDARDS THAT
ARE MANDATORY TO BE USED BY ANY
PRIVATE RESIDENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS. JEFF THIS
DEBATE ABOUT THE VISION OF MY
AGENCY YOUNG PEOPLE IN
RECOVERY. R. Y. T. R. THE
NATIONAL GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION. FOCUSED ON PEER
RECOVERY SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN RECOVERY IT'S.
PROBLEMS CONVICTED SHOPPERS.
AFTER YOU BEEN ON IT OPEN
TROPICAL PUBLIC THE OWNER RIGHT
KIRKLAND PRINTABLE LAW AGES.
THE COVERED FROM. USE THE SOLAR.
POSTED BY. EVERYBODY LET ME BE
BY. ARE THE PERSON WE TERM
WHICH COULD DURING. THE CAR
SURVATION INFO WHY AN HONOR TO
YOU POP. FIFTY TWO TODAY.
MALACCAN RETAINED BY THE TO
CHANGE OF RETURN ALL. OF A
RECOVERY RATE COMMUNITY IS A
BEING INCLUDING. RESIDENTS. SO
LIVING ENVIRONMENTS BECOMING
THAT THEY AND WE KNOW THE NOW-
PART OF A WEEK RATE YOU. AND IN
MY BE PREPARED TO THE QUALITY
OF THEM IN ORDER TO SURE THAT
PEOPLE RECOVERY NOT BECAUSE-
INTERCHANGES FOR LONG TERM
RECOVERY AND- IN AUGUST NOT
BEEN IN. I THREE FOR RECOVERY
Y. CAL. IN THE IN THE PROMO
FROM. LESLIE CARCERI. AND THE
COVERAGE. CONTINUES TO GROW
SEVERAL AND WILL BE IN A WIDER
ALL THREE ACROSS STATE. I CAN
TELL PERSONALLY FROM AT. I HAVE
THROUGH THE FOR FROM. ACOSTA
TREATMENT PROGRAM ANY
EXTRADITION ALSO RELIVING.
THERE'S TRANSITION TO RECOVER
RESIDENT. LIVING IN DETRIMENTAL
TO IN THE OR SEEKING LONG TERM.
THERE WAS NO. THERE ARE NO
BROKE STANDARDS ECONOMIC ENOUGH
THAT. FORTY ROBERT BARNETT AND
POSITIVE FORMATTER IN THE FALL.
FROM A PANEL SPOKE ACCORDING
SERVICE STAND- MONEY BASIC Y.
SKILLS FUN THERE AND QUALITY OF
LEAD AND ONE OF. DURING THE
COMPANY EIGHT APARTMENT BY. SB
SIX. AB EXPERIENCE ON THE NEXT
OUTCOME NOT HAVE PEOPLE STARED
OF LIVING. IN BLACK AND- SELL
GAMES MOTOR AND CURRENTLY THE
LACK OF CHARACTER. IS ON THE
BILL SUPPORT OF HAVING TO RE.
POST STARTED YOUR PART ALL OF
FOR ME IN THE BED. I HAVEN'T A
VICTIM OF THE OF HOW BONDS AND
SALLY THE INFLUENCE DRUGS YOU
KNOW. IN THE HOME BUT I WAS IN
TO CLEAR THE REESE THE RIVER.
MORE ENOUGH TO MAKE OVER TO
PREVENT TOOL. THEY WERE NOT YOU
KNOW CONSIDERED. AB AND I EIGHT
WHEN SERVING CUT POINT IN ORDER
FOR OF PRACTICAL IN QUALITY
STANDARD. IF WE ARE LICENSED
PUT AND SEPARATE WE MIGHT SEE
DO THING IS A TRANSITIONAL
LIVING AND KING OF. IN ANY
COUNTY RIGHT COMMUNITY CHANGE
RESOURCE OF A MARKET AVAILABLE
SHOULD NOT BE A BUT IT'S- THE
CARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION. I HOPE YOU
GUYS SUPPORT AB AND NINETY
EIGHT THANK YOU SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL A DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE A- WITH HAVE NO READ.
WITNESSES AN OFFER. WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE FOR- THE PUBLIC
COMMENT IF YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION ONLY PLEASE
SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
OPERATOR. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- QUESTION
FOR MR RODRIGUEZ PLEASE- I'M
SORRY MOTION BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ AT. THE SECOND BY MR
MCCARTY. NO QUESTIONS BUT A
MOTION AND A SECOND- THE BILL
DOES TO ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE MISTER DALY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. IT YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION- IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BY MR RODRIGUEZ
IN THE SECOND BY MR MCCARTY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HI WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES I AGUIAR-CURRY. FIGURE
CURRY I. BIGELOW BIGELOW HI
BONTA BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
FLORA FLUORIDE MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I TO. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO YOUR BILLS
OUT LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FURTHER
SAT ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
DALY. MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE GONNA
START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK THEIR STAFF
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
ADDITIONALLY I'M COMMITTED TO
WORK ON AND THE ISSUES OUTLINED
IN PAGE SEVEN AT THIS MOMENT
MOVES ON TO JUDICIARY AND AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
THEIR- SUPPORT ON THAT. I'M
HERE FOR- EATING DISORDERS ARE
SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM
AFFECTING YOUTH OF ALL RACES
AGE AND GENDER ACCORDING TO A
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ARTICLE
PUBLISHED. IN THE NEW ENGLAND
JOURNAL OF MEDICINE WHICH
INCLUDES DATA FROM SIXTY THREE
US EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
CONCEPTION OF DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS LEAD TO TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS PER YEAR IN THE US. WELL
CALIFORNIA'S AT THE CORPORATE
WHEN IT COMES TO TAX STATUTES
AND REGULATIONS CONCERNING
THEIR THREE SUPPLEMENTS. IT
DOES NOT CURRENTLY PROHIBIT THE
SALE OF WEIGHT LOSS DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS TO MINORS DESPITE
THE WELL DOCUMENTED DANGERS OF
THESE PRODUCTS. AS WRITTEN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WOULD
PROTECT MINORS- BY. IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE USER'S WEIGHT
LOSS SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET PILLS
BY PROHIBITING RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS AND SELLING
THESE PRODUCTS TO MINORS UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
AND I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS SORTS
OF THAT THE WITNESSES COULD
FILL IN THE REST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS-
AGUIAR-CURRY WILL MOVE ON TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR A SECOND BY
MR MCCARTY- WILL MOVE ON TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- PLEASE OPEN TE PHONE
LINES WERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON WOULD
BITE SEPARATE NAY AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. MY AME IS
DR J. FROM THE GADA AND I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN AND FACULTY MEMBER
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO. I AM HERE TODAY
SUPPORTING ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE AND URGE YOU
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THE U. S.
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT INDUSTRY
GENERATE OVER TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
REVENUE. WE HAVE ALL SEEN THE
PRODUCT AND LOCAL PHARMACIES.
GROCERY STORES AND HEALTH FOOD
STORES. WHAT MANY PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW IS THAT WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS ARE NOT REVIEWED BY
THE FDA FOR SAFETY OR
EFFECTIVENESS BEFORE THEY ENTER
THE MARKET. RESEARCH AFFECTING
THE COMPOSITION OF THE
SUPPLEMENT I FOUND THAT MANY
ARE LACED WITH BANNED
SUBSTANCES. PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
STIMULANTS STEROIDS AND OTHER
TOXIC INGREDIENTS. RIGOROUS
SCIENTIFIC STUDY AFTER STUDY
HAS SHOWN THE TYPES OF
DOCUMENTS THAT POSE SERIOUS
HEALTH RISKS TO CONSUMERS. FOR
INSTANCE ONE RECENT SCIENTIFIC
STUDY FOUND THAT YOU'RE GIVING
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS WHAT
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN
THOSE USING ORDINARY VITAMINS
THE EXPERIENCE OF YOUR MEDICAL
HARM INCLUDING HOSPITALIZATION
DISABILITY. AND EVEN DEATH.
OTHER STUDIES HAVE LINKED
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS WITH
ORGAN FAILURE HEART ATTACKS
STROKES AND DEATH. THE CDC
ESTIMATES THAT SUPPLEMENT YOU
THE TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS EVERY
YEAR WHAT THE QUARTER DUE TO
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT ALONE.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS RECENTLY ISSUED A
REPORT STRONGLY CAUTIONING
AGAINST USING THESE PRODUCTS
FOR ANY REASON. YOU TO USE OVER
THE COUNTER DIET PILLS ARE SIX
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
DIAGNOSED WITH AN EATING
DISORDER THAN NON USERS. AT THE
PEDIATRICIAN SPECIALIZING IN
ADOLESCENT EATINGDISORDERS I
HAVE CARED FOR COUNTLESS YOUTH
IN THE BAY AREA. YOUTH WEIGHT
LOSS SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET PILLS
DEVELOP EATING DISORDERS BECOME
CRITICALLY ILL AND REQUIRED
HOSPITALIZATION. THE NUMBER OF
THE TEENAGER THE HOSPITALIZED
FOR EATING DISORDER THAT UCF
HAS DOUBLED SINCE THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC. WE NEED TO GET
THESE DANGEROUS PRODUCTS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF OUR KIDS. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY ONE GIVE
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ACTION NOW
TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN. BILL
WOULD PREVENT THE SALE OF
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS AND
OVER THE COUNTER DIET PILL TO
MINORS. ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD
MOVE THE PRODUCT FROM OPEN
SHELVES TO BEHIND THE COUNTER
JUST AS WE HAVE DONE WITH OTHER
RISKY PRODUCTS LIKE CIGARETTES.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. WE
MUST ACT NOW TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO.
OUR NEXT WITNESS OR IS IT JUST.
HELLO YES THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRPERSON WHAT VICE
CHAIRPERSON MADE HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
HEALTH CARE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY HI MY NAME IS KELSEY LU
AND I'M A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
YOUTH FROM DENMARK CALIFORNIA
WAY CURRENTLY ATTEND STEINBERG
HIGH SCHOOL. I'M HERE TODAY TO
SHARE MY STORY AND I'M- NEWS
ACROSS THE STATE. WHO LIKE ME
STRONGLY I THANK BILL NUMBER
ONE THREE FOUR ONE. A TEENAGER
GROWING. UP TODAY I NO STRANGER
TO WAIT CONCERNS AND MAKE IT A
PART OF AN H. I. FOUND ONE WHO
DEVELOPING EATING DISORDER AT
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN. LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
ADOLESCENTS YOU'RE MY FAVE
EXPERIENCES. I'M NOT THINK THAT
OF WHAT TODAY WILL DO FINE I.
BY AND IT. FOR ME NOW LOOK BACK
WHAT I WOULD ABLE TO DO EXPORT.
I WENT MANY MY PEERS ARE EIGHT
TO GIVE. TO COPE WITH THE
PRESSURE LOSE WEIGHT. TO BE
ADDED BECAUSE- IF I FEEL ABOUT
APPEARANCE AND I'M LOOKING FOR
A QUICK FIX MY PROBLEM I TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN ACCESS TO HUNDREDS
OF PRODUCTS AND SUPPLEMENTS
THAT I CAN EASILY BY WITH NO
LEGAL RESTRICTIONS WHATSOEVER.
I JUST A QUICK OF A BUTTON ON
MY PHONE. EVEN MORE CONVENIENT.
FIVE MILLION. MY LOOK WITH THE-
I THINK EASILY PER. TITLED
WEIGHT LOSS UP FROM YOU ARE MY
DISCRETION. NO CLUB OR FARM
WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO STOP ME
AND MY PARENTS WOULD NEVER KNOW
UNLESS I TOLD THEM. WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENT AND DIET PILL
COMPANIES NO KENYA. ARE THERE
BEST CUSTOMERS. IF HOOKED ON
THEIR PRODUCTS THEY WILL HAVE A
GUARANTEED MARKET FOR YEARS TO
COME THANK YOU LIBERTY EXPLOIT
OUR LOW SELF CONFIDENCE AND
BODY IMAGE STRUGGLES. MAKING
IMPOSSIBLE PROMISES THAT
HORRIBLE TEAMS CAN'T HELP BUT
TO BELIEVE. ON A DAILY BASIS
I'M BOMBARDED WITH ADS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA LEARN NEEDED BY
THE LATEST WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET COKE.
TRYING TO GET NEED TO TREAT MY
HEALTH BUT. THE CODE THAT
BETTER BOTTOM. POPULAR SOCIAL
AND TO ARE ACTUALLY YOU'D LIKE
ME I ROUTINELY TARGETED BY PILL
WAIT LOSS OF MY COMPANY. I
THEIR PRODUCTS YES DEFINITELY I.
BILL NUMBER ONE THREE FOUR HI
IT WILL LIMIT THE Y. AND THE-
OF HARD WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT
AND THAT COKE ME AND MY FRIEND.
I ALONG WITH HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS. A YOUNG LIKE ME CAL
WILL BE MUCH SAFER WHICH
PROTECT AGAINST DANGEROUS
WEIGHT LOSS AND DIET PILLS. SO
I URGE YOU ALL AT PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS VALID I DEDICATE
LEADERS FOR OUR STATE VOTE TO
SUPPORT A FAMILY BILL NUMBER
ONE THREE FOUR ONE. THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA ARE
DEPENDING ON YOU. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME AND LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MOVING ON TO-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT IT'S WITH MILLER FACT
IT DOES YET I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN HERBAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION AFTER THAT. AFTER
THE NATIONAL TRADED.
REPRESENTING MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MEMBER
COMPANY. DOING BUSINESS AS THE
GROWERS PROCESSORS
MANUFACTURERS AND MARKETERS OF
HERBS AND HERBAL PRODUCTS.
AFTER MISSION IS TO PROMOTE THE
RESPONSIBLE AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMERCE THE FOCAL PRODUCTS TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS HAVE
INFORMED ACCESS TO A WIDE
VARIETY SB FIVE OKAY. WELL WE
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
GOAL AND ADDRESSING THE FEAR
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEMS
EATING DISORDERS AMONG YOU. WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. ALTHOUGH
THE BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED
THAT WOULD SERVE ONLY TO KEEP
GO DIETARY SUPPLEMENT PRODUCTS
WITHOUT ACTUALLY EDUCATING THE
TEAM IN THE HOUSE. THIRTY
SUPPLEMENTS ARE SUBJECT TO WELL
ESTABLISHED DIRECT REGULATION
ENFORCEMENT TEAM. THE FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION AND THE
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION HAVE
CLEAR AUTHORITY OVER DIETARY
SUPPLEMENT. THROUGH THE FEDERAL
FOOD DRUG AND COSMETIC ACT ANY
FTP ACT. THE ACT HE IS CHARGED
WITH INSPECTING MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES REVIEWING LABELING
AND MONITORING PRODUCT FOR
SAFETY WELL THE ATHLETES HE
PURSUED TO ACCEPT A FOLLOW AND
LEADING ADVERTISING. ALTHOUGH
EVEN TO NOTE THAT OVER THE DAY
SUPPLEMENT CONTAINING
INGREDIENTS CITED BY THE
DOCTORS YEAH. SUGGESTS A
FEDERAL AND PHARMACEUTICAL ARE
FROM FELL BY THE FDA AND ARE
THEREFORE ALREADY EVEN THE BOX.
IN ADDITION WE QUESTION WHETHER
THE THIRTY BY MONSTER INDICATE
A COURSE PROBLEM. A REVIEW OF
THE REFERENCES THEY PROVIDE
SHOWS THAT TO THE THIRTY AND I
ACTUALLY. WEIGHT LOSS PRODUCTS
MORE PRESENT EVIDENCE THAT
THESE PRODUCTS ARE FREQUENTLY
USED BY TEAMS ARE AT THE LEVEL
BEYOND MANUFACTURER
RECOMMENDATION. UNFORTUNATELY
THE OWNER EXPAND IN THE BILL
AND THE BREATH OF THE PRODUCT
THE COLORS WILL LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. IN
PUSHING CONSUMERS TO PRODUCT.
PURCHASE PRICE FROM GILEAD
SELLERS AND ONLINE MARKETPLACES.
WHEN THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
I'M DAVE ADULTERATED PRODUCT
MAY BE SOLD. FOR THESE REASONS
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WE I DO
APPRECIATE AFTER MEETING WITH
THAT AND WE ARE COMMITTEDTO AN
ONGOING DIALOGUE- WITH HER
OFFICE SHOULD THE BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
COMMENTING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
DANTE STAMP THEM ASAP AND
ADVISERS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNCIL FOR RESPONSIBLE
NUTRITION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. BY WAY OF BE BRIEF
BACKGROUND HERE AND IS THE
LEADING TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING DIETARY SUPPLEMENT
AND FUNCTIONAL FOOD
MANUFACTURERS AND INGREDIENT
SUPPLIERS. LIKE THE DARK BY
THINKING THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR MEETING WITH US PRIOR TO
THIS HEARING TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS WE FELT LIKE THE
MEETING WAS PRODUCTIVE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DIALOGUE. HERE AND ALIGNED WITH
POSITION WITH THAT STATED BY
LITERACY IS THAT IT IS ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HERBAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
ONLY AT THE KEY POINTS. FIRST
THERE ARE UNFORTUNATELY SOME
BAD ACTORS OUT THERE WHO
PURPORTS TO SELL DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS FOR WEIGHT LOSS.
BUT WITH DECEPTIVELY AND
ILLEGALLY TAINTED THOSE
PRODUCTS WITH UNAPPROVED
PHARMACEUTICAL INGREDIENTS. TO
BE CLEAR THE INCLUSION OF SUCH
INGREDIENTS NO LONGER MAKE THE
PRODUCT OF DIETARY SUPPLEMENT
BY DEFINITION RATHER IT IS IN A
LEGAL PRODUCT THAT SHOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN SOLD OR MARKETED IN
THE FIRST PLACE. THE FDA HAS
WORK TO TAKE THESE PRODUCTS OFF
THE SHELVES BUT WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
STILL OUT THERE. HERE IN
SUPPORT FOR THE CRACKING DOWN
ON THE ACTORS TO ENSURE THE
TAINTED PRODUCTS NEVER MAKE IT
INTO THE HANDS OF MINOR. OR
ANYONE ELSE FOR THAT MATTER. I
CAN BETTER ALSO WITH. BOB AT
OUT THERE TO SELL WOULD GET HIM
A DIED. FAT WHICH USED. AND ONE
FIVE THE WRECK. DOSAGE STATE
AND EFFECTIVE. WE BELIEVE THOSE
FACTORS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO SELL THESE PRODUCTS
RESPONSIBLY IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE LAW. THE EXTENT REASONABLE
MIND MIGHT DISAGREE ON THE
UTILITY OF THESE PRODUCTS. WHAT
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON IS
THAT PRODUCT BANDIT THE
HARSHEST FORM A PRODUCT
REGULATION AND SHOULD THEREFORE
BE AFFIRMATIVELY SUPPORTED BY
AT THE- IN THIS CASE THE
EVIDENCE SHOULD SHOW
CORRELATION BETWEEN THESE
PRODUCTS ANY DISORDER. OR BODY
DYSMORPHIC DISORDER AT BIRTH
DEFECT BUT IT'S NOTED WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE SAUDIS TO
WHICH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SITES
ARE FACTUALLY FOR THE
LEGISLATION COULD NOT SHOW SUCH
A CORRELATION. SPECIFICALLY ONE
ARTICLES FOCUSED ON
BODYBUILDING IT DOES NOT SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENT. ANOTHER STUDY DID
NOT ATTEMPT TO FIND A
CORRELATION BETWEEN SUPPLEMENT
USE AND EATING DISORDERS. AND
ANOTHER IS A CASE STUDY MEANING
IT ONLY HAPPENED TO ONE PERSON
REGARDING THE USE OF BODY
BUILDING PRODUCTS. THIRD AND
FINALLY IN LIGHT OF EVERYTHING
I'VE MENTIONED WE DO BELIEVE.
THAT WITH MORE WORK IN DIALOGUE
THERE IS A WAY TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE TO FURTHER SEPARATE THE
GOOD ACTORS FROM THE BAD ONES
WITHOUT IMPOSING A PRODUCT FAN.
FOR THAT THAN THE OTHER AND
IT'S COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA
ON A PATH FORWARD. AND TO
FURTHER ASSIST IN HER EFFORTS
TO COMBAT BUT SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM WITH EATING
DISORDERS AND BODY DYSMORPHIA
MCCARTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR. OTHER FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT OF THOSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL- WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR
NAME. ORGANIZATION POSITION ON
THE BILL. AND WHEN MARK COULD
YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA AT SOME
POINT- MISTRUST HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE IN THE QUEUE ON THIS ONE.
ALL RIGHT JUST ONE MOMENT FOR
THOSE HO ARE OPPOSED. OR IN
FAVOR OF IT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ANDTHERE ON YOUR PHONE AN
OPERATOR WILL GET YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION. AND THEN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY GO AHEAD.
ALL RIGHT ONE MOMENT.
RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE FIVE IN Q. WOULDN'T
SPEAK OPERATORS TO GET THEIR
NAMES OKAY GREAT LET'S GO AHEAD
THEM WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. AND
PERSONAL GOALS ALIGN TO NINETY
THREE. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR PROBATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. MY NAME
IS JULIE AND I TACKLE YANO AND
I'M WITH THE STRATEGIC TRAINING
INITIATIVES FOR THE PREVENTION
EATING DISORDER AND I FULLY
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND NOW
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE EIGHTY
THREE. PLEASE TAKE YOUR- NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION. HI MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS DON
GILBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO LINE UP THREE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DALY FONG REPRESENT TEACHER
TEACHER TRAINING INITIATIVE FOR
THE PREVENTION OF EATING
DISORDERS HERE FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND NOW WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALTECH WITH THE
NATURAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION- THIS PROPOSAL UNDER
CONSIDERATION WOULD. LATER AND
STREET CORRECTIONS MOST LARGEST
MALL BUSINESS USERNAME AND
CAUSES AND WE AT EVERY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. JUST YOUR NAME I
WILL GO A LOT FROM MY NUMBER
THREE FIVE TWO CURRICULA
DEVELOPMENT IT'S JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AND- ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS A MEANDER FOOL FROM
STRAIGHT. A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCHER AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND IT TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI NINETEEN O'CLOCK AND
I AND USE OR YOUNG ADULTS I
SHOULD THINKING HOW NINE
SUPPORT. EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY.
THANK YOU MEXICO PLEASE. AND
THE LAST TIME HABITUS TIME IS
THREE TO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI AM CAGNEY ACTION ON BEHALF
OF THE STRATEGIC TRAINING THIS
YEAR FOR THE PREVENTION OF
EATING DISORDER INSURANCE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THAT WAS OUR LAST LINE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN THE
THANK YOU SOME OF THEM FOR
BRINGING US FOR WE SPOKE A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER TODAY ABOUT
THIS AND- I AM A LAYOFF THIS
BILL TODAY- BECAUSE I DO THINK
IT HAS MERIT. I DO THINK THIS
BILL IS VERY BROAD AS IT'S
CURRENTLY IN FRONT. OF THERE'S
A LOT OF PRODUCTS OUT THERE-
VERY SIMPLY WAY PROTEIN THAT ON
THE SHELF IN A LOT OF AREAS.
THAT HAS IN THE BILL.
THERMOGENIC WITHIN THAT
PARTICULAR PRODUCT THAT UNDER
THIS PARTICULAR BILL WOULD BE
BANNED OR HADLEY WRITTEN
REMOVED FROM THE SHELF AND
PLACED UNDER LOCK AND KEY. SO I
DO THINK THIS BILL HAS MERIT-
THERE IS SOME REALLY REALLY
AGGRESSIVE DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS
OUT THERE THAT SHOULD NOT BE IN
OUR KIDS HANDS I ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE THAT. I WOULD JUST LOVE
TO DEFINE IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
NARROWLY AND I WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT AND- I'M
SURE WE'LL HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION BUT- APPRECIATED
BRING THIS FORWARD I AM GONNA
LAY OFF OF IT BECAUSE I DO
THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S A LITTLE
BIT TOO BROAD. THANK YOU. MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD YOU KNOW THE
PANDEMIC REALLY LOT OF THINGS
CAME TO THE SURFACE. ONE OF THE
THINGS IS THESE YOUNG MEN-
YOUNG. BOYS AND GIRLS- ONLINE
AND BUYING THESE DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS. AND IF YOU HAVEN'T
SAT AROUND A TABLE WITH SOME
TEENAGERS RECENTLY- BATEI
STORIES ABOUT HOW THEIR- OF
FRIENDS ARE USING THESE. AND
THE FEAR THAT THE FAMILIES
HAVE. AND SO- IT'S A I THINK A
VERY TIMELY. BILL I KNOW THERE
MIGHT BE BROAD BUT I THINK THAT
IT'S GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I'M SURE SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU. I
WITH OTHERS BUT- I THINK IT'S A
REALLY GOOD BILL ND I'M GOING
TO TELL YOU. THERE'S NOTHING
WORSE THAN HAVING. THEY CAN GO
DOWN TO THE- THE LOCAL DOLLAR
STORE OR WHATEVER AND BE ABLE
TO PICK UP SOME PRODUCTS. SO
AGAIN I APPRECIATE FOR BRINGING
THAT FOR THEM I CAN COOPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISS MISS
KOREA. IS AN ODD MIKE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO
COMMITTEE- I CAN TELL YOU THAT
I REMEMBER BEING IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND BUYING THESE DIETARY PILLS
AND EVEN WOULD LIKE FOR MY
DRILL TEAM IN GIRLS SPORTS TEAM
WE WOULD SHARE THEM AND AT THE
TIME BEING SIXTEEN YEARS OLD
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW DANGEROUS
THEY ARE HOW DEFECTIVE THEY
ARE. HOWELL REALLY THE ISSUES
FACING YOUNG GIRLS ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO BODY SHAMING
WHEN IT COMES TO- YOU KNOW
SOCIETY STANDARDS ON BEAUTY
ETCETERA IT ALL PLAYS A ROLE SO
I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL IT'S ACTUALLY
QUITE REMARKABLE THAT WE HAVE
NOT DONE THIS BEFORE IN THE
STATE SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
AND I LOVE TO ALSO BE A I JOIN
AUTHOR A CO AUTHOR. IF YOU
WOULD HAVE ME AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON IN ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BUT
I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO ONE
THE BILL DOES- ENJOYED DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BUT JUST A POINT
OF CLARIFICATION WE GOT A LOT
OF CALLS FROM PEOPLE OPPOSING
THE BILL BECAUSE CONSUMERS
DON'T WANT THEIR SUPPLEMENTS
TAKEN AWAY. THE BILL DOES NOT
APPLY TO ALL SUPPLEMENTS I
WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THE DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS PURCHASED BY THOSE
PEOPLE UNDER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
AGE AND TO DETERMINE BY DPH I
WOULD WOULD NEED ACCESS
LIMITATIONS. RIGHT THANK YOU
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. HAS YES THANK YOU THIS
IS NOT BAD AYE THIS IS A SAYING
THAT ARE MINOR SHOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO DIET PILLS OUT THERE-
AND THE SUPPLEMENTS- WITHOUT
THEIR PARENTS ENGAGEMENT IN THE
DOCTOR'S ENGAGEMENT ON HOW TO
MANAGE UP AND SO. I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. ENCOURAGE WITH
THE FAR TO VOTE ON THE BILL IF
YOU REFERRED ME TO MAKE SURE WE
GET IT RIGHT- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY NEIGHBOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WITH THAT
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY WHAT. HI
WHAT I MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NONVOTING. BONTA BURKE
BURKE HI CARILLO. HI FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I TO.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO FEDERAL AYE
WALDRON. SIX ZERO THREE MAR
OKAY LEAVE THE BILL ON ARE
COMING TO VERY MUCH JUST TO
CLARIFY THEM THE MOTION WAS BY
MISS- AGIR CURRY THE SECOND BY
MR MCCARTY AND IT WAS INDEED TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY SO.
THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
FOUR OFF FIFTY. THIS GONZALEZ.
BOB DECHIARA. SEE IF I CAN.
MANAGE ALL MY PAPERS- I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY WELL
ESTABLISH A NEUTRAL AND
INDEPENDENT BODY TO OVERSEE
PARAMEDIC LICENSURE DISCIPLINE
CURRENTLY THE MERGING SEE
MEDICAL SERVICES A THORNY
ISSUES PARAMEDIC LICENSES
CONDUCTS DISCIPLINARY
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTES
COMPLAINTS THEY HOLD THE SOLE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE FINAL
DETERMINATIONS AND SERVIZI
INVESTIGATOR PROSECUTOR JUDGE
AND JURY WHEN TAKING LICENSURE
ACTIONS WHAT PARAMEDICS MAY
APPEAL TO AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE EVEN AFTER A LONG PROCESS
THE ALJ. DECISION IS SIMPLY A
PROPOSED DECISION AND GOES BACK
TO THE EMS AUTHORITY FOR FINAL
DETERMINATION IF THE PARAMEDICS
LICENSES REVOKED IN THE PROCESS
THE LIKELY LOSE THEIR
LIVELIHOOD BECAUSE MOST PERMITS
REQUIRE AN ACTIVE BLACK
LICENSE. NO OTHER CALIFORNIA
ISSUED A MEDICAL LICENSES LEFT
IN THE HANDS OF A SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE A FINAL AND
BINDING DECISION WITH SUCH
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
LICENSEES AB FOUR FIFTY WILL
ESTABLISH A BOARD OF MEDICAL
PEERS AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO BRING BALANCE AND FAIRNESS
TO THE PARAMEDIC DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS WITH ME TODAY ARE.
THINK VIRTUALLY- IN SUPPORT I
HAVE BRIAN RICE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL.
FIREFIGHTERS OR THE SPONSOR
THIS BILL. THANK VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND A SECOND THE
MOST REGISTER FOR A SECOND I
MISS BURKE. I BELIEVE. SO GO
AHEAD WITH OUR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SO THE MISMATCH CARE
AND MEMBERS OF THE CAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD I'M SORRY. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY REGARDING EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY NINE FRIEND SO THE
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS I
REPRESENT OVER THIRTY THOUSAND.
CAREER FIREFIGHTER EMT AND
PARAMEDICS I WAS THE THIRTY
YEAR PLUS VETERAN OF THE FIRE
SERVICE- HERE IN SACRAMENTO
SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND RETIRED AT THE
RANK OF DEPUTY CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS. CURRENTLY
PARAMEDICS- ARE LICENSED BY THE
STATE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY OR ANSWER-
TO PROVIDE CRITICAL ADVANCED
LIFE SUPPORT SERVICES. ANSWERED
ALSO IN THE FINAL TO IMPOSE
LICENSURE DISCIPLINE THEY CAN
TAKE SEVERAL FORMS INCLUDING
REVOCATION OR SUSPENSION-
IMPOSING CONDITIONS OF-
PROBATION OR- IMPOSITION OF
FLYING TOWARDS CERTAIN MINOR
OFFENSES. PARAMEDICS OFFER
OPERATE IN A VERY STRESSFUL AND
UNPREDICTABLE ENVIRONMENT AND
THEY OPERATE UNDER A VERY
STRICT SCOPE OF PRACTICE AND
MUST FOLLOW CLEARLY ARTICULATED
PROTOCOLS WHEN PERFORMING
PATIENT ASSESSMENTS IN
RENDERING CARE IN THE FIELD.
AND UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SOMETIMES MISTAKES ARE MADE
THAT IS WHY IT'S CALLED
PRACTICING MEDICINE. AND YOU
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS WHEN YOU
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS FOR CONDUCT
IT COULD BE A TRAINING ISSUE
THE RESULT OF BURN OUT COULD BE
A MORE SERIOUS ISSUE ALL
REQUIRES WITH MEASURED REVIEW
AN INTERVENTION. AND DESPITE
THE FACT DIFFERENT PROFIT
AGAINST A PARAMEDIC TAKE YEARS
TO RESOLVE THIS OP AND BEGINS
WITH AN INVESTIGATION AND
ACTION TAKEN BY THE EMPLOYER-
WHICH FREQUENTLY THE FIRST TO
BE AWARE OF THE ISSUE AND THEY
INTERVENE WITH DISCIPLINE OR
TRAINING AS APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER THE CASE CAN
INTENTIONALLY MOVE UP TO THE
STATE LEVEL WHERE ANSWER MADE-
RELEGATE THE SAME CONDUCT
IMPOSED DISCIPLINE ONCE AGAIN
OFTEN WITHOUT CONSIDERATION OF
ANY REMEDIATION- REMEDIATING
ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE EMPLOYER
OR EVEN- PROPOSED RULING
PERMITTED. MINISTRY OF LAW
JUDGE. UNLIKE EVERY OTHER
HEALTH PROFESSIONS WE'RE JUST
ON USER GETS A OR HER BY A BOY
OF THEIR PEERS THE PUBLIC THE
FINAL. FORTY FOUR PARAMEDIC
DISCIPLINE WISE WITH DIRECTOR
EVENTS- THE VERY AGENCY THAT
MAY BRING THE CHARGES. CBS OWN
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN CAUGHT UP IN
THE SUN CARE SYSTEM PILOT TIME
AGAIN AT COST YEARS- THEIR
LIVES THE NEW WORST EMPLOYMENT
THE CONSEQUENCES IN
OPPORTUNITIES WITH NOT A LOT OF
HOPE FOR JUSTICE. IN ONE CASE
TO ORANGE COUNTY PARAMEDICS
WERE CLEAR TO DISCIPLINE BY
THEIR EMPLOYER. INSTACART JIM
WITH INCOMPETENCE AND SUSPEND
THE LICENSES EVEN THOUGH ENABLE
JADED MINISTRY TO BLODGET'S
FOUND THE CASE DID NOT RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF INCOMPETENCE AND
RECOMMENDED NO ACTION BE TAKEN.
DIRECTOR MADE THE FINAL AND
BINDING DECISION TO IMPOSE
DISCIPLINE IN THE FORM OF A
LICENSE SUSPENSION AND OTHER.
PENALTIES YET ANOTHER INSTANCE
OF LOS ANGELES FIRE DEPARTMENT
PARAMEDIC- THAT IF PEOPLE CASE
OF MISCOMMUNICATION RESULTED IN
A LICENSE REVOCATION. AND ONCE
AGAIN UNVEILED J. FOUND THAT
CASE BROUGHT BY MS THAT DID NOT
HAVE MERIT. FOR THE PROPOSED
DISCIPLINE AND ONCE AGAIN THAT
RECOMMENDATION BY THE ALJ WAS
TO SATISFY- THE FINDING WHICH
WOULD STRIP THE MEDIC OF HIS
LIFE IN. AN APARTMENT- APPEAL
TO A SUPERIOR THE- ALSO FOUND
THAT MS COULD NOT FIFTY THE
CHAR AND- IT BACK. SIX YEARS
SIX YEARS INTO THE PROCESS THE
PARAMEDIC IS YET AGAIN IN FRONT
OF AN ALE J. FOR A NEW A NEW L.
J. FOR ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION.
THIS ISN'T FAIR IT'S NOT RIGHT
THAT AFTER SIX YEARS- ONE OF
OUR- FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDICS
WOULD ONCE AGAIN HAVE THEIR
LIVELIHOODS IN THE HANDS OF ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO SO CLOSELY TIED
TO THE INVESTIGATION. AND THE
OUTCOME WE'RE ASKING FOR A
NEUTRAL CLEARLY DEFINED
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS THAT
ALLOWS FOR LICENSEES TO
UNDERTAKE WITH CONFIDENCE. AND
FAIRNESS IN PROCEEDINGS INSTEAD
OF DRAWN OUT CASES THAT ARE
STACKED AGAINST THEM ARE OFTEN
TIMES- LEAVING THEM TO BELIEVE
THERE'S NO OTHER RECOURSE THAN
JUST ACCEPTING WHATEVER
DISCIPLINE IS IMPOSED. EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE SURE LICENSE
YOUR DISCIPLINE IT'S PROMPT
PROPORTIONATE CONSISTENTLY
APPLIED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
EVERY OTHER ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL PARAMEDICS
TO THE HIGHEST. PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS. PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND WHILE THE
SWEAT. CANNOT HELP HER MEDIC OF
OUR HAD THE UNDERGO HAVING
THEIR LAW TURNED UPSIDE DOWN AB
FOUR FIFTY OR BRING REASSURANCE
AND RELIEF TO THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS IN THE FIELDPROVIDING
HE INVESTED THROUGH THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I JUST ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT CONSISTENCY AND
FAIRNESS AND TO BE TREATED
EQUALLY LIKE ALL OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
LICENSED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT. THIS IMPORTANT BILL
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
UNDERSTAND YOUR AVAILABLE IN
THE GALLERY FOR QUESTIONS IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS ARE YOU ATTESTED
TESTIMONY HI GOOD MISTER CHAIR.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES SIR SURE
I'VE GOT MY DETAILS I JUST
ACTUALLY WORK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE OF THAT WAS MY
PRESIDENT SO I DID. I WAS ON
THE LINE EARLIER FOR AB THREE
EIGHTY NINE SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
INDULGENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THAT YOU. HOPEFULLY
WILL PASS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE ASKING FOR. PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES PUBLIC SEWER. PART COME
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION NAME
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE. HARPER PEOPLE OF FAULT
LINES. WHICH TO VOICE THEIR
OPINION PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT
THEY'RE ALL ON THE PHONE. RIGHT
NOW WE DO HAVE ONE LINE LINE
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES AND UNITED EMS
WORKERS ASKING LOCAL FOUR NINE
ONE ONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
MORE CALLS OF THE PARKLAND
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MOTION IS WAS MADE BY A
MISS- MISTER FLORES SECOND BY
MISS BURKE. MOTIONS TO PASSED
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT THAT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW I. BONTA. BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO CAREER I'VE LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I TO. RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON I FLORA FLORA HI.
SENATOR OF THE BILL'S TEN VOTES
IT'S OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ONTO THEIR
NEXT BILL MISTER JONES SAWYER
A. B. TEN FORTY TWO WHENEVER%
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TODAY I AM PRESENT IN AB
TEN FORTY TWO TO MAKE SURE NO
COMPANY CAN ESCAPE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PROVIDING SUB
STANDARD CARE TRY MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO BROADEN ITS SCOPE TO
SEEK PAYMENT FOR UNPAID.
NURSING HOME VIOLATIONS FROM
AFFILIATED BUSINESSES OWNED OR
CONTROLLED BY THE LICENSEE OF
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
NURSING HOMES BECAUSE OF THE
MOST DANGEROUS PLACE TO I'M
SORRY NURSING HOMES BECAME THE
MOST DANGEROUS PLACE TO LIVE
AND WORK DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH NEARLY
THIRTEEN THOUSAND LIVES LOST AT
THESE FACILITIES OVER THE PAST
YEAR. THAT'S ONE IN FOR COVERT
YES IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO
NEGLIGENCE AND UNSAFE PRACTICES
COMPLEX OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES
HAVE ALLOW BAD ACTORS DO
OBSCURE FINANCIAL ASSETS AND
LIMIT THEIR LEGAL. EXPOSURE TO
TRUTH ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS TYPE
TO COME A BETTER KNOWN AS
RELATED PARTIES FOR CLARITY
RELATED PARTY OR COMPANIES THAT
PROVIDE A WIDE VARIETY OF GOODS
AND SERVICES. TO NURSING HOMES
OF THE SAME OWNER IN EFFECT
THESE LICENSEES CAN OBSCURE TO
FINANCIAL ASSETS. AND MAKE THE
BUSINESS STRUCTURE SO
COMPLICATED THAT ENFORCEMENT OF
PENALTIES IS DIFFICULT. AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE ISN'T ASKED IF THERE'S AN
OUTSTANDING FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN UNPAID CITATIONS
THAT NURSING FACILITIES HAVE
FAILED TO PAY FOR QUALITY OF
CARE ISSUES. WHEN THREE OF THE
TOP FIVE NURSING HOMES THAT
RECEIVE THE MOST FINDS IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS ARE OWNED BY
LARGE CHAIN STILL US ACQUIRING
NEW FACILITIES IT IS CLEAR OUR
CURRENT ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
IS NOT WORKING. BY EXPANDING
WHO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH CAN
HOLD RESPONSIBLE FOR SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS. AB TEN FORTY TWO
BILLS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
INCENTIVIZES ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED IN THE OPERATION OF
NURSING HOME TO PROVIDE QUALITY
PATIENT CARE. WITH ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IT KEPT
ME WRITTEN. REYES WHITE WHITE
TEN WITH. S. E. I. U. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
STRUCTURE PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I WOULD SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE IF THEY'RE ON YOUR PART.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- COULD BE WHITE LOOK AT
THE EYES OF CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WE HAD A
BOTTLE OF AB TEN FORTY TWO I
THINK EARLY THANK AND
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THE VERY. IMPORTANT DOWN.
OUR MEDICAL NINETEENTH. HAS A
COUPLE LONG. ARE PRACTICES
BETTER CREATED AND- PROPERTY
DRIVEN IN. THAT STUCK WITH.
DEBATE AND MY- OF OUR WORK. AND
THE CALL OF CARE PER RESIDENT.
CHRONIC UNDERSTAFFING LACK OF
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT AND
LOOPHOLES IN THE SYSTEM ARE AT
THE ROOT OF THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY WHICH IS WHY. WE ARE
SEEKING TO IMPLEMENT REFORMS
THAT WILL MOST LIKELY. THAT THE
COURT ONE THAT IS BUILT ON
QUALITY TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AB TEN FORTY
TWO WEEKS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LIABILITY PRODUCTS HONORED IN
RELATED PARTY DISCO NURSING
FACILITIES BY DEFAULT IN THE
FOLLOWING. ONE OF THE SEVENTY
FELT TO PAY SPECIFIED FEES AND
PENALTIES. THAT ARE OF BETTER.
AND ALL APPEALS HAVE BEEN
EXHAUSTED BPH IS AUTHORIZED TO
NOTIFY AND RECOVER THE UNPAID
PENALTY AMOUNTS FROM THE
FACILITY OWNER OR RELATED
PARTY. TO A BOTTOM TO
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
DPH TO INFORM THESE RELATED
PARTY. REGARDING SYRIA
VIOLATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE IN THE FACILITY AND
RENDERS THE PARTIES RESPONSIBLE
FOR CLASS DOUBLE EIGHT EIGHT
AND THE VIOLATION. IS A CLASS
AND LEFT UNPAID BY THE OWNER.
AND THREE REQUIRED DH CS TO
NOTIFY AND INFORM RELATED
PARTIES THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
AND PAY QUALITY ASSURANCE WE
OFTEN UNDER THE CLOCK.
CURRENTLY THROUGH FRAGMENTED
OWNERSHIP. FACILITIES OWNERS
ARE PERMITTED TO OBSCURE
ACCESS. LIMIT LEGAL EXPOSURE
AND CONTRAST TO THEMSELVES AT
INFLATED PRICES. THIS IS DONE
THROUGH THESE RELATED PARTY
TRANSACTIONS. TRANSACTIONS MAKE
IT DIFFICULT FOR THE STATE TO
ENFORCE THE COLLECTION OF
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEES. AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY FROM
FACILITIES DUE TO THE MANY
ENTITIES OR RELATED PARTY-
BETTER HI. TO THE FACILITY.
RELATED PARTIES CAN BE MATH
COMPANIES I CAN'T COME. TO
MARKETING OR COULD COMPANY AND
CAN BE A BY THE NURSING. THE
OWNER FROM RELATIVE OR NON
ASSOCIATE. BE RELATED PARTY
PAYABLE INTO TO AND IN QUALITY
OF CARE. AND LIKE ANY RESPONSE
OF FOR FINANCE BENEFITS THAT
RESULTS ARE THE ISSUE. I BETTER.
WITH IT IS IMPORTANT TO FEEL IS
A CLASS MAY. OR BE BY. ALL
PARTIES ARE KNOWN NOTIFY. SO
THAT THE COULD ADEQUATE ADDRESS
AND RESPONSIBLE BE HELD A- CAN
BE VIOLATIONS IN THE CASE A
DIRECT ON HOW SHAPE OR SECURITY
OF RESIDENTS. CALLED A
VIOLATION AND THE M. DANGER OF
DEATH OR- HARM LOCAL. AND CLASS
W. BY. INDICATOR DON WRECKED
TALK TO MAKE CALLS OF DEATH
ABOUT THAT. ALTHOUGH THIS HAS
MADE EFFORTS TO. QUALITY OF BY.
INCENTIVES THE USE OF. DISCOUNT
THESE MEASURES ARE NOT AFFECT
AS THEY BE THERE CURRENTLY
REMAIN  LARGE PORTION. OF THE
CALL ASSURE BE GOLD UNPAID. DUE
TO POOR IN BOTH AND MINIMAL
CONTACT LOOK. STAFF FAILED TO
PAY THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ENDED
HAT IS BY. EIGHT MILLION OUT.
DOLLAR AS OF FEB YOU. TWENTY
TWENTY. ASIAN BECOME LESS OF
THE COLLECTION OF THE QUALITY
ASSURANCE SPEECH IS CRUCIAL
DRAWS. MUCH NEEDED FEDERAL MADE
FUNDS TO THAT. AB TWO FORTY TWO
AM TO PUT QUITE OF CARE AND
ACCOUNT- QUITE CARE IS THE G.
THROUGHOUT STAFFING STAFF WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND I THINK THAT'S-
IN THE CARE GIVER WORK FOR.
ADOBE ACCOUNT OF THE NOT GOING
ARE IN. IN NURSING AROUND THE
USE OF LATEST PARTY'S RESIDENTS
AT WORKERS WERE CONTINUE TO
SUFFER AT THE OF NAY HOME. YOU
THOSE INTO TO A- THEIR MEDICARE
AND MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT. FOR
THE BREEDERS WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
AND I DO WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE DID HAVE
OUR NUMBER MOGLIA OUT FROM ONE
OF THE FACILITIES WHO
UNFORTUNATELY IS UNABLE TO BE
WITH US TODAY. AND I WILL BE ON.
AGAIN THE COMMODORE HER BEHALF
AS WELL THANK YOU CAN MUCH.
THANK YOU MUCH. ZERO IN
ADDITIONAL WITNESS IN SUPPORTER.
SHE COULD MAKE IT OKAY VERY
WELL THANK YOU SO WITH THAT AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION. SO WE
WILL ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT. I JUST WANNA
BE FAIR HERE. I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE ARE SO AT THIS POINT WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
A PUBLIC COMMENT- IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL AND
MISREPRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. AND PEOPLE OF NEPAL ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO VOICE HER
OPINION ON A. B. TEN FORTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE ON THE LINE WILL BE
GETTING THEIR- MY NUMBER IN
JUST A MOMENT. THANK YOU. AND
LINE NUMBER THREE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS TONY CHICKEN TELL WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. NO MORE CALLS
ON THE LINE THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE THE BILL
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MISTER JONES
SAWYER WE HAVE A MOTION. A
MOTION BY MISTER IS THERE IN A
SECOND BY THIS BURKE- MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS- TAKE
A CLOSE MISTER JONES SAWYER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GO
AHEAD AND ASK MADAM SECRETARY
TO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. AND
CLIPPERS HI WHEN I MAYES. MAYES
NONVOTING. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NARROW BONTA BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO. LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. THE VERY.
NAZARIAN I TO. RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
FIVE ZERO- SORRY FIVE TO ONE
FIVE TWO ONE WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON COST YOUR TRANSFER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS POINT.
WE NEED OFF OR SO- SO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO AHEAD MISTER
NAZARIAN. WE HAVE MR LEVINE WAS
WAS HERE FOR QUITE AWHILE AND I
THINK HE GAVE UP ON THIS BUT
I'M PRETTY SURE HE'LL BE BACK.
OKAY. SHOULD I BEGIN WITH- ITEM
NUMBER. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO
PLEASE. K. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LET ME BEGIN BY FIRST OF
ALL ACCEPTING THE- COMMITTEES-
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS-
CURRENTLY MANY PATIENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE NOT GIVEN CLEAR
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE PROVIDES
INSTEAD THEY ARE FORCED TO FIND
OUT ISSUES WITH COST AND
PRESCRIPTION ALTERNATIVES AT
THEPHARMACY COUNTER. THIS LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY CAUSES MANY
CHALLENGES TO BOTH THE CONSUMER
THE PATIENT AND THE PROVIDER
WHEN PATIENTS AREN'T GIVEN THE
FULL PICTURE OF WHAT THEIR
BENEFITS PROVIDE THEY'RE OFTEN
LEFT PAYING HIGHER OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES THAN THAN
EXPECTED THAT OFTENTIMES THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THIS LEADS TO MANY
CHALLENGES MORE SPECIALLY THE
PATIENT UNDER MEDICATING UNDER
MEDICATED PATIENTS OFTEN HAVE A
HIGHER RISK OF A COMPROMISED
IMMUNE SYSTEM. AND ARE MORE
LIKELY TO CATCH A VIRUSES SUCH
AS COVERT NINETEEN. THAT IS WHY
I'VE INTRODUCED AB SEVEN FIFTY
TWO BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL
AUTHORIZE HEALTH PLANS TO
FURNISH SPECIFIED INFORMATION
ABOUT A PRESCRIPTION DRUG UPON
REQUEST. BY AN ENROLLEE OR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER USE IT
UTILIZING CURRENT AND AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY FOR MANY PATIENTS
HAVING THE OPTION TO KNOW THEIR
COST OPTIONS AND ALTERNATIVES
EARLIER IN THE TREATMENT
PROCESS IS A SERIOUS GAME
CHANGE. BECAUSE IT PROVIDES
THEM OPTIONS. FOR SOME FOR SOME
AS THE OPTION OF SIMPLY BEING
ABLE TO ASK THE QUESTION WHILE
THEY ARE IN THEIR DOCTORS
PRESENTS FOR OTHERS IT'S BEING
ABLE TO ENGAGE THEIR PROVIDER
ABOUT ALTERNATIVE TREATMENTS
POTENTIALLY COVERED BY THEIR
INSURANCE. WITH SOMEONE THEY
ALREADY HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIP WITH FOR
CLARIFICATION. THE DATA AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A. B. SEVEN
FIFTY TWO ALREADY EXIST THIS
BILL ABSOLUTELY DOES NOT CREATE
A NEW SEPARATE SYSTEM AND IT
DOES NOT MANDATE DOCTORS TO USE
A PARTICULAR SYSTEM. THIS BILL
SIMPLY GIVES THE PATIENT AND
THE PROVIDER THE ABILITY TO
PROCESS THE TO ACCESS
INFORMATION THROUGH THE
INTERMEDIARY OF THEIR CHOICE A
REQUIREMENT THAT IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH RECENTLY PASSED
FEDERAL REGULATION. REQUIRING
PLANS TO GIVE PATIENTS ACCESS
TO THEIR INFORMATION. BY
ADDRESSING THE LACK OF GLOBAL
PATIENT SPECIFIC INFORMATION
SHARING. AB SEVEN FIFTY TWO
EMPOWERS PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS
TO HAVE REAL TIME ACCESS TO
PATIENT SPECIFIC ELIGIBILITY
BENEFITS AND COVERAGE
INFORMATION AND IN THE PROCESS
SAVES THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR AND
WASTED ON OUT DATED HIGHLY
BURDENSOME TASKS THAT CAN AND
SHOULD BE AUTOMATED. I'M JOINED
BY- PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION LIZ HELMS AND TIM
MADDEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE. I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK IS THERE IN THE
WE'LL GO TO- YOUR WITNESSES. IS
IT GOING TO BE MRS HOLMES WAS
THAT MRS HOLMES WAS GONNA BE
FIRST MISS HELMS AND- TWO MEN
OKAY MRS HOLMES. THANK YOU.
WILL YOU TELL ME WHEN YOU'RE
READY. YES READY. HELLO THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN WORD I DON'T
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITY MY NAME IS WITH HIM
I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT CHECK
POLLUTION OR FORESEES WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE TWO THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING YOU THE FOURTEENTH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
VIEWS ON THE PATIENT CHOICE AND
TRANSPARENCY ACT I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK MY NUMBER IS AREA
OFFERING CHARCOAL AUTHORS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MARIE WALDRON
ROB BONTA AND SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER THE FOURTEENTH OF THE
COALITION OF MORE THAN THIRTY
LEADING STATEWIDE CONSUMER
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WILL.
PROVIDE A GROUP THAT PROMOTES A
COLLABORATIVE WORKING
POLICYMAKERS INDUSTRY LEADERS
PROVIDERS AND CONSUMERS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
CHIU ABLE DECISION MAKING
TOWARD HER WORK SHOULD BETWEEN
A PATIENT AND THE PHYSICIAN
PATIENT WOULD BE CENTRAL ACTIVE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THEIR ONLY I
WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO STICK
WITH THEIR TREATMENT PLAN THIS
BILL IS CRITICAL AND FINALLY
SHE GAVE UP TIME CONSUMING AND
FRUSTRATING PROCESS WITH THAT
WAY ON PATIENTS. AND THEIR
PROVIDERS. ABOUT THEIR
HEALTHCARE GREAT WHAT CAN. YEAH
OFTEN THE HIM FOR IS ABOUT
UNTIL AFTER THEY WERE BARBECUE
COUNTER WITH A NEIGHBOR WHICH
LOCAL PART OF AND THEY GAVE
THEM. THEM ALTOGETHER. WE HEAR
ABOUT THEIR ALL THE TIME. SO
CARE ONLY WITH PATIENTS STATE
OF BUT ALSO WE CAN CREATE YOUR
LOSING IS A MORE COST
HEALTHCARE FOR THEIR OUT. FORTY
BILLION BY FREEING UP EXISTING
DRUG DATA FOR PATIENTS WHILE
REDUCING STRAIN ON PHARMACISTS
AND PHYSICIANS. ACCORDING TO
THE COVER MINUS TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MEDICATION ACCESS REPORT
67% OF PATIENTS ARE GONNA PICK
UP A PRESCRIPTION TO FIND A
CLOCK MORE THAN EXPECTED. IN
THEIR REPORT 82% OF PROVIDERS
LOOK VERY WHAT ARE
AUTHORIZATION A TIME CONSUMING
PART OF THEIR DAY AND THAT SUCH
THERE ARE YEARS TAKE AWAY FROM
HAVING FONG RENEWABLE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY. WITH PATIENTS. EIGHT
SEVEN FIVE TWO OFFERS REAL TIME
POLLUTION BUT WILL LEVERAGE
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY TO
STRENGTHEN PATIENT BETTER CARE.
ENSURE DECISION MAKING
HAPPENING HELLO THE PROGRAM
NINETY THE TWENTY PROVIDER AND
PATIENT RANGERS TV OF THE
WELFARE BURDEN UPON PROVIDERS.
INCREASE IN HERE STOCKBROKER
MEDICATION AND IMPROVE QUALITY
AND ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS DIVISION. IN ADDITION
BUT NOT MANY REASONS DALY
STATED WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALLOWING THE PARTIES. CARE
ACT ARGUES TODAY. THANK YOU MRS
HOW IN THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE
SIDE WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND TEN BATON WITH THE CAL
RHEUMATOL ALLIANCE REPRESENT
REMOTE TO THROUGH K. CAN WITH
ROOM. I'VE BEEN ONE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THEY FACE WITH HER
PATIENCE IS THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE PATIENT'S
HEALTH INSURANCE AND UNDERSTAND
THE DETAILS OF THE PATIENT'S
DRUG BENEFITS. WHEN
RHEUMATOLOGISTS ARE DEVELOPING
A CARE PLAN FOR THEIR PATIENTS
CHRONIC DISEASE THE UNDERSTAND
CAUSES AN ISSUE. AND TRY TO
INCORPORATE THIS ASPECT INTO
THE DECISION ON WHAT MEDICATION
TO PRESCRIBE THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE DETAILS
OF THE PATIENT'S DRUG BENEFITS
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS INCLUDING. NOT
KNOWING WHAT DRUG IS NOT A
GIVEN HEALTH PLAN OR HEALTH
INSURER'S FORMULARY FOR THE
SPECIFIC PATIENT AND THEIR
COVERAGE. WHETHER THE DRUG IS
SUBJECT TO STEP THERAPY OR
OTHER PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS. WHAT ARE THE
PATIENTS RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
ANY OUT OF POCKET COSTS SUCH AS
DEDUCTIBLES AND CO PAYS. EACH
HEALTH PLAN AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY HAS THEIR OWN
PORTAL PROVIDING DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS OF INFORMATION MANY
TIMES NOT SPECIFIC TO THE
PATIENT COVERAGE AND DRUG
BENEFITS. NOT KNOWING THIS
INFORMATION CREATES ISSUES WHEN
THE PATIENT GOES TO THE
PHARMACY TO GET A PRESCRIPTION
FILLED. AT THE PHARMACY THE
PATIENT LEARNS THEY HAVE LARGE
OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES THEY
CAN'T AFFORD. SOMETIMES THE
PHARMACY WILL CALL THE
RHEUMATOLOGIST AND LOOK INTO
PRESCRIBE A DIFFERENT
MEDICATION BUT MOST TIMES
PATIENTS SIMPLY DO NOT FILL THE
PRESCRIPTION. THE PATIENT THEN
RETURNS TO THE RHEUMATOLOGIST
FOR THE NORMAL CHECK IN ONLY TO
TELL THEM THAT THEY NEVER FILL
THE PRESCRIPTION AND THE
CONDITION WORSENED. THE
RHEUMATOLOGIST THEN HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS HOPING
THE NEW MEDICATION THEY
PRESCRIBED IS ONE THE PATIENT
CAN AFFORD. EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
TWO WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS HELP
RHEUMATOLOGISTS. UNDERSTANDING
THE PATIENT SPECIFIC
INFORMATION THROUGH ONE PORTAL
THAT CAN BE UTILIZED IN THE
RHEUMATOLOGIST WORK FLOW
SYSTEMS WILL INCREASE THE
PATIENT'S ABILITY TO START THE
TREATMENT THEY'VE BEEN
PRESCRIBED. THIS PROVIDES MORE
INSURANCES. THE PATIENT WILL BE
ADHERENT IMPROVES THE PATIENT
PHYSICIAN RELATIONSHIP. MOST
IMPORTANTLY A FULLY INFORMED
PRESCRIPTION PROVIDES GREATER
CONFIDENCE THE PATIENT WILL
PICK UP THEIR MEDICATION AND BE
IT HERE AND TO THE PRESCRIBED
THERAPY. THAT MEANS THEY ARE
MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
IMPROVED HEALTH AND HAVE A
BETTER OUTLOOK ON THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. THE PATIENTS
INTERESTING CARE ARE THE FIRST
CONCERN FROM A COLLEGES. THE
ISSUES OUTLINED ALSO CREATED
UNNECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON RHEUMATOLOGIST IN
THEIR PRACTICE WHICH TAKES
VALUABLE TIME AWAY FROM SEEING
PATIENTS. IN FOR PRESCRIBING
CAN REDUCE CALL BACKS FROM THE
PHARMACY RELATED TO THIS
PRESCRIPTION REJECTION BY THE
PATIENT. AS WELL AS REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF CALLS INTERACTIONS
AND TIME SPENT WITH HEALTH
PLANS AND HEALTH INSURERS. THIS
TIME COULD IN TURN BE USED TO
SEE MORE PATIENTS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH- ARE THERE ANY- WITNESSES.
RIGHT TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
MORE TIME ON AB SEVEN FIFTY TWO
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR OTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- NICK
LEWIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS- WE HAVE A
POSITION OF OPPOSE ON THE BILL
THAT IS IN PRINT- WE REALIZE
THE NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS ARE
GOING INTO THE BILL TODAY- AND
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSORS AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. BEFORE I'M HEARING OUT
OUR CONCERNS ON THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE- HEALTH PLANS IN
CARRIERS ARE CERTAINLY NOT
OPPOSED TO THE IDEA PROVIDING
USEFUL INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS- ESPECIALLY TO ASSIST
THEM IN MAKING IMPORTANT
DECISIONS ABOUT PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS- IN OTHER ASPECTS OF
THEIR HEALTH CARE- INDEED- THE
PLANS VERY. PROVIDING MUCH OF
THIS INFORMATION ARE REQUIRED
UNDER EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY TWO-
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE GOING INTO
THE BILL TODAY- REVIEW THE BILL
ONCE IT GOES INTO PRINT- AND-
POTENTIALLY REASSESS OUR
POSITION MOVING FORWARD- IF WE
HAVE A POSITION CHANGE. AS A
RESULT OF THE AMENDMENTS- WILL
BE NOTIFYING THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMUNITY- AS SOON AS THAT
HAPPENS- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LOUISA SAYS THERE A%
SECOND WITNESS MY GUESS IS THAT
THERE ISN'T BUT JUST TO MAKE
SURE. ALL RIGHT WITH THE MISS
MODERATOR WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- ARE THERE IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WISHES TO.
TO ADD ON THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEN THEIR
POSITION. ON THE BILL. MISTER
MODERATOR. I NUMBER FOUR OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES AT THE NATION
END OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AND ONE FOUR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
LINE FOR OCTOBER PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDED MARCHING WITH
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN LINE
FOUR OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ON BEHALF OF THE CHRONIC CARE
POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. ONE
THREE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THREE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEVEN CHOI
JOKES ARE PRESENTATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE ANYMORE CALLERS.
YES WE HAVE. ANOTHER SIX IN Q.
OKAY. WE GOT A LINE FOR ALL
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON YES MEAN PELLET ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH BACK WITH
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY WE ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. IN FOUR HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH SHARE MEMBERS
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE UP THE
AMERICAN AMERICAN HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS A HIP- WE JUST
ACT OF THE COMET THE CAP AND
ARE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSE OUR-
EVALUATING THE MEMBERS THANKS.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. ONE
FOUR ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU FOR TAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE THREE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS SHELBY
DO VERY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER I
THINK WE HAVE TO MORE ALIGNED
YES TO MORE ONE FOUR ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBER MELISSA CORTEZ
REPRESENTING COVER MY MEDS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I THINK LAST
CALLER. M. BECOME TORN FOR
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MICHELLE REBIRTH OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR ANYBODY ELSE
WAS AT THAT COMPLETED. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT
THIS IME GREAT THANK YOU WE'LL
WE'LL BRING IT BACK INTO MY
HEAD BACK OVER TO THE CHAIRMAN.
CHAKA COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TRANSITIVITY. SEEING
NONE OF THE BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OF THE
RECOMMENDATION IS HANG ON A
SECOND WHICH- YEAH. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS NO IT'S NOT IT
IS IT IS IT IS IN THE P. R. AS
A MAN IT DEPENDS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. HELLO MISTER MISTER
MAYES IS THAT MOVES THE BILL
MISS BURKE IS THE SECOND-
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NONVOTING
BONTA. BURKE BURKE HI CARILLO.
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN VERY HIGH TO.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO
FIVE ZERO FIVE WALDRON WALDRON
HIGH. EIGHT ZERO YOU HAVE EIGHT
VOTES BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN BUT
THE BILLS OUT OF COMMITTEE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
SINCE YOU'RE HERE. OF I. EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE PLEASE WHILE
YOU'RE THERE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AB EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE REQUIRES HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO OFFER
AN HIV TEST TO ANY PATIENT FOR
WHOM A BLOOD DRAW IS ALREADY
BEING DONE. IN ORDER TO
MINIMIZE ANY BURDEN. ON THE E.
D. ON THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
THE BILL WOULD FURTHER EXEMPT
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS FROM
EXISTING LAW REGARDING HIV
TESTING SUCH AS PRETEST
COUNSELING AND POST TEST
COUNSELLING. AND EXCLUDES
PATIENTS IN A LIFE THREATENING
SITUATION. THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
THE EASY TO USE RAPID HIV
TESTING OR HOME TEST KITS.
DESPITE SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS IN
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WITH HIV OR WITH NEW HIV
DIAGNOSES THE STATE STILL HAS
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVING WITH HIV
AND IS EXPERIENCING FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED NEW DIAGNOSIS EVERY
YEAR. WE HAVE BEEN LARGELY
SUCCESSFUL IN FINDING PEOPLE
WHO HAVE RISK FACTORS SCREENING
THEM AND GETTING THEM INTO CARE
AND TREATMENT IF NECESSARY. IT
IS THE CARE AND TREATMENT
INCLUDING EFFECTIVE DRUG
TREATMENT REGIMENS THAT HAVE
PEOPLE LIVING WITH HIV WELL
INTO THEIR SENIOR YEARS AND
BEING PRODUCTIVE HEALTHY
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY. HOWEVER WE
HAVE NOT BEEN AS SUCCESSFUL
WITH PEOPLE WHO DO NOT USUALLY
ENGAGE- I'M SORRY WHO WHO DO
NOT USUALLY ENGAGE IN IT WHO
USUALLY ENGAGE IN RISKY
BEHAVIORS ARE IN DENIAL ABOUT
THEIR RISKY BEHAVIORS OR
UNAWARE. OF THEIR RISK OF
EXPOSURE BY A PARTNER. LARGELY
THAT IS WHY WE CONTINUE TO SEE
SO MANY NEW INFECTIONS EACH
YEAR. MAGNIFYING THE PROBLEM IS
THE FACT THAT ACCORDING TO THE
CDC. COLLEAGUES 15% OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNAWARE OF THEIR HIV
POSITIVE STATUS ARE RESPONSIBLE
440% OF THE NEW INFECTIONS LET
ME JUST REPEAT THAT AGAIN
BECAUSE THAT'S KID CRITICAL
HERE. ACCORDING TO CDC 15% OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNAWARE OF THEIR
HIV POSITIVE STATUS ARE
RESPONSIBLE 440% OF THE NEW
INFECTIONS OF THAT. 15% 45% OF
THEM ALMOST HALF OF THAT
POPULATION FALLS WITHIN THE
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR AGE
RANGE. HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS ARE THE LAST MAJOR
COMPONENT OF THE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR HIV TESTING
DOES NOT ROUTINELY OCCUR THE
CDC AND A CALLED ON ROUTINE HIV
TESTING IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS MORE THAN THREE
DECADES AGO. IN THE REPORT ON
THE- EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT HIV
TESTING PILOT PROGRAM CREATED
BY AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE-
AUTHORED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN- THE TO RESPOND TO THE
SHORTAGE OF HIV TESTING
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AS
ENACTED THE BILL CREATED A
PILOT PROGRAM SO THAT THE STATE
COULD BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
KIND OF TESTING THAT IS
OCCURRING. IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS AND EFFECTIVE
PROTOCOLS THAT EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN EMPLOYING
IN DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH RELEASED THE
RESULTS OF ITS PILOT PROGRAM
THAT REAFFIRMED THE VALUE OF
ROUTINE HIV TESTING IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS. EVEN THE
EDUCATIONAL AFFILIATE OF THE
AMERICAN HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
PROFESSES THE VALUE OF ROUTINE
HIV TESTING AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS- COLLEAGUES JUST SO
YOU KNOW BY THE WAY. AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE ESTABLISHED
SIX PILOT PRO TO PROJECTS.
SEVENTY THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE WERE TESTED BECAUSE OF
THAT BILL. ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY PEOPLE HAD
POSITIVE HIV CASES WHO WERE NOT
AWARE WHICH YIELDED A ONE POINT
7% OUTCOME ONE POINT 7% ALMOST
TWO PEOPLE OUT OF EVERY HUNDRED
THAT SHOWED UP TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM IN THIS AGE RANGE DID NOT
KNOW THAT THEY WERE HIV
POSITIVE AND THEY GO ON TO IN
FACT FORTY PERCENT. MORE PEOPLE-
WITH THAT I BELIEVE I'M JOINED
BY RAND MARTIN- AND- WITH THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN CONTINUING THIS WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR ASSYRIAN
IN THE GALLERY MISTER MARTIN
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. BY. NO. RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION- APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MISTER NAZARIAN JUST
PROVIDED A GOOD SUMMARY OF THE
BILL- I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT IT'S LONG ACCEPTED IN
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT JUST GETTING
A TEST RESULT JUST KNOWING YOUR
HIV STATUS CHANGES BEHAVIORS
COMPELS PEOPLE TO GET INTO CARE
AND TREATMENT EVEN WITHOUT ALL
THE COUNSELING AND OTHER THINGS
THAT WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO
THROUGH. SO IT'S PARAMOUNT TO
GET PEOPLE INTO TESTING ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HF HAS BEEN
DOING FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS JUST TRYING TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS GET ROUTINE PAP
TESTING HAPPENING IN MORE
LOCATIONS SO WE HAVE CHANGED
THE TESTING PROCESS BY LAW WE
HAVE MORE TESTING GOING ON IN
PUBLIC HEALTH CLINICS WE HAVE
INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT ARE
NOW REQUIRED TO PAY FOR HIV
TESTING IN EMERGENCY ROOMS ALL
WITH THE GOAL OF IMPROVING- ART
HIV TESTING IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LAST THE LAST PLACE THAT A JOB
IS REALLY PUSHING TO GET HIV
TESTING MORE ROUTINE IS IN THE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
FOR THE REASONS THAT-MISTER
NAZARIAN HAS ALREADY DESCRIBED-
BUT THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE OF
THE ER AS A AS A GOOD PLACE FOR
HIV TESTING GOES BACK TO THE
MID NINETIES WHEN THE CDC FIRST
ANNOUNCED THAT THIS WAS A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE SHOULD BE GETTING
GETTING- GETTING TESTED WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE COMPLICATIONS OF
ANY EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT THE
CAPACITY OF STAFF THERE TO DO
THE THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO
DO. WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE
FOR AN URGENT REASON SO WE HAVE
TAKEN A LOT OF AMENDMENTS MET
THEM WE THANK MORE THAN HALFWAY
TO TRYING GET TO MAKE IT EASIER
ON THEM TO ACTUALLY FACILITATE-
THIS OF THIS POLICY OBJECTIVE
BUT AT AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THE OBJECTIVE NEEDS TO BE
MET WITH A ONE POINT 7%
POSITIVITY RIGHT OUT OF THAT
PILOT PROJECT MEANS THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO DO NOT KNOW
THEIR HIV POSITIVE. WHO CAN BE
CAPTURED. IN IN THAT PROCESS
AND CAN- CAN TRY AROUND WELL
HEALTHCARE. AND PROTECT PEOPLE
THAT THEY INTERACT WITH. I WANT
TO CLOSE MY SIMPLY QUOTING.
FROM THE STUDY THAT MISTER
NAZARIAN REFERENCED IN WHICH
THEY SAID. BECAUSE HIV INFECTED
PATIENTS VISIT THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. AT MORE THAN TWICE
THE RATE OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. AND THEY MAY. SERVE
AS THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF CARE
FOR MARGINALIZED INDIVIDUALS
MOST AT RISK FOR HIV INFECTION.
THE ROUTINE OFFERING OF AN HIV
TEST IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT OF A HOSPITAL CAN BE
AN EFFECTIVE MEANS TO DIAGNOSE
LINK AND RE ENGAGE PATIENTS AND
CARE WE ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GO TO
THE PHONE LINES NOW- I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
YES THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS TIM
MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE. FIRST OF ALL
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR FOR THEIR TIME AND
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS OUR ON GOING
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH A SPONSOR ON
THIS ISSUE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. ARE THE AUTHOR
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION AS HE
MENTIONED WHICH EVENTUALLY LED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLISHING REPORT ABOUT
HIV TESTING IN THE MARKET IN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. OUR
CONCERNS IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ARE THE SAME AS THEY
ARE TODAY. MANY OF OUR CONCERNS
WERE IDENTIFIED AS BARRIERS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THREE HEALTH REPORT WHICH
EXAMINED HOSPITALS THAT
VOLUNTARILY IMPLEMENTED A
PROGRAM TO OFFER HIV TESTING.
IN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS. WELL
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
THE AB THIRTY FIVE IMPROVE THE
CONSENT PROCESS THERE ARE STILL
A CONVERSATION REQUIRED.
BETWEEN THE PHYSICIAN AND THE
PATIENT THAT IS BOTH TIME
CONSUMING AND POTENTIALLY
MISSED TIME. PATIENTS WHO WERE
IN THE MERCY DEPARTMENT WITH
SERIOUS CONCERNS ARE LIKELY
AFRAID. AND ARE NOT IN THE
FRAME OF MIND TO BE DISCUSSING
HIV TEST. THEY MAY BE UPSET
WITH THE TREATING PHYSICIAN FOR
DISCUSSING PERFORMING AN HIV
TEST WHEN HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEIR SYMPTOMS LEADING TO
LONGER CONVERSATION. THESE
CONVERSATIONS ADD THIS
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME TO
THE TOTAL TIME THE CARE
PROVIDED IN BUSY EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. ACCORDING TO THE
CDC BLOOD DRAWS ARE PERFORMED
ON 42% OF ALL PATIENTS. IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
MERCY DEPARTMENTS TREAT OVER
FOURTEEN MILLION PATIENTS PER
YEAR. EVEN IF ADDING AN HIV
TEST EACH OF THESE ENCOUNTERS
ONLY TOOK AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MINUTES. THAT WOULD RESULT IN
AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY NINE
MILLION MINUTES OF CARE. EACH
YEAR THAT EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS-WOULD BE ASKED TO PROVIDE.
THERE IS NO WAY TO ABSORB THIS
WITHOUT IMPACTING THE
TIMELINESS AND QUALITY OF CARE
PROVIDED TO ALL PATIENTS. IN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPORT STATES QUOTE. PROGRAM
FIFTEEN ABILITY MAY HINGE UPON
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ABILITY
TO IDENTIFY HOW TO COVER THE
ACTUAL COST OF SCREENING
PATIENTS FOR HIV. AB EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE DOES NOT ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS AND WOULD
ADDITIONALLY RESULT IN
UNEXPECTED COST UNINSURED
PATIENTS. SIMILARLY IT INSURED
PATIENTS MAY HAVE A SHARE OF
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH TESTING
WHICH WILL LIKELY BE UNKNOWN TO
THEM AT THE TIME THE OFFER IS
MADE. EMTALA WHICH IS THE LAW
THAT REQUIRES THE MERCY
DEPARTMENTS TO TREAT ANYONE
COMING IN DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
THE DISCUSSION OF COST OF CARE
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
THE REPORT ALSO POINTED OUT ALL
THE HOSPITALS WHO WERE IN THE
PILOT PROGRAM RECEIVE SOME
LEVEL OF EXTERNAL FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE PILOT.
LASTLY IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL THE SPONSOR RECOGNIZES
THERE ARE WHAT THEY CALL
ADDITIONAL OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES. BUT STATE THAT
THESE OPERATIONAL ISSUES SHOULD
NOT GET IN THE WAY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE IMPORTANT THING TO
KEEP IN MIND IS IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT THESE
OPERATIONAL ISSUES ARE NOT
SIMPLY AN ADMINISTRATIVE HASSLE
THEY RESULT IN DELAYED CARE FOR
OTHER PATIENTS WITH
EMERGENCIES. THIS IS NOT A
QUESTION OF AN ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS VERSUS PUBLIC HEALTH
THIS IS A QUESTION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SCREENING VERSUS HEALTH
OF OTHER EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
PATIENT. IT'S A DIFFICULT
CHOICE BUT WE MUST ADVOCATE FOR
THE GREATEST GOOD. FOR THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF PATIENTS FOR
THESE REASONS REMAIN IN A LOOK
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR OTHER FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT- AND PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT-
POSITION NAME POSITION AND
ORGANIZATION ONLY PLEASE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTRUST
REITER. AND WE HAVE COME FROM
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CON EL GATO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY NURSES ASSOCIATION
THERE WAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE
INTO IT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WITH MISTER
SMITH YEAH IF I JUST WITH THE
WITH THE AUTHOR THE DAUGHTER
WANTS TO HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE I.
HAVE GOT THE A LETTER HERE
FROM. THE EMERGENCY THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. AND THE POINTS THAT
THEY BRING UP IN HERE AND I
THINK THEY ADDRESSED THE IN
THEIR OPPOSITION SEEM TO BE-
THE REAL AND- AND I'M
SYMPATHETIC CAN YOU CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT THE IDEA OF
CONSENT- THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
WOULD TAKE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS. THE COST BENEFIT- OF IT.
THANK YOU OR BRINGING THAT UP
I WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO ADDRESS
THAT IN MY CLOSING BECAUSE I
DID HERE. MR MADDEN BRING IT UP
AND I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE.
WITH WHAT HE PRESENTED AND I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE. MISTER MARTIN
ALSO JOIN IN IF I'M MISSPEAK IN
OR SAYING ANYTHING THAT'S WRONG
BUT FIRST OF ALL. FROM WHAT I
RECALL HEARING HE SAID IT TAKES
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES.
COLLEAGUES THIS IS NOT GOING TO
TAKE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES
THIS IS GONNA BE PART OF AN
EXISTING BLOODWORK TEST THAT
HAPPENS. WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL IS
ADMITTED INTO THE ER ROOM. AS I
SAID VERY SPECIFICALLY EARLY ON
IN IN MY COMMENTS- THIS BILL
REQUIRES HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS TO OFFER AN HIV
TEST THAT ANY PATIENT FOR WHOM
A BLOOD DROP IS ALREADY BEING
DONE. SECOND IT REQUIRES A
CONSENT SO IF A PATIENT IS IN A
LIFE THREATENING CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY'VE BEEN ADMITTED TO THE
HOSPITAL BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
A- ACCIDENT. DAY CAN'T SPEAK
THEY WILL NOT BE ASKED FOR
CONSENT THEY WILL JUST NOT BE
GIVEN THAT TEST. BECAUSE IT
WILL NOT HAPPEN UNLESS THEY
CONSCIOUSLY GIVE A VERBAL
CONSENT TO THE TEST- TO THIS
TESTING WE'VE BEEN AND I DO
APPRECIATE MR MADDEN ALSO
POINTING OUT THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS SINCE I WAS
FIRST ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. THIS IS THIS IS BEEN
pTIME. AFTER THE MAGIC JOHNSON
GENERATION. OF YOUTH WHO WERE
IMPACTED WHEN MAGIC JOHNSON
CONTRACTED HIV AND THE WHOLE
WORLD BECAME MORE AWARE. OF
WHAT HIV DOES EVERYONE TOOK
MORE PRECAUTIONS- THE
TECHNOLOGY AROUND HEALTH CARE
ALSO ADVANCED WE WERE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH. CARE THAT IS NOW
MORE AFFORDABLE- AND ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO LIVE LONGER BUT THE
REALITY IS WE STILL NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP CATCHING
IT EARLY ENOUGH SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE HEALTH ARE
NECESSARY SO THAT THERE AREN'T
OTHER CONSEQUENCES AS WELL. AS
WELL AS A RAPID RAPIDLY GROWING
RATE OF INFECTION ESPECIALLY
AMONG YOUNGER THE AGE RANGE
THAT I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WHICH TENDS TO BE MORE
PROMISCUOUS. AND ENGAGE IN
RISKY BEHAVIOR. SORRY I WENT ON
A BIT LONGER THAN WHAT YOUR
QUESTION WAS ASKING BUT WAS
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT I
CAPTURE EVERYTHING. I JUST-
THIS IS AN ABOUT AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO ME- I KNOW ALONG WITH
MY OTHER COLLEAGUE- FROM THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WE'VE- WORKED
ON CAMPAIGNS WITH- GET TESTED
COACHELLA VALLEY BECAUSE JUST
YOUR POINT THE MORE PEOPLE THAT
ARE TESTED THE DON'T KNOW. THE
BETTER OFF- THE TECHNOLOGY THE
SCIENCE- IS IT IS GOTTEN IS
BECOME AMAZING I THINK OF PREP
AND PAT. AND THE EARLIER THAT
YOU CATCH IT THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO ARREST IT- IS- IS THERE
AND SO- YOUR YOUR DESIRE TO
WANT TO WORK IN THE SPACE- I'M-
ALSO VERY SYMPATHETIC I JUST
I'M CONCERNED THAT WE'VE GOT
EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIANS
SAYING THAT THIS THIS IS GOING
TO CREATE. ISSUES FOR THAT I'M
AND I'M TRYING TO SQUARE THE
CIRCLE A LITTLE BIT. A LITTLE
BIT THERE AND- AND SO YOU KNOW
AGAIN I'VE I GUESS I'D WHAT I
HEARD FROM YOU IS THAT MAYBE
THE EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIANS
DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL OR THE OR
IS THERE MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
A TO BE DONE HERE. I LOOK I'VE
MADE MYSELF AVAILABLE I'VE
WORKED WITH THEM IN. EVERY
TURN. THIS IS. I I'VE DONE NOW
WHAT THE FIRST BILL WAS VETOED.
AT THE SECOND ONE WAS NARROWLY
CRAFTED SO THAT IT WOULD CREATE
THE PILOT PROGRAMS THAT ENDED
UP RESULTING IN THE STUDY THAT
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE IS A
NEED WHEN 2% THERE IS 2%
INFECTION RATE. YET WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT FRACTIONS ANYMORE
IT'S TO HOLD BODIES BEING
INFECTED AND EXT PASSING IT ON
TO OTHERS- AND THAT'S WHY WE
LOOK. GIVEN THE STRENGTH OF THE
STUDY AND WHEN SEVEN OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THIS AND HAVE
BEEN STUDY AND BY THE WAY LET'S
NOT FORGET SEVENTY THOUSAND WHO
GAVE CONSENT. TO BE TESTED. SO
IT'S EVEN A SUBSET OF EVERYONE
WHO'S BEEN ADMITTED TO THE C.
R. ROOMS. UP WHEN YOU HAVE
THESE NUMBERS WHICH BY THE WAY
THE REASON I'M BRINGING THAT UP
IS BECAUSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WHO ARE. CONDUCTING AND
EXPOSING THEMSELVES TO RISKY
BEHAVIOR- ARE PROP PROBABLY IF
THEY WERE TESTED MOST OF THOSE
I'M BETTING WE'RE NOT WILLING
TO BE TESTED. IS THEY DON'T
UNFORTUNATELY WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE OUTCOME MIGHT BE SO IT
FURTHER SKEWS THAT REPORT I
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF THIS
NUMBER WOULD HAVE TO WOULD BE
EVEN HIGHER. IF EVERYONE WAS
EXPECTED TO TEST. SO EIGHT I AM
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE ARM DOCTORS- BECAUSE I DO
NOT WANT THIS TO BE A
BURDENSOME ISSUE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A VERY
CRITICAL PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE AT
STAKE AS WELL STDS HAVE GONE UP.
GOING BACK TO THE PREVIOUS
POINT I MADE ABOUT THE MAGIC
JOHNSON ERA IT SEEMS THAT AFTER
TWENTY YEARS AFTER THE MAGIC
JOHNSON PHENOMENA. MOST FOLKS
STARTED TO WITH AND WITH THE
ADVANCEMENT OF TECHNOLOGY I
THINK THIS RECENT GENERATION
HAS- FORGOTTEN WHAT THE
PREVIOUS GENERATION WENT
THROUGH AND HOW CAREFUL WE HAD
BECOME AND HOW MUCH MORE
WILLING WE WERE TO TEST AND
MAKE SURE WE KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH OUR BODIES- AND
IT'S BEING DONE AT THE
DETRIMENT OF THIS NEW
GENERATION. AND SO WE NEED TO.
PUT BACK CERTAIN- TESTING INTO
PLACE IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PEOPLE ARE THIS
GENERATION. ISN'T LOST IN IN
THIS FIGHT AND IF MISTER RAND
WANTS TO CONTRIBUTE ANYTHING TO
THIS I. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE TWO ADDITIONAL POINTS AS
FROM POLYMER MISTER NAZARIAN
SAID A NUMBER ONE THERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE'VE ALREADY
BEGUN TALKING WITH CAL A STEP
ABOUT AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
WE THINK WE CAN SAVE EVEN MORE
TIME OFF THAT- IT WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO POINT OUT WE WERE
QUANTIFYING THE AMOUNT OF TIME.
THE NUMBERS THAT WE WOULD
CHALLENGE OF THE NUMBERS THAT
THEY'RE USING BECAUSE THEY TALK
ABOUT 42% OF EMERGENCY ROOM
PATIENTS ARE GETTING A BLOOD
DRAW TO BEGIN WITH- BUT THEN
THEY USE THEIR CALCULATION AT
THE FULL 100% OF PATIENTS TO
COME UP WITH THEIR TWENTY EIGHT
OR TWENTY NINE MILLION MINUTES
AN ADDITIONAL TIME. SO WE THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE SUBSTANTIALLY
LESS WE TAKE OUT MOST OF THE
THINGS THAT TAKE THE TIME- BUT
IF THERE ARE MORE THINGS THAT
WE CAN TAKE OUT THE TAKE OUT
SOME ADDITIONAL TIME WE WILL DO
THAT AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND THEN MISTER CHIEF YOU
DON'T MIND I'D. LIKE TO ADD ONE
MORE THING. AGAIN GIVEN THAT
THE- TIMES THAT WE'VE WORKED ON
THIS BILL. MAKING INTO A PILOT
PROJECT AND THEN NOW MOVING
FORWARD. IN ALL THOSE TIMES WE
ALSO TRY TO CURTAIL THE BURDEN
OF HAVING TO HAVE THE KEY OUR
DOCTORS BE THE ONES EVEN EITHER
COMMUNICATING THE INFORMATION-
WE UNDERSTAND THEIR ER ROOM
DOCTORS THEY SHOULD AND THEN
SPACE. IT'S A VERY CRITICAL
ISSUE WHEN YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN
TO SOMEONE WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
INFECTED WITH WHEN THEY HAD NO
IDEA THEY WERE COMING INTO THE
HOSPITAL ROOM FOR SOME OTHER
REASONS WE'VE GONE OUT OF OUR
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT EVEN SOME
OF THESE NUANCES THEY ARE NOT
BURDENED WITH- TO IT AGAIN I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE- TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION EVEN THE
SLIGHTEST NUANCES. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT FOR US TO
AT THIS POINT FORWARD MOVE MOVE
FORWARD ON. PLEASE GO AHEAD
WANT TO STAND ON THIS BECAUSE
YOU THIS THE CONTINUAL WORK IN
PROGRESS AND BECAUSE THIS IS
THE FIRST A HEARING ON THIS ALL
ALL SUPPORTED TODAY KNOWING
THAT IS A WORK IN PROGRESS.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN THE BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND I- I
UP. UPLOAD YOUR PERSISTENCE AND
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE THAT GOES BACK TO THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR- CAREER HERE
IN THE IN THE- IN THIS
BUILDING- HI. I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION AND- A MOTION BY MISS
BURKE. SECOND BY MISS AGUILAR
CURRY. THE MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS. WHICH I
TO CLOSE. I'VE DONE A LOT OF
TALKING RESPECT AS FOR ADULTS.
THANK YOU MISTER IS AREA MOST
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HI WHAT I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NONVOTING
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE. BURKE I
CARILLO. LARA MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY THIS AREA HI NAZARIAN
HIGH TO. RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
EIGHT ZERO I WAS ABLE TO LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISSED
IN THIS AREA. MR LEVINE. YOU
HAVE. THIRTEEN AB. SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
EIGHTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CREATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
GUIDELINES AND A DESCRIPTION OF
THE BEST PRACTICES FOR USE BY
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES.
AND CONGRESS LIVING FACILITIES
THAT ARE PROVIDING POST ACUTE
CARE DURING A PANDEMIC A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS OR OTHER
EMERGENCY THESE GUIDELINES
WOULD ADDRESS AT MINIMUM. THE
PROVISIONS OF CARE WHEN THERE
IS A SURGE IN THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS REQUIRING CARE
RESULTING FROM THE EMERGENCY
ONE OF POPULATIONS MOST AT RISK
OF ILLNESS AND DEATH FROM THE
COVE IN NINETEEN. PANDEMIC ARE
THOSE LIVING IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. AT THE INTERMEDIATE
CARE SOLVING CONGREGATE LIVING
FACILITIES- THIS BILL WILL
APPLY TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
OFTEN HAVE UNDERLYING HEALTH
ISSUES IN OUR HOUSE IN A WAY
THAT INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT KOBE NINETEEN COULD BE
TRANSMITTED. AS WE'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC THESE
FACILITIES HAVE STRUGGLED TO
HALT THE SPREAD OF CODE
NINETEEN NO ONE WAS PREPARED
FOR THIS A DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS
IT WOULD HAVE TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE UNITED STATES HOWEVER ONE
THING WE CAN BE PREPARED FOR
THE FUTURE. EIGHTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE THE SAFETY GUIDELINES
IN DESCRIPTION OF BEST
PRACTICES TO BE CREATED WHILE
LEAVING IT UP TO THE PART IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES TO DETERMINE.
WHAT THESE GUIDELINES WILL
SPECIFICALLY LOOK LIKE THIS
BILL WOULD ENSURE A STREAMLINED
AND EFFECTIVE WAY TO PROVIDE
THESE FACILITIES PRACTICES. TO
REDUCE TRANSMISSION OF DISEASES
IN FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES
OR PANDEMICS THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PROVED HOW ESSENTIAL
IT IS TO HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE.
BEFORE WE ARE IN A CRISIS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
PATRICIA MCGINNIS- OF
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM AND REBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND YOU WONDER OKAY. OKAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
ON CAPTAIN JANET ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM FOR A NON
PROFIT LONG TERM CARE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT FOR THIRTY
SIX YEARS HAS BEEN ADVOCATING
TO IMPROVE THE CARE CHOICES AND
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IN LONG TERM CARE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE STILL A BASIC.
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE LEARNED OVER
THE PAST YEAR WHEN 40% OF CO
THE DEATH NATIONALLY WE'RE
RESIDENTS AND STAFF IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES. AT LEAST
NINE THOUSAND OF THOSE DEATHS
WERE IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES THE PROVISIONS OF AB
SIX HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT. MANY OF THESE DEATHS
WERE PREVENTABLE HAD FACILITIES
IMPROPERLY PREPARED WITH
INFECTION CONTROL AND
PREVENTION PROTOCOL. ACCORDING
TO CMS INFECTION IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF MORBIDITY OR MORTALITY
IN OUR NATION'S LONG TERM CARE
HEALTH FACILITIES. YET NOT NOT
TELL FACILITIES ARE STRUGGLING
WITH INFECTION CONTROL WELL
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT RELEASED IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUND THAT MORE THAN 80%
OF NURSING HOMES NET NATIONALLY
WERE CITED FOR INFECTION
PREVENTION DEFICIENCY. FROM TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. ABOUT HALF
OF THOSE HAD PERSISTENT
PROBLEMS AND WE'RE CITED ACROSS
MULTIPLE YEARS. NOT ALWAYS
COULDN'T DEAL WITH SEPSIS
OUTBREAKS SO THEY CERTAINLY
WEREN'T PREPARED FOR A PANDEMIC
OF THIS MAGNITUDE. THE LACK OF
STAFF. THE LACK OF TESTING
PARTICULARLY IN THE EARLY
MONTHS THE LACK OF BASIC. NEEDS
SUCH AS MAPLIN GARRN AND THEN
MOST OF ALL THE INADEQUATE
TRAINING ON SEXUAL CONTROLLED
PREVENTION PROCEDURES ALL ADDED
TO THE TRAGEDIES THAT RESULTED
IN CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. TRAGEDY THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE REPEATED
AGAIN. EIGHTY SIX AT THE VERY
NEEDED PROVISIONS FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE TO PREVENT THIS
KIND OF TRAGEDY FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FUTURE. AND I URGE A YES
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING ON TO OUR WITH PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ AND I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY NINE
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE
DECREASED FROM ACCREDITED
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING
EIGHTY SIX WHICH WOULD TACKLE A
PARTICULARLY PERVASIVE PROBLEMS
STEMMING FROM THE COVET
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHICH IS THE
FOUNDER ABILITY OF RESONANCES
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
AND CONGREGATE LIVING HEALTH
FACILITIES. THE COMPANY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS PROVIDED
THE GAPS AND INSUFFICIENCIES
THAT'S CONTEMPORARY HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IT IS CLEAR THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED FOR UPDATED
GUIDELINES WITH RESPECT TO
PANDEMIC PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES
OR OTHER EMERGENCIES AND THESE
FACILITIES. DURING THE COMING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE THOUGHT
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR KOBE CASES AND A HUNDRED
AND 310-003-0070 SEVEN NURSING
HOME RESIDENT DEATHS NATIONWIDE
AND IN CALIFORNIA WE HAD
580-004-0090 NINE CASES. AND
NINE THOUSAND AND FIFTY NINE
DOUBTS IN THESE FACILITIES- THE
RESIDENTS OF THESE FACILITIES
NEED SPECIAL ATTENTION FROM THE
STATE IN ORDER TO PREVENT DEATH
AND FUTURE PANDEMICS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THIS STOP BY
REQUIRING THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO COLLABORATE ON HEALTH AND
SAFETY GUIDELINES AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR THESE FACILITIES
AND AT A MINIMUM ADDRESS THE
PROVISION OF CARE WHEN THERE IS
A SURGE IN THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS REQUIRING TREATMENT.
WILL HELP TO DECREASE THESE
TRAGIC DEATHS IN THE FUTURE WE
BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT TO
INCORPORATE THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC INTO HAND ENHANCE THE
RESPONSE CAPACITY OF OUR
SYSTEMS OF CARE WHICH ANY S. W.
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I. BOATS ON EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS A IN A
DON'T BELIEVE THERE IS ANY-
THERE IS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO FAR
AS I CAN FOR AS I'M AWARE SO WE
WILL MOVE. NOW TO. PUBLIC
COMMENT- THESE OPEN THE LINES
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. WHEN
SUPPORT YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
ONLY PLEASE MISREPRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. AND IF
ANYONE WANTS TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE THEN FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRING THE BILL FOR-
REALLY APPRECIATE CONSIDERING
WHAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH WITH
PANDEMIC IN OUR HOMES AND SO-
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO
ONE THE BILL DOESN'T CHOI A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION- IT'S IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION NOW. MOTION
BY MISTAKE HERE CURRY. IN THE
SECOND WAS. I'M SORRY. A
SEGMENT OF. THE SECOND BY MR
BURKE. SO THIS OF MOTION IS DUE
PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS-
MADAMS WHICH I CLOSE MR LEVINE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU- PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL VOTE IS PLEASE CALL.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. WHAT I
WHAT I MAYES. PHASE II
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW HI BONTA.
BONTA HI BURKE. BURKE HI
CARILLO FLORA MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY THIS AREA. TO RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
SEVEN MINUTES OR MORE THESE ONE
MORE WITH THE BILL- ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR LEVINE
THANK YOU AGAIN MR CHEN ALSO
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU SIR. MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU HAVE AB TWO
SEVENTY NINE. ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS A PRELIMINARY
MATTER- I LIKE TO ACCEPT ALL
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS WELL
AS GIVEN NOTICE OF MY INTENT-
WE HAVE COMMUNICATED THIS YEAR
STATUS SHERMAN OF OUR INTENT TO
AMEND FURTHER AMEND THE BILL TO
EXCLUDE THE LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES OPERATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND I ARE HERE
TO ASK. FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BI TWO SEVEN NINE. TO PROTECT
SENIORS LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
AND INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES R. I. C. S. DURING
THIS COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROHIBIT
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
I SEE APPS FROM EVICTING.
TRANSFERRING WE'RE CHANGING THE
CONDITIONS OF OPERATIONS FOR
RESIDENTS WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT
FOR MEDICAL NECESSITY DURING
THE V. OFFICIALLY DECLARED
COBIT NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY PERIOD. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE SIX MONTHS
ADVANCE NOTICE OF ANY PROPOSED
TERMINATION OF OPERATION TO
EVERY RESIDENT FOR UP TO A YEAR
AFTER THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
PERIOD. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE NOTICE OF ANY TRANSFER
OF ANY INDIVIDUAL TO THE
NURSING HOME OR FACILITY. WHO
HAS TESTED POSITIVE FOR CARBON
NINETEEN. AS WE ALL KNOW
SENIORS LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
ARE AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
TO COVER NINETEEN. IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE PANDEMIC SENIORS
LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
ACCOUNTED FOR UP TO HALF. OF
ALL DEATHS DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN. WE NEED TO PROTECT
THESE VULNERABLE SENIORS FROM
BEING EVICTED. FROM SUFFERING
TRANSFER TRAUMA ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. PLEASE
GIVE THE SENIORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES THE PEACE OF MIND
KNOWING THAT THEIR HOMES AT
THIS STAGE IN THEIR LIVES WILL
NOT BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM.
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY JOIN
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR SANTIAGO. I
THINK YOU'RE A THANK YOU MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE AND-
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO CALL PERCENT-
DURING THIS TIME THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE AND INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BILL PARTICULARLY THE
ENTIRE DISTRICT AND TO THE REST
OF CALIFORNIA WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN OUR DISTRICT AND WHY THIS IS
AN EMERGENCY CALL THE NEEDS.
HOW TO REACH THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK VERY QUICKLY AND FIND IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE CLOSE TO
SEVENTY SENIORS WERE BEING
KICKED OUT OF THEIR ADDED THEIR
RESIDENTS NOW SIMPLY- BECAUSE
THE THIS FACILITY WANTS TO DO
THIS FOR OTHER MOTIVES AND
REASONS. THERE'S NO REASON WHY
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO WAIT
TILL AT LEAST THIS CALL THE
CRISIS IS OVER KEEP IN MIND
THAT THE SENIORS OF JAPANESE
AMERICAN SENIORS WHO HAVE BEEN
IN THESE COMMUNITIES- THE THING.
IT'S THE- OR YOU. SINCE EITHER
THEY WERE BORN OR OR- THEY GREW
UP OR THE MATURED THEIR BOOK
AND IT'S CULTURALLY SENSITIVE-
IF YOU COULD SEND IT TO THE
SERVICE CULTURALLY SENSITIVE IN
A FACILITY THAT'S PROVIDING
CARE FOR THEM. WHAT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE NEED TO GET THIS
DONE BECAUSE THIS IS HAPPENING
ACROSS. THE STATE WE'RE SEEING
THE POTENTIAL FOR FACILITIES TO
REMOVE SENIOR SIMPLY BECAUSE
THERE'S ANOTHER MOTIVE AND THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE US THE
ABILITY. TO AT LEAST PREVENT
ANY MOVEMENT OF ANY SENIORS. A.
N. N. N. INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES OR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC SO IT'S REALLY NOT AN
AGGRESSIVE BUILT A MODEST BILL
THAT ALLOWS SENIORS TO STAY
WHERE THEY'RE AT. AFTER THAT. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO CO PRESENT. I
AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM NOT
TORRANCE. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THE
COMMISSION CHAIR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU BOTH- WITH THAT WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES I BELIEVE
WE HAVE TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- SO MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE. OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. INTERNET SERVICES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
MIKE DARK A STAFF ATTORNEY AT
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM A NONPROFIT
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE ADVOCATES FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND LONG TERM CARE.
WHEN PEOPLE MOVE INTO NURSING
HOMES THEY LEAVE BEHIND
FAMILIES. FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
THEIR PLACES OF WORSHIP THEIR
PROFESSIONAL IDENTITY. GIVEN UP
MOST OF WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO GET
THEIR LIVES DIGNITY AND MEANING.
OFTEN THE ONLY THING THEY HAVE
LEFT IS THE FACILITY THEY LIVE
IN THE PEOPLE THEY MEET THERE
THE OTHER RESIDENTS THE STAFF.
BEING FORCED TO LEAVE A NURSING
HOME FOR ANOTHER FACILITY WAS
UNIVERSALLY UNDERSTOOD TO BE
TRAUMATIC BEFORE COPE WITH IT.
WHICH IS WHY BEFORE KOBE.
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE THE RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE
IN IDENTIFYING ANOTHER FACILITY
TO GO TO. A HUGE PROBLEM WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW WITH CODE IT IS
THAT RESTRICTIONS ON VISITATION
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE BUT THAT THE
NEW FACILITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE CLEAN. AND SAFE
AND ADEQUATELY STAFFED BUT THIS
BILL ASKED IS TO TEMPORARILY
EXTENT OF HONORABLE NURSING
HOME IN A FEW UP RESIDENTS THE
SAME KINDS OF PROTECTIONS
AGAINST DEPICTION OF RESIDENTS
OUTSIDE CONGREGATE SETTINGS ARE
ALREADY GETTING. INTO MANY
STATE AND MUNICIPAL RULES. THE
BILL CURRENTLY EXPLICITLY
PERMITS TRANSFERS TO GENERAL
ACUTE HOSPITALS FOR MEDICAL
REASONS WHICH IS APPROPRIATE.
BUT IN ITS CURRENT FORM IT
WOULD ALSO PERMIT ATTENDING
PHYSICIANS CONTRACTING WITH
DISABILITIES TO TRANSFER
RESIDENTS ON THE NON EMERGENCY
BASIS TO OTHER SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY. AND ITS A RULE WHICH
WOULD BE INCONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT TRANSFER LAWS- AND
COULD BE EASILY EXPLOITED
CANTOR WOULD RESPECTFULLY URGE
THAT THIS ISSUE BE DEALT WITH
BY A SIMPLE AMENDMENT- ONE
THING THAT DOES STAND OUT ABOUT
THE- OPPOSITION LETTERS FILED
BY INDUSTRY INTEREST. IS THAT
NO ONE IS EVEN DISPUTING THAT
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE RIGHT NOW
TWENTY VICTIMS RESIDENT WHETHER
FAMILY TO VISIT POTENTIAL ME
PERSONALLY TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE APPROPRIATE. AND NOT THE
ARGUMENTS THEY DO OFFER IN
OPPOSITION ARE COMPELLING THE
BILL WOULD NOT KEEP FACILITIES
AREIN GENUINE FINANCIAL
STRAITS FROM DISTRACTING
RESIDENTS. BUT IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THEY FILE A PETITION. FOR
CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY FIRST.
OPPOSITION TO THE LAW ME
BECAUSE THE BECAUSE TO. SIMPLY
MISSES THE POINT BUT CHIEF
EXISTING PROTECTIONS LIKE BEING
ABLE TO VISIT THE TRANSFEREE
FACILITY FIRST HAVE ALREADY
BEEN SUSPENDED AS A RESULT. OF
CALLED THE DISSERTATION
RESTRICTIONS. FINALLY IS
ORWELLIAN TO SUGGEST THAT A
BILL TEMPORARILY HALTING
EVICTIONS OF THE OLD AND THE
SIX DURING A PANDEMIC WOULD
INTERFERE WITH PATIENT CARE.
IT'S NOT A CONCERN FOR PATIENTS
BUT DESIRE FOR PROFIT THAT IS
DRIVING THE CLOSURE OF
FACILITIES. LIKE SAKURA ICE YET
LOS ANGELES. WE SHOULD BE ABLE
AS A SOCIETY DEALING WITH THE
DEVASTATING PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. TO DELAYED THAT KIND OF
PROFIT TAKING FOR ONLY A SHORT.
TIME I HEARD YOUR YES VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
TO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOULD
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS CARRIE
FORTY YEAR I'M A RESIDENT OF
PASADENA CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY AS THE
DAUGHTER OF THE CURRENT STOCK
WITHOUT LIFE YES PRESIDENT. THE
BILL WILL HELP MY FAMILY AND
ALL THE RESIDENTS AFFECTED
IDEA. AS WELL AS NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
MY FATHER IS JAPANESE AMERICAN
BORN IN TORRANCE CALIFORNIA
NINETY FOUR YEARS AGO TO
IMMIGRANT PARENTS FROM JAPAN
YEAH LIVED IN THE TORRANCE
GARDENA AREA HIS ENTIRE LIFE
AND GREW UP IN THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. FOR
GENERATIONS THE JAPANESE
COMMUNITY SUPPORTED THESE
RETIREMENT AND ASSISTED CARE
FACILITIES. LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE DAY WHEN THEIR RELATIVES
NEEDED CULTURALLY SENSITIVE
CARE IN THEIR SENIOR YEAR. THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN RESIDENTS OF
THE FACILITY I SHARED HISTORY
DURING WORLD WAR TWO MANY WERE
RELOCATED FROM THE HOME AND
SENT TO INTERNMENT CAMPS. MY
FATHER HIS MOTHER AND MY AUNT
OR FORCED TO MOVE INTO THE
CAMP. MY GRANDFATHER WAS
ACTUALLY ARRESTED BY THE FBI MY
FATHER WAS POWERLESS TO STOP
THE PROCESS. THE FBI CAME
KNOCKING ON THEIR DOOR ON
FRIDAY THE THIRTEENTH AND TOOK
HIM AWAY. THE FAMILY WITHIN
FORCED TO LEAVE THEIR HOME ON
LATER NOT NOT STILL REMEMBERS
EATING CHOCOLATE EASTER BUNNY
AT THAT TIME. IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS TERRIBLE MOMENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY IT HAPPENING
AGAIN. AT THAT TIME THEY WERE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR HOME
BECAUSE OF FEAR THIS TIME
THEY'RE BEING TAKEN AWAY
BECAUSE OF GREED. THEY'RE
LOSING THEIR HOMES AGAIN THE
CLOSURE HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
PATIENT CARE THE CURRENT OWNERS
THE PHYSICAL WANT TO REDEVELOP
THE LAND TO BUILD CONDOS. IT
ADDS TO THE GENTRIFICATION. OF
THE BOYLE HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE RESIDENTS ARE WE- THE
FEELING- SHE GOT UP AT NIGHT
THE JAPANESE REYES MEANING IT
CAN'T BE HELPED OR NOTHING CAN
BE DONE ABOUT IT. I HAVE NOT
YET FOUND THE COURAGE TO TELL
MY DAD THAT THE FACILITY WILL
BE CLOSING. IT WOULD REAWAKEN
THOSE FEELINGS OF HELPLESSNESS.
IT FELT PREVENT MY FATHER AND
ALL OTHER RESIDENTS FROM BEING
CAPTAIN TO THE UNCERTAINTY. OF
LOCATING VETTING ARRANGEMENTS.
WHICH WOULD BE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE THERE ARE
LESS THAN A DOZEN INTERMEDIATE
CARE FACILITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS IS THE
ONLY ONE THAT CATERS TO THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
DURING THE PANDEMIC IT IS
ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT TO EVEN
LOOK AT OTHER FACILITIES. IF
THERE'S A TO QUOTE THE FACILITY
FAMILIES WILL HAVE GREAT
DIFFICULTY FINDING A COMPARABLE
FACILITY WITH IDENTICAL AND
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE CARE. MY
FATHER NEEDS TO IMMEDIATE
MEDICAL CARE CARE AUTHORED BY
ORDINARY YOUR HOME WOULD NOT BE
SUFFICIENT. THAT COULD ICF
PROVIDES THE PROPER LEVEL OF
KERR. PLEASE PASS THE BILL.
PLEASE PREVENT CORPORATE GREED
TO GO UNCHECKED DURING A
PANDEMIC. PLEASE DON'T LET MY
FATHER OR ANY OF THE RESIDENTS
AFTER WE LEFT THE TRANSGRESSION
OF THE PAST. MY HAVING TO LOSE.
THEIR VETTING CIRCUMSTANCE.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT- SO IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
HIM FOR OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
PLEASE JUST GIVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. MISTER ROBERTS-
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
WHEN. WHEN YOU'RE READY WITH
CALLERS. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM ONE NUMBER FOUR TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONALIST THOSE. WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT COMMENT FROM NINE THREE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE NINETY SEVEN. I CAN HEAR
ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS ROSCO CRAYON YOUNG MORE
MORE- BLISS WHO BOARD MEMBER IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THAT LINE
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS TAI
CHI YEAH DOLLAR PROGRESSIVE
ASIAN NETWORK FOR ACTION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
TWO SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
GRAYSON LINE FOR EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF ANY RIGHT
NOT THAT THE ONLY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. COMING
FROM MY NUMBER THREE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR KENNETH
TIGHE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. COMMENT FROM MY
NUMBER FOUR THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SCHERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS IGOR
CHECKUPS SHARE THE BARCLAY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON SIDE-
BOND ON WHICH TYPE COMMITTEE
SPEAKING IN MY INDIVIDUAL
CAPACITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK GOD
FOR MY NUMBER FOUR TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR READING MEMBERS DISHES
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
FORMER ASSEMBLY AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE COMMITTEE CHAIR
MARICO IMADA IN STRNG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND THE
NEXT COME IT COMES FROM LINE
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS IS
DAVID MALDONADO NUMBER OF STATE
OUR SENIORS NETWORK HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THERE IS NO OTHER
MEMBERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE THE BILL DOESN'T CHOI
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. DO I
HEAR A MOTION. EXCUSE ME MISTER
CHAIR YOU'VE DONE A LOT FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY OF
POLITICS JENNIFER SNYDER IN THE
HOUSE THE COMPANY SUFFICIENT
HEALTH FACILITIES- I'M WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY ON WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED SO- I
APOLOGIZE YOU BUT PLEASE YOU
KNOW I'M- PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
THE FUTURE THANK YOUNG PROJECT
TOGETHER YOU KNOW THE FUTURE
PLEASE- GET TURNED UP TO US AND
SO WE CAN HAVE YOU. ON OUR LIST
SO THANK YOU. YES WE DID WE
DID- SO- SORRY MISTER CHAIR
GOOD EVENING AND- SHE CHECKED
ME MEMBERS THAT JENNIFER
SNYDER. APPLICA ON BEHALF THE
COMPANY SUFFICIENT HELP
FACILITIES- WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER SIX. SIX NINE HUNDRED
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
FOUR HUNDRED INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITY. FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED IN THE
STATE- I WANT TO FIRST PLACE TO
START BY SAYING THIS EVENING
WE'RE EXTREMELY SYMPATHETIC-
WITH THE LOCAL SITUATION.
OUTLINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI AND SANTIAGO AND
HAVE APPRECIATED BOTH OF THEM
MEETING WITH US AND ARE VERY
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN BE HELPFUL
TO THEM- INVOLVING THIS. VERY
IMPORTANT DISTRICT ISSUE-
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST OPPOSE AB
TWO SEVEN NINE TODAY ON IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. BECAUSE THE BILL
WOULD NOT JUST APPLY TO THE ONE
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY
THAT'S IN LOS ANGELES BUT WOULD
ALSO IMPACT ALL RIGHT YES. IN
ALL ELEVEN HUNDRED SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES STATE WIDE.
THE BILL WOULD LIMIT ANY
CHANGES TO PATIENT SERVICES
FACILITY OWNERSHIP OR OTHER
STATE APPROVED FACILITY
MODIFICATION. THAT MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT ACTUALLY BENEFIT
PATIENT CARE. AND WE AGREE THAT
THEY COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS BEEN DEVASTATING FOR A LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES THE
PATIENTS IN THE CARE GIVERS
AND- WE AGREE THAT THESE TIMES
ARE UNPRECEDENTED- WE ALSO
AGREED SUPPORT TO KEEP PATIENTS
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN THEIR
CURRENT FACILITY LOCATION. BUT
THE TYPES OF RESTRICTIONS AS
OUTLINED IN AB TWO SEVEN NINE
HI THE HANDS AT THEIR SIDES OF
DROPS DATE THAT ARE MAKING
DECISIONS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE PATIENT SAFETY AND WELL
BUILT. WELL BEING. I WE'VE
EXPRESSED COULD BE ON ARE AND
HAVE PROVIDED AND THEN NOT-
THAT WAY. REALLY TRY TO PUT
FOR- CREATING SPECIFIC CODE. WE
LOVE PLAN RECALL. AND APPROVAL
OF THE BILL REAL OKAY. TWENTY
I'M AND I. EIGHTY TWO SAID NINE
IN A CORPORATE COULD HAVE A
CLOSER TO PHONE FOR YOUR SHOULD
BE IN STATE THREE THE GROUND
AGAIN MY DECLARE BANKRUPTCY.
AND IT I RESTRICTION A LONG
WITH A SIX MONTH NOTICE TO OF
OWNER ONE YEAR AFTER THE
COMPANY PANDEMIC WITH. NOT ONLY
PATIENT FURTHER AT RISK BUT
PUSH THE STATE INTO ACROSS
BANKRUPTCY CROW WITH DEBTORS
BEING PAID AND PATIENTS NOT
BEING PROPERLY CARED FOR. SO
AGAIN WE'RE- VERY MUCH
AGREEMENT WITH THE- THAT
SITUATION OF MY FINANCIAL COULD
HAVE BEEN HANDLED BETTER. AND
SHOULD HAVE REQUIRED MORE
INVOLVEMENT AND OVERSIGHT BY
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF UBLIC
HEALTH. WE DO HOPE WE CAN
ASSIST IN FINDING A SOLUTION TO
THAT SITUATION RATHER THAN.
CREATED STATE WIDE RESTRICTION
AND PACKING OVER. ELEVEN
HUNDRED LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND THEY'RE NINETY
THOUSAND PATIENTS- THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TO OPPOSE AB TWO
SEVEN NINE- I'M AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR CUTTING IN AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY WELL
EXCUSE ME I MISTER CARR I
APOLOGIZE LEVINE THERE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN SOME MIX UP BY I'M
HOPING TO ALSO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT- GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER SMITH I'M WITH
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT- MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING ASSISTED LIVING
AND CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES ALSO KNOWN AS LIFE
PLAN COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY I
REMEMBER THERE ARE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND YEARS IN THE
STATE. FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE OPPOSITE GOAL
TO ENSURE THAT SENIORS ARE NOT
PLEASE WE FULLY UNDERSTAND AND
ARE SYMPATHETIC WITH THE-
CONCERN BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BALLOT A COMPLICATION FOR THE
SENIOR. I'M CARE CONTINUUM. I
MENTIONED ARE MY AND CAN CARE.
COMMUNITY WHICH ARE MULTI LEVEL.
COMMUNITY WHAT HAVE INDEPENDENT
ASSISTED AND SKILL LEVELS ALL
IN ONE- I THANK LAST FEW
COMMUNITIES TO. ENTER TO ONE
CAMPUS OR FACILITY AND
SEAMLESSLY MOVED THROUGH CARE
AT THE AGE OF THEIR CARES
CHANGED. AS OUTLINES ARE IN
SUPPORT AND IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WE RECOGNIZE TRANSFER
TRAUMA AND THE WELL DOCUMENTED
AND TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE IT
SHOULD BE AVOIDED. THE C. C. R.
M. C. MODEL- THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED ACCOMPLISHES- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL HAVE
POTENTIAL TO IMPACT OTHER CARE
OFFERED IN THE BCC. ARE THREE.
SO IT'S A MULTI LEVEL PROVIDER
TO THE- TO CLOSE THEIR NURSING
FOR LEGION. FINANCIAL REASON.
BUT MUST WAIT SIX MONTHS TO DO
SO ENTER THE BAKER. YEAH I
ADULT LIVING IN THE PARTS OF
THE CAN MY ALSO BE DISPLAYED.
WHAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
IN. AT EFFECTOR CARMEN BE DONE
TO BE RESIDENTS WITH IN. I THE
POTS OF MONEY. STILL NURSING
FACILITIES BEEN ENTERED HELLO
OF FINANCIAL BECAUSE AND COULD
PP. PRIVATE TESTING AND CENSUS
WE ARE. ABOUT LEAST ONE
MULTILEVEL. RETURN COMMUNITY-
AT SHOWS CLOSE THEIR- GOVERNOR
FACILITY AND APPROPRIATE-
TRANSFER- OUTSIDE THOSE KILLED
RESIDENTS AGAIN A PROGRAM
PLACES- AND WE KNOW MANY OTHERS
ARE CONSIDERING- DURING THE
SAME. AGAIN KEEP THEIR IT
INDEPENDENT. AND ASSISTED
LIVING- STILL UP AND RUNNING
AND NOT JUST THOSE FOLKS IT
GROUPS WHO WERE AT- THEY LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT OTHER AT-
OUT OF THEIR HOMES AS WELL
AGAIN. LIKE TO. ECHO GEN
PROVIDERS WITH ABOUT TOWARD THE
LOCAL IS- AND WHAT IT WHAT IT
HAPPENED IN A ANGELES AREA WE
ARE HOPE THAT- WE CAN. CONSIDER
OTHER. THAT MY BE AND HOW NOT
HAVE. TO DESPITE OTHER SENIOR
NOT POP UP IN. OKAY THANK YOU-
NOW WILL BRING ABOUT TO THE
COMMITTEE- DO WE HAVE A OR SO
ON THIS PROMOTION. MOST BY
MISS- A SECOND BY- MISTER
SANTIAGO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GENTLEMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT- WHILE THE- ORIGINAL
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL IS-
WAS WHAT- IS HAPPENING AT ONE
PARTICULAR INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITY- AND A LOS ANGELES AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO TH
DISTRICT IN BOYLE HEIGHTS. THE
SAKURA GARDENS I SEE YEAH YOU
KNOW WHICH IS IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSFERRING THEIR RESIDENTS
TO- ONE OF THEIR- NURSING HOMES
THE K. I. K. I. LOS ANGELES
ALSO IN MR SANTIAGO TH
DISTRICT- IN LINCOLN HEIGHTS.
WHICH HAS SUFFERED THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF COVERT DOUBTS AMONG
ANY NURSING HOMES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE AND SO THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT IT THROUGH THEIR THEIR
YOU KNOW IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR RESIDENTS TO BE
TRANSFERRED- OR ADDICTED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC IT'S THE HUMANE
THING TO DO IS THE RIGHT. THING
TO DO AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT HI
WHAT I MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE HI CARILLO. FLORA FLORIDA
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I. TO
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIZE AYE
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. WALDRON
UPLOADING. SEVEN ZERO. THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROUTE WILL LEAVE
AN ON CALL THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
A TIME WE DO HAVE TIME FRAMES
FOR WITNESSES TO REGISTER TO
VOTE TESTIFY- SO I WAS
SURPRISED- AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE A RECORD FOR THE LAST
TWO OPPOSITION WITNESSES. WE
TOLD OTHER OFFICERS WE TOLD
OTHER WITNESSES IT WAS PASSED
THE TIME AND THE P. FOR THEM TO
WAIT REGISTER AS WITNESSES.
JUST A NOTE. FOR THE NEXT TO
HEARINGS IF YOU ARE IF YOU
MISSED THE DEADLINE. FOR
REGISTERING AS A WITNESS
WHETHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. YOU'LL BE ALLOWED
TO SUPPORT OR TO MAKE YOUR CASE
ONLY. AS ME TOO. AND PUBLIC
COMMENT SAID STATING YOUR
POSITION ON THE ON THE BILL. SO
IN FAIRNESS TO THE PEOPLE WHO
DID. WE DID HAVE EVERYTHING ALL
LINED UP- HI I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HONOR THAT.
AND SO- IN NEXT TO HEARINGS WE
WILL- WE WILL BE VERY STRICT
ABOUT IT SO I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT- YOU WANT TO BE A
WITNESS. GET IT IN TIME. AND
DOUBLE CHECK WITH US AND MAKE
SURE IT'S BEEN RECEIVED AND
THAT YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE COUNTY
SO THANK YOU. MISTER O'DONNELL.
YOU HAVE I'D NEVER SIXTEEN. P.
FIVE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX WHICH WILL EXPAND
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS.
EVEN PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC THE
INCIDENCE OF YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WAS INCREASING AT
AN ALARMING RATE. AND THE
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY EXACERBATED
THESE CONDITIONS. SCHOOLS ARE
WELL POSITIONED TO MEET THE
HEALTH THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF STUDENTS. BUT THEY LACK THE
RESOURCES TO DO SO EFFECTIVELY.
FOR TOO LONG SCHOOLS OF LACK
THE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
NECESSARY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO MEET
STUDENT NEEDS. WE ARE LEAVING
FEDERAL MONEY ON THE TABLE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVES ONLY TWENTY
NINE DOLLARS PER MEDIC CAL
ELIGIBLE CHILD. IN
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR SCHOOL BASED
SERVICES WELL OTHER STATES
RECEIVE UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER CHILD. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
CHOOSE EXPERT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAMS. WHO REVISED
INTENSIVE SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE
TO SELECT LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES. THE TEAMS WILL ASSIST
THE L. A. AS WITH ACCESSING
FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
EXISTING PROGRAMS LIKE THE
ELLIE A BILLING OPTION PROGRAM.
THEY WILL ALSO ASSIST THE L.
A.'S WITH ESTABLISHING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY HEALTH
AGENCIES COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS AND HEALTH PLANS TO
MAXIMIZE THE SERVICES AND
REVENUES AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES. AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE TWO YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM THE PARTICIPATING
ELEAZAR WILL HAVE DEVELOPED A
SUSTAINABLE MODEL WITH RELIABLE
ON GOING FUNDING FROM MULTIPLE
SOURCES TO MEET STUDENTS. THE
CD WILL USE LESSONS LEARNED TO
DEVELOP RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
TO SCALE UP THESE EFFORTS
STATEWIDE. IN SHORT MISTER
CHAIR THE EFFORT HERE IS TO
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS
THE STATE AND LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO BILL MEDICAL FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
TODAY ARE. ALEX RISK OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S TRUST AND
RUBEN REYES SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE ROLE OF ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE WHEN THEY- ARE NOT OPEN I
MEAN OPEN THE LINES AND LET THE
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. ONE ZERO.
I THANK YOU- ALEX BRISCOE
PROPOSED THE CALIFORNIA CHOSE
TRUST. IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. I AM. THERE IS LEGITIMATE
CRISIS AND THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL AFFECT CHILDREN. IT
IS A CRISIS THAT PRECEDED THE
PANDEMIC BUT THE CAMPAIGN
DEMOCRATS BROUGHT INTO
EXTREMELY ACUTE. KNOWLEDGE IN
OUR CULTURE AND SOCIETY.
CONSIDER THE FACTS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IN THE DECADE BEFORE
COURT NINETEEN. WE SAW STRIKING
INCREASES IN UTILIZATION AND
ACUITY AMONG CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH. PATTERSON AND SYSTEMS.
WE SAW ONE HUNDRED AND 4%
INCREASE IN INPATIENT VISITS
FOR SUICIDE AND SUICIDAL
IDEATION. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AND WHILE LENGTH OF
STAY DECLINED ACROSS OUR
STATE'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
ACOSTA ALL THESE BURDENS THEY
ACTUALLY INCREASE FOR
PAEDIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH BY
FIFTY PERCENT. AND CHILDREN
THEMSELVES TOLD US IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY.
YOU'RE A 61% INCREASE IN SELF
REPORTED MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE. IT HAS
ONLY EXACERBATED THIS
CHALLENGE. IS BROUGHT IN TO
CLEAR FOCUS CHALLENGES OF OUR
EIGHT. CHILD SUPPORTING
SYSTEMS. HAVE ARE FORCED US TO
EXAMINE NEW OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE SUPPORT
FOR CHILDREN. SHUTTLE INCLUDING
RADY CHILDREN'S HOW. AND OPENED
SO STRIKING INCREASES ENERGY
DEPARTMENT UTILIZATION FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS WERE UP
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND 35% FOR
ADOLESCENTS AND CHILDREN SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN. IT IS NO NEWS- TO
ELECTED LEADERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST MEDICAID PROGRAM IS THE
LARGEST MEDICAID PROGRAM IN THE
NATION. AND UNFORTUNATELY
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN ONE
OF THE WORST. WE RANK FORTY
FOURTH IN THE NATION ACCESS TO
CARE FOR CHILDREN. AND CHILDREN
REPRESENTS 42% OF OUR ROLE IS
THAT ONLY 14% OF ALL
EXPENDITURES. CALIFORNIA IS
GROUND ZERO FOR INCOME
INEQUALITY WE WILL BE BY THE
FALL. WE WILL BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE SIX OUT OF TEN CHILDREN
WHO LIVE IN THE STATE SIX
MILLION CHILDREN WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAID. LIVING
UNDER 210050% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY. LESS THAN 5% OF
CHILDREN ENROLLED MEDICAID GET
ANY ACCESS AND SUPPORT ALL FROM
HOME. SCHOOLS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
ANY RESPONSE AT SCALE. THE
SYSTEM IS EXTRAORDINARILY
COMPLEX AND SCHOOLS CAN AND
MUST BE ESSENTIAL ACTORS. FIRST
MS NEED SCHOOLS CHILDREN EIGHT
EIGHTEEN HAVE THE LOWEST RATE
OF PRIMARY CARE UTILIZATION OF
ANY DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP AND
MEDICAID PROGRAM. SO WHEN THEY
NEED TO HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THE
MOST THEY CAN'T ACCESS IT. AND
ALSO THE FINANCE OF THE LINE.
THE CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS THE
FOURTH HIGHEST TAX BASE IN THE
NATION BUT WE READ THIRTY
FOURTH AND SPENDING PER
BENEFICIARY TO ALL OF US WHO
LIVE HERE ARE ASKING THE SAME
QUESTION. HOW DO WE PULL DOWN
MORE FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS FOR
THE DOLLARS ARE ALREADY
SPENDING. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
FIVE A SIX. SPEAKING AFTER ME A
SUPERINTENDENT RUBEN RACE OF
THE ROAD THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE WORKED SERVER CANNOT REST ON
SOME OF THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
THAT IS CONSECRATE BASIS AND
IT'S A PLEASURE AND AUSTIN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MR HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM WORKING RIGHT S.
AND I'M THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SACRAMENTO. WELL IT'S A SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SERVING TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS IN
PRESCHOOL THROUGH GRADE SIX.
ARE PART OF THE CITY IS
CHARACTERIZED BY A VERY HIGH
POVERTY RATE. OUR SENSE OF
SECURITY HELD A STEP BETWEEN
NINETY AND 95% OF OUR STUDENTS
LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY LINE.
BUT ALSO CALPERS THAT NEARLY A
QUARTER OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS. THE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
THAT SO MANY CHALLENGES
CHALLENGES IN THE LIVES OF OUR
STUDENTS. CHALLENGES ALL TO
CREATE A NUMBER OF OBSTACLES TO
LEARNING AND IMPACT GREATLY OUR
STUDENTS ABILITY TO WORK WITH
OTHERS AT SCHOOL AND TO ENGAGE
FULLY IN THE CLASSROOM. BUT I
BECAME SUPERINTENDENT IT WAS
CLEAR TO ME THAT WE MUST
DEVELOP RESOURCE INTO THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. IN ORDER TO ALLOW OUR
STUDENTS TO REACH THEIR
POTENTIAL. THESE DAYS OF ALL
THE INCREASE OVER THE PAST YEAR
DURING THE CUP OF NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE SEEN A GREAT
DEAL OF EVIDENCE THAT EVEN THE
YOUNG STUDENTS WE SERVE IN OUR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. ARE DEALING
WITH ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND
I'VE LOST MANY OF THEIR SOCIAL
SKILLS DURING THESE MONTHS OF
ISOLATION. OVER TIME WE HAVE
USED. LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FIVE. TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS. BUT MAKING STRETCH
OUR RESOURCES ONLY SO FAR. AT
THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
CONTINUE TO SEARCH OUT FUNDING
SOURCES INCLUDING
REIMBURSEMENTS TO SUPPORT OUR
WORK IN THIS AREA. THE MANAGED
CARE TO FAMILY TO BURY COMPLEX
AND NAVIGATING THE SYSTEM IN
ORDER TO ACCESS FUNDING.
AVAILABLE UNDER THE SYSTEM IS
DIFFICULT TO SAY THE LEAST.
REBEL HAS TRIED TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT TO
FIFTEEN. WHAT EXAMPLE WOULD BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THIS
HAS RESULTED IN ADDITIONAL
COMMISSION AT ONE OF OUR
SCHOOLS. BUT WE STILL FALL FAR
SHORT OF MEETING OUR STUDENTS
NEED. THIS BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE NEEDED
GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT
SOME SOME NEEDED BY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO ACCESS FUNDING
FOR THESE VITAL SERVICES. OUR
STUDENTS WELL BEING AND OUR
ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY DELIVER
INSTRUCTION DEPENDS ON OUR
ABILITY TO ACCESS RESOURCES.
ORTEGA'S MENTAL HEALTH WORK. IN
THE LONG TERM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
REGISTERED SO WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE.
FOR- PUBLIC COMMENT FOR THOSE
WITH AND THEN THE PHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT JUST YOUR NAME POSITION
ORGANIZATION ONLY. WHEN YOU'RE
READY- MISTRUST WRITER PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE'LL START WITH
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
ADRIN SHOPPING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
ONE NUMBER FOUR THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS
IS CHERYL DAVILA FORMER
COUNCILMEMBER IN THE CITY OF
BERKELEY. CHECK THE QUEUE IN.
BUT I WAS REALLY ON THE LINE
FOR THE LAST TIME WHICH I DOUBT
THAT THE POOR DIDN'T DIDN'T GET
A NUMBER TO GET IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO OUR
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE LINE FOR THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THE CALLER PLEASE. WE GO TO
LINE FOR THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANYTHING UNDER THE
CHILDREN NOW AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHAT SEVENTEEN HERE
THERE. THE GUIDELINES FOUR
THIRTY I'M SORRY FOR TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB ONE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION WILLING
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. AND WE HAVE LINE FOR
TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I APOLOGIZE. JUST ONE MOMENT.
OKAY IT WOULD HAVE LINE NUMBER.
I NEVER THREE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THERE'S NONE IN THE
QUEUE THERE'S NO MORE OKAY
QUESTIONERS IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORTH- IT'S
IRONIC THAT TODAY HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICT. EMPLOYEES UP IN LAKE
COUNTY AND CINNAMON NAPA COUNTY
AND OF THE IN THE INTEREST AND
CONCERN ABOUT OUR STUDENTS
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL RIGHT NOW-
SIMILAR HEALTH ISSUES HOW TO
DEAL WITH THEM. BUT WHAT I
REALLY LIKE ABOUT YOUR BILL IS
BECAUSE IN AREN'T THEY ARE IN A
RURAL COMMUNITIES WE DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND YOU
INCLUDED THIS IN THE BILL SO I
WANT TO THANK AND COMMEND YOU
ON THAT. AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU
ANY ANYONE ELSE. SEE KNOW WHAT
THE BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS WALDRON I
HEARD A SECOND BUT IN HER WHO
IT WAS. MISS BURKE THANK YOU-
THANK YOU FOR BEING THE SECOND
THEIR MISTRUST ON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. AS FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
O'DONNELL- METASPECTRUM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SOME OF THE PAST
MOMENTO TO APPROPRIATIONS WHAT
HI WHAT IF I MAYES. MAYES I
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BONTA BONTA FIVE BURKE
BURKE HIGH CARILLO. LARA LAURA
HI MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE. TO RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON HIGH. NINE ZERO NINE
VOTES YOUR BILLS OUT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
O'DONNELL. VERY NICE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT IT'S BETWEEN NORRIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ADD AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
IMPROVES PATIENT PROTECTIONS
AND INCREASES CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE BY ESTABLISHING
MINIMUM INSURANCE COVERAGE
STANDARDS FOR LICENSED DRUG
ABUSE RECOVERY AND TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND RECOVERY
RESIDENCES THAT CONTRACT WITH
THE GOVERNMENT ENTITY. I
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO EXISTING
STATE LAW THAT REQUIRES A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY RECOVERY RESIDENTS TO
MAINTAIN MINIMUM INSURANCE
COVERAGE LEVELS THE LACK AT
THIS REQUIREMENT PUTS PATIENTS
AND WORKERS AT RISK. AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT AIMS TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AND INCREASED
STANDARDS PLEASE TO INTRODUCE
TODAY FOR SUPPORT TESTIMONY I
TO WITNESSES BOB MALLORY
MICHAEL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE AND SHERRY DAILY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION. PROFESSIONALS AND
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU- PLEASE
MISTER ARE OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN.
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON CHAIR LED VICE CHAIR
MAYES AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MALLORY MY PHONE
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
HERE ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDOLARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AS THE BILL'S
SPONSOR COMMISSIONER LARA LIKE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. COMMISSIONER
LARA IS SPONSORING A B. FIFTY
EIGHT BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
ENSURE PROPER HEALTH SAFETY AND
INSURANCE STANDARDS THE DEATH
SO THAT THERE IS B. FOR
ENVIRONMENT FOR CONSUMERS TO
GET THE TREATMENT THEY NEED
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THIS BUT THEIR SAFETY.
ESPECIALLY DURING A PRIMER MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE SPEAKING
EXISTENCE GET A CO THE
NINETEENTH. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOU'RE EITHER ON THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
WHEELCHAIR MEMBER SHERRY DALY
WITH CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
RECOVERY RESIDENCES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY AS AN
ENTHUSIASTIC CO SPONSOR OF THE
EIGHTY UP TO FIFTY EIGHT TO
REQUIRE INSURANCE COVERAGE HE
MAINTAINED BY BOTH ENTITIES.
CONCERNING TREATMENT PROGRAMS
MOST ARE REQUIRED TO KERRY
INSURANCE FOR CONTRACTING
PURPOSES THE COUNTIES ARE THE
FALL SHORT OF THE STATE MANDATE
TO DO SO WE'VE BEEN PATIENT
VULNERABLE TO FLY BY NIGHT
OPERATORS WHO DO NOT
PARTICIPATE IN COUNTY
CONTRACTS. AND MAKE IT A FIGHT
TO OPEN TREATMENT PROGRAM
WITHOUT USING PROPER BUSINESS
PRACTICES THIS BILL WOULD CLOSE
THIS LOOPHOLE IN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM REGARDING RECOVERY
RESIDENCES WERE FAR MORE COMMON
FOR OPERATORS TO ATTEMPT TO FLY
UNDER THE RADAR. BY PURCHASING
HOMEOWNERS OR RENTERS INSURANCE
POLICIES WHERE THERE IS NO
COMMERCIAL LIABILITY INCLUDED
AT ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WOULD END
THE UNETHICAL PRACTICE THE NEED
TO HAVE APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF
INSURANCE RECOVERY RESIDENCES
IS THREEFOLD FIRST IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE RESIDENTS
TO BE PROTECTED SHOULD HARM
COME TO THEM OTHER PROPERTY.
SECOND IN ORDER FOR LANDLORDS
TO TRUST OWNERS AND OPERATORS
TO USE THE PROPERTIES FOR
RECOVERY RESIDENTS OPERATIONS
THERE MIGHT BE SOME ASSURANCE
THAT IF THERE IS PROPERTY
DAMAGE OR ANY SORT OF ACCIDENT
OR INCIDENT REQUIRING MEDICAL
EXPENSES. THE OWNER OF THE
PROPERTY WILL NOT BECOME THE
DEEP POCKETS AND ANY ENSUING
LAWSUIT THIRD AND PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY ALL RECOVERY
RESIDENCES THAT ARE NOT RUN BY
THE RESIDENTS EXCLUSIVELY WHICH
WOULD BE THE CASE AN OXFORD
MODEL HOME. MUSCAT THE LEVELS
OF INSURANCE THAT THEY THE
BILLS THAT WE DON'T LOSE GOOD
OPERATORS WHICH WOULD LEAD TO A
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF BEDS
AVAILABLE AS AN EXAMPLE LAST
YEAR WE HAD AN UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT AT ONE OF OUR
CERTIFIED HOMES WARM ONE WHERE
AND ONE RESIDENT ATTACKED
ANOTHER. THE OPERATOR OF THE
HOME HAVE PROVIDED EXPLODED BY
AN EXCELLENT BERMAN FOLLOWED
ALL THE GUIDELINES FOR SAFETY
OF THE RESIDENTS BECAUSE YOU
VOLUNTARILY PURCHASE PROPER
LEVELS OF INSURANCE THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATED FORCED ENTRY VIA
THE INSURANCE PLAN AND THAT
PLAN HOME RUN HOMES STILL EXIST
TODAY. HAS NOT BEEN FOR THE
INSURANCE THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE
CASE THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
CRUCIAL NEED. TO SUSTAINING THE
HOUSING RESOURCE WHILE
RESPECTING THE- DECIDE NOT TO
TREAT THESE HOMES. INSTITUTION
OR VIOLATE INTO THAT RIGHTS THE
REST OF. IT DOES NOT ENCROACH
FAIR HOUSING OR- STATUTE SIMPLY
SETS THE GROUND RULES FOR
TRANSACTION. BETWEEN OWNER
ROBERT. AND THEIR INSURE
CARRIER. WE RESPECTFULLY DR OUT.
THANK VERY MUCH. THIS DOES WE
DO SHOW ANY RED OPPOSITE TO THE
BILL WERE WITH WITNESSES EXCUSE
ME FOR A IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL SO WITH THAT WILL ASK THE
OPERATOR TO OPEN THE LINES FOR.
PUBLIC COMMENT. PUBLIC COMMENT
IS JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
OPERATOR. AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANYONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SINCE OUR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. I DO I DO
HAVE SOME COMMENTS AND- I WILL
PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS TO GET ONGOING EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE
PROVIDED TO SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS BY THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE INDUSTRY. I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE TRYING
TO GO WITH THE BILL AND IT HAS
MY SUPPORT TODAY OUR FEEL QUITE
STRONGLY THAT SOME OF THE
POLICY QUESTIONS WE RAISED NEED
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION HOPE TO
SEE THEM ADDRESSED AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD- THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE SO THAT I
CAN CONTINUE SUPPORT AT. THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IMPACT OF A COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS JUST
STARTING TO BE FELT WE HAVEN'T
HAD FOR A LONG TIME IT IS
INADEQUATE NUMBER OF TREATMENT
FACILITIES OUTPATIENT CLINICS
RECOVERY RESIDENCES AND S. UT
WORKFORCE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT YOUR BILL MAY HAVE
MOVING FORWARD. AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE SERVICES AT
THE TIME OF OUR GREATEST NEED
I'M ALSO NOT CONVINCED THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT VIOLATE A
PROTECTIONS OFFERED TO
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM A
DISABILITY UNDER THE FHA AND
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT LIKE OTHER BILLS THAT WE
HAVE LOOKED OUT OVER THE YEARS
IN THIS IN THIS AREA SO- SO-
I'M- I BELIEVE YOUR BILL MAY
FACE THIS ISSUE BEFORE THE NEXT
COMMITTEE- WHICH IS- THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. I AM I AM
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH EMPOWERING
INSURERS THE AUTHORITY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES ARE
COMPLYING WITH THEIR LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE BY
STATUTE OVERSEEN. BY DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. WHAT
RECOVERY READ ARE NOT CURRENTLY
REGULATED I KNOW THAT'S A HUGE
PART OF THE PROBLEM AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT EFFORTS BEEN
ABLE BEEN. UNDERTAKEN TO TRY TO
SEE THAT HAPPEN. BUT I JUST
DON'T SEE THE LOGIC IN HAVING
THEM BE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
ANY ARE OUR STANDARDS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF INSURANCE ONLY- I
ALSO HAVE IN THE INSURER IS
TOTALLY UNFAMILIAR WITH THOSE
STANDARDS. THE SPD INDUSTRY OR
HEALTH CARE STANDARDS IN
GENERAL DETERMINE IF THEY'RE
COMPLIANT. SEEMS AT BEST A
STRONG COURSE IN MY OPINION SO-
SO. LIKE I SAID I'M SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I STILL
BELIEVE THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORK. THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE HERE AND WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL
I'LL JUST SAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THIS COMMENT AND FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR EVERYTHING
THEY THAT YOU IN YOUR COMMITTEE
HAVE DONE TO WORK WITH US TO
ADVANCE THIS POLICY. YES WE
WILL CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO WORK
ON. FIVE HUNDRED AND THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN NOT
ENOUGH ANALYSIS AND IN THOSE
COMMENTS. CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THAT INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
AND WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THREAD THAT NEEDLE PROPERLY.
AND THAT WE ACHIEVE OUR GOAL OF
RAISING STANDARDS OF PATIENT
CARE. I IN THE RECOVERY SPACE
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY PHONE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BEFORE US THE MOTION.
WAS MADE BY MR MAYES SECONDED
BY MR FLOOR MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO INSURANCE- M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT WHEN I MAYES. MAYES I. HER
AGAR AYE BIGELOW. BONTA BONTA
HI BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. FLORA
FLORA HI MAIENSCHEIN MEASURING
HIGH MCCARTY. THIS AREA. CHIU
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON HIGH. NINE ZERO
I'M SORRY THE- I COULD HEAR.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLLOVER BROTHERS
ADAM THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU- WE'RE MISS WICKS IS
TESTIFYING IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
SO MR BONTA WOULD YOU BE READY
TO. PRESENT YOUR BILL. PLEASE
GO AHEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD 2% EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY EIGHT. THE FOOD
PRESCRIPTION PILOT WHICH IS
PART OF ALAMEDA COUNTY THIS-
AND I THINK WE HAVE SOME
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED TO WE'RE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU FOR THOSE. THIS BILL
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THE RACIAL
AND ETHNIC HEALTH DISPARITIES
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THROUGH FOOD
PRESCRIPTIONS A MEDICALLY
SUPPORTIVE FOOD INTERVENTION.
THE GOALS OF AB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT ARE BOLD INNOVATIVE AND
AMBITIOUS. JUST AS THE HEALTH
PROVIDER WOULD WRITE A
PRESCRIPTION FOR AN ANTIBIOTIC.
FOR AN INFECTION A PRESCRIPTION
FOR MEDICALLY SUPPORTED FOOD.
CAN HAVE THE SAME POSITIVE
HEALTH IMPACTS FOR SOMEONE WITH
PREDIABETES DIABETES. OR
HYPERTENSION. ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
INCREASING ACCESS TO HEALTHY
FOOD. COULD HELP PREVENT MANAGE
AND OR MITIGATE THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF CHRONIC DISEASES.
AND THE MEDICAID POPULATION
THIS TWO YEAR PILOT PROGRAM
ADDRESSES UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS AT THE FRONT END. BY
PROVIDING HEALTHY FOOD
PRESCRIPTIONS AS A MEDICAL
INTERVENTION. IN ALAMEDA ST
BERNARD YOU KNOW. AND FRESNO
COUNTIES. THROUGH THIS PILOT WE
CAN GAIN AN INNOVATIVE
HEALTHCARE TOOL TO ADDRESS
HEALTH DISPARITIES. AND BUILD A
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AYE- THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE VOTE. THANK YOU.
JOINT JOINING ME VIA PHONE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT OUR WOMEN'S CHAMP
MEMBER OF ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND DR STEPHEN
CHAN CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER ALL
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND YOU
WANT TO OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
OF HER ON THE LINE. RIGHT CAN
WE BE SPEAKING OR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD OF YOUR ONLINE. THE
DOCTOR STEPHEN CHEN AND THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF ALL IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE I LEAD
THAT FOOD IS MEDICINE
INITIATIVE. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTEEN
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT BEFORE
COALBED A LANDMARK STUDY
ALREADY DEMONSTRATED THAT AN
UNHEALTHY DIET IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN OUR COUNTRY
SURPASSING TOBACCO USE HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE AND OBESITY AND
CAUSING MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DEATHS PER YEAR. WITH
CALVIN IN THIS LAST YEAR WE
KNOW THAT THE VIRUS STRIKES AT
PATIENTS WITH UNDERLYING DATE
RESPOND TO CRIME DISEASES LIKE
DIABETES. COUPLE THIS WITH A
FOOD INTAKE AND WORSENING DIET.
AND WE HAVE A PERFECT STORM FOR
FURTHER DEATH SUFFERING AND
HEALTH DISPARITIES. ESPECIALLY
AMONG ME THE COLOR. ONE WAY TO
MEET THE MOMENT IS TO USE THE
POWER OF FOOD PRESCRIPTIONS TO
PREVENT TREAT AND REVERSE
CHRONIC DISEASE IN OUR BY POT
COMMUNITIES. LET ME SHARE STORY
FOR A PATIENT TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
MODEL HERE WORKS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. MISTER X. IS A FIFTY
SIX YEAR OLD MEXICAN AMERICAN
MAN WITH HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE.
HE AND CO WAS MORBIDLY OBESE
WITH THE WAY THAT HUNDRED
POUNDS OVER HIS IDEA BY THE WAY
HE COULD HAVE BEEN ANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OR FAMILY MEMBERS.
FORTUNATELY HIS DOCTOR
PRESCRIBED HIM FOOD
PRESCRIPTION THROUGH A FOOD
PHARMACY THAT OPERATED ON SITE
IN THE CLINIC WAITING ROOM
BEFORE KOBE. AND- AND NOW WE'VE
SHIFTED IT TO WEEKLY DOORSTEP
DELIVERY COULD DURING OPEN.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
FOOD FOR THE FOOD
PRESCRIPTIONS. IS SOURCED FROM
LOCAL FARMS THAT PROVIDE ME
GENERALLY GOING THROUGH. THAT
MEANS BEDSIDE FREE SEASONAL
NUTRIENT DENSE FOOD THAT IS
GOOD FOR HUMAN HEALTH AND SOIL
HEALTH. MR ACTION GOT.
NUTRITIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL
COACHING TO AMPLIFY THE EFFECTS
OF THE POOCH- PRESCRIPTION. BY
THE END OF HIS TREATMENT THIS
TRACK INCREASES FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE INTAKE BY TWO. THIS
IS NOTABLE BECAUSE AN INCREASE
IN ONE SERVING PER DAY IF YOU
EXTENDED ACROSS THE U. S.
NATIONALLY. WOULD BE THIRTY
THOUSAND LIVES SAVED OUR YEAR
IS BLOOD PRESSURE DROPPED
SIXTEEN POINT. FOR REFERENCE
TEN POINT ELEVATION IN BLOOD
PRESSURE THE SESSION WITH TWICE
THE RISK OF DEATH FROM A HEART
ATTACK OR STROKE. DIABETES
REVERSED FROM POORLY CONTROLLED
THAT LEVELS TO PRE DIABETIC
RANGES. HE WENT FROM A C. INTO
A LIFESTYLE TO EXERCISING FOUR
POINT FIVE HOURS PER WEEK. AND
A LOT SIXTY POUNDS. THE STORY
OF MISTER X. HIGHLIGHTS HELP-
PRESCRIPTIONS PLUS NUTRITIONAL
BEHAVIORAL COACHING CAN BRING
ABOUT ALL PERCENT CHANGE. IN
ADDITION I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT OUR MODEL AND THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY HAS DEMONSTRATED A 77%
REDUCTION IN HOSPITAL AND YOU
ARE RECEIVING THIS IS. A
SIXTEEN POINT REDUCTION IN
BLOOD PRESSURE IN OUR PATIENTS
WITH HYPERTENSION ANY 47%
REDUCTION IN DEPRESSION SCORES.
IN SUMMARY THE PILOT FOOD
PRESCRIPTION PROGRAMS SUPPORTED
AN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
EIGHT WILL FLATTEN THE CURVE.
OF CHRONIC DISEASE. AND CLOSE
THE GAP AND HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND ADDRESS STRUCTURAL RACISM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUILT.
ON IT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND WIND
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN WOULDN'T COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WILMA CHAN CHAIR OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND THE SPONSOR OF AB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT I SPENT SIX
YEARS AS AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
INCLUDING TWO YEARS CHAIRING-
THE HELP COMMITTEE. THIS
LEGISLATION WAS PART OF
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE COBIT-NINETEEN RACIAL DISPARITIES
TASK FORCE ESTABLISHED IN
OAKLAND AND ALAMEDA COUNTY
WHICH BOTH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
CO CHAIRING. THE TASK FORCE HAD
TWO GOALS IMMEDIATELY
ADDRESSING THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC HEALTH DISPARITIES
CREATED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
SECONDLY ADDRESSING THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THAT
PERPETUATE RACIAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES. THIS LEGISLATION
ADDRESSES BOTH OF THESE GOALS
BY USING FOOD PRESCRIPTIONS AS
A MEDICAL INTERVENTION TO TREAT
REBIRTH AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
PREVENT THE PROGRESSION OF DIET
RELATED CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITION. AMONG A RISING RATE
FOR MEDIC CAL POPULATION. AS A
COVERED BENEFIT WHO-
PRESCRIPTIONS WILL HELP
MITIGATE GROWING RATE OF FOOD
AND THAT NUTRITION AND SECURITY
WHICH HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED IN THE PAST YEAR.
UNDER THE PILOT- MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THREE
COUNTY SCHOOLS DALGLISH FOOD
PRESCRIPTION PROGRAMS THIS BILL
USES AN EQUITY LENS TO TARGET
POPULATIONS WITH THE HIGHEST
HEALTH DISPARITIES FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE PILOT. AN
ESTIMATED TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
DIAGNOSED WITH DIABETES
HYPERTENSION OR ONE OF THE
OTHER SPECIFIED HEALTH
CONDITIONS WILL RECEIVE FOOD
PRESCRIPTIONS WHICH WILL HELP
THEM WITH THE PRESCRIBED
NUMBERS OF STARVING. OF
NUTRIENT RICH FOODS FOR THE
LAND THAT THE INTERVENTION
WHICH IS TEN TO SIXTEEN WEEKS.
THE CARD PRESCRIPTIONS CAN BE
COMPLEMENTED WITH EXISTING
BEHAVIORAL COOKING OR NUTRITION
EDUCATION PROGRAMS RUN TO
APPOINTED BY MOST HEALTH PLANS.
THE RESULT FROM FOOD
PRESCRIPTION PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
DRAMATIC AS DR CHAN HAS JUST
TESTIFIED. THIS IS A HEALTH
EQUITY ISSUE AS THE HEALTH
CONDITIONS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
MAKING THEM DISPROPORTIONATELY
VULNERABLE FOR COBRA NINETEEN
RELATED HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
DEATH. AS YOU KNOW RECENT CODE
NINETEEN DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. SHOW THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATIN ACTS
COMMUNITIES REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER PERCENT OF
COPING NINETEEN. ILLNESS AND
DEATH COMPARED TO THEIR-
OVERALL POPULATION
REPRESENTATION IN CALIFORNIA WE
MUST DO BETTER THAN THIS. THESE
HEALTH DISPARITIES EXIST
BECAUSE OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
TO STOP DOWNSTREAM IT'S TIME TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMATIC ISSUES
THAT DRIVE THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. IN
INNOVATIVE WAYS BY ADDRESSING
THESE HEALTH CONDITIONS AT THE
FRONT END WE CAN CLOSE THE
PERSISTENT HEALTH DISPARITIES
GAP IN OUR STATE WE CAN BUILD A
CALIFORNIA RESILIENCE WITH
HEALTHIER RESIDENTS LESS LIKELY
TO BE HOSPITALIZED HOSPITALIZED.
IN SIRIUS COM. OR DIE FROM
CHRONIC- OR DISEASES LIKE COPD
IN NINETEEN. FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL SO WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO- PUBLIC
COMMENT ASK THE OPERATOR TO
OPEN THE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH IS ASKING FOR
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER UP WRITER.
AND WE GOT A LINE THREE OH FOUR
THIS IS JAN FLORIAN BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. GO TO LINE FOR TWENTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
CENTER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GO
TO LINE TWO ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THERE ARE
LOCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK DEPEND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WE GOT A LINE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS KELLY MCMILLAN
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT'S A GOOD ONE FOR
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YES WE GO TO LINE FOR FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SHARON MEMBERS TEN MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT WOULD ALIGN THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN
TELL STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE
GOT A LINE FOR FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
FORTY FIVE. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT IN LINE FOR TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY OF ONE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SPECIAL ALIGNED FOR FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KELLY BEING WITH HEALTH NET IN
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND
WELLNESS SERVING OVER TWO
MILLION MEDICARE MEMBERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIX EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE FOR
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS
WILLIAM AT THE BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS HER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO
THE LINE FOR FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TURN MEMBERS KATHY
MUSTARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND NEXT LEVEL ONE FOUR FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NAME
JAMIE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE
NO OTHER COMMONERS IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. C. NINE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY- OF THE SECOND BY
MISTER FLORA DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS- BILL DOESN'T
DO IT TWO DOZEN JOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE CLOSE
MR BONTA YES- THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
INITIATIVE IS EQUITABLE AND
INNOVATIVE AND- CAN HELP REDUCE
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT WOULD HAVE MEANT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT HI WHAT I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW BONTA. BONTA
AYE BURKE OKAY I CARILLO. FLORA
LAURA HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE CHIU.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ FIVE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON
WALDRON I. TWO ZERO TWELVE ZERO
BILLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THAT WILL
GO BACK TO MISS WICKS- A. B.
TWELVE- FOR ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR WORK- AND
TIME ON THIS BILL AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. BUT
BEFORE THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY UNEQUAL ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE THE CDC HAS
FOUND THAT RACISM IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS
CONTRIBUTED TO FUNDAMENTAL
HEALTH INEQUITIES AND THE CDC
IS HIGHLIGHTED THAT LIFE
EXPECTANCY AMONG BLACK
INDIVIDUALS IN THE UNITED
STATES IS FOUR YEARS LOWER THAN
WHAT INDIVIDUALS AND IN SOME
PARTS OF MY DISTRICT IT'S- UP
TO TEN YEARS. THIS PANDEMIC IS
FURTHER EXPOSED AND EXACERBATED
THESE. THESE INEQUITIES IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. BLACK LATIN
ACCENT INDIGENOUS PEOPLE ARE AT
AN INCREASED RISK OF EXPOSURE
ILLNESS HOSPITALIZATION. AND
DEATH RELATIVE TO THEIR SHARE
OF THE POPULATION. AS WE HAVE
SEEN THE COVER NINETEEN
MORTALITY RATE FOR BLACK
INDIVIDUALS IS MORE THAN THREE
TIMES THAT OF WHITE
INDIVIDUALS. THEREFORE IT IS
IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN EVER.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE COMPLETE
ACCURATE. AND TRANSPARENT DATA
REPORTING IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
AND RESPOND TO THE HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES IN OUR STATE.
CURRENTLY OUR STATE IS LIMITED
ON. HEALTH QUALITY AND
WORKFORCE DATA AND THESE
METRICS ARE NEEDED TO BEGIN
ADDRESSING THIS THESE ISSUES.
AB TROUBLE FOR REQUIRED THE
COLLECTION OF DATA ON PATIENT
HEALTH OUTCOMES BY RACE
ETHNICITY AND OTHER
DEMOGRAPHICS. THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRE COLLECTION OF WORKFORCE
DATA. WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS DIVERSITY AND STAFF AND
MANAGEMENT HEALTH CARE DELIVERY.
MY OFFICE IN THE BILL'S
SPONSORS HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITALS
ASSOCIATION. WHO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS REGARDING THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS. THE
BILL AND THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY SEIU AND SUPPORTED BY HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND OTHERS. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY ARE VERY. A
VERY JUNE DíAS REPRESENTING US
YEAH YOU AND STEPHANIE POWELL
REPRESENTING US YEAH YOU YOU H.
W. THANK. THANK YOU- THIS IS A
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
AND MEMBERS AND A FAMILY MEMBER
WAIT FOR CHAMPIONING THE BILL
MY NAME IS ANGIE THE ACT HERE
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA
AND ARE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS MOST OF WHICH ARE FIVE
NINETY CENTRAL HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. WHO HAD SEEN HOW LACK
OF ACCESS AND QUALITY OF CARE
HAVE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR BEFORE AND DURING THIS
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS
WE AS YESTERDAY DAYS AFTER
DECLARING RACISM AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT THE CDC RELEASED
A PAIR OF STUDIES FURTHER
QUANTIFYING THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
CLOTHING NINETEEN ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE STUDY
NOTED THAT THESE HEALTH
DISPARITIES WERE NOT CAUSED BY
THE PANDEMIC BUT THEY WERE
CERTAINLY EXACT EXACERBATED. BY
CALLED THE NINETEEN. I DID I'M
GOING. LEVEL IN THE DELIVERY
AND QUALITY OF HEALTH
CONTRIBUTION THESE HEALTH
DISPARITIES. UNEQUAL HEALTHCARE
TREATMENT HAS BEEN CAUSED BY A
NUMBER OF FACTORS. INCLUDING
LACK OF ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
AND TIMELY PROVIDER CARE
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND URBAN
AREAS. UNCONSCIOUS BIAS OR
STERN PERCEPTION THAT PROVIDERS
MAY HAVE WHEN TREATING PATIENTS
OF COLOR. PROVIDERS NOT
POSSESSING OR OFFERING
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE- INTERPRETATION
SKILLS ARE LANGUAGE ACCESS TO
PATIENTS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY AMONG OTHERS. AB
TROUBLE FOR WOULD ADDRESS
RACIAL INEQUITIES IN HEALTHCARE
BY REQUIRING HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS TO SHARE REYES
DISAGGREGATED HEALTHCARE
QUALITY AND WORKFORCE DATA. AS
WE ALL KNOW COLLECTING AND
UNDERSTANDING THE DATA ARE THE
FIRST STEP. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
PROVIDERS ARE FULFILLING THEIR
PROMISE ON DELIVERING QUALITY
CARE AND I GAVE BIRTH WORKFORCE
EIGHTY TOTAL WAR WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP
EQUITY PLAN TO ADDRESS SUCH
DISPARITIES. ON TO ADDRESS SOME
OF STATE CASE OPPOSITION. NOTED
IN ANNOUNCES. I POTENTIAL CHIU.
A H. R. K. IN NYC ACCORDING
THIS THESE CHALLENGES HOSPITAL
OR COLLECT AND REPORTING THESE
BECAUSE THESE ARE QUALITY
INDICATORS THAT ARE USED. BY A
WIDE RANGE OF ORGANIZATIONS FOR
A VARIETY OF PURPOSES. FOR
EXAMPLE HOSPITALS NATIONWIDE
USE THESE QUALITY INDICATORS TO
ASSIST IN QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS. ESPECIALLY IN ACUTE
CARE HOSPITALS THIS SETTINGS
ADDITIONALLY HOSPITALS USE
THESE QUALITY INDICATORS TO
HELP THEM UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
ACTUALLY COMPARE WITH OTHER
HOSPITALS IN RELATIONSHIP TO
BOTH STATE AND NATIONAL
AVERAGES. SECONDLY ON THE WORK
FORCE AND T. DATA AB TOTAL
FORCE REPORTING REQUIREMENT IS
BASED ON THE PROVIDER MEETING
BOTH OF THE FOLLOWING
REQUIREMENTS. BURKE B. I THEIR
PRIVATE PUBLIC OR NONPROFIT
PROVIDER WITH THREE HUNDRED OR
MORE PHYSICIAN AND SECONDLY
HAVING A HUNDRED OR MORE
EMPLOYEES. THE BILL ACTUALLY
LIMITS REPORTING TO THE
PROVIDER THESE ARE EMPLOYERS
THAT ARE ALREADY BEING REQUIRED
TO REPORT ON THE HER FEDERAL E.
O. ONE FORM- HAVING THIS DATA
WILL HELP ENSURE AN EFFECTIVE
AND EQUITABLE RESPONSE TO THE
LONG TERM IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND OTHER DIFFERENT
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND I BOTH. I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO ONE OF OUR AND YEAH YOU
MEMBERS STEPHANIE PAULO FOR HER
TESTIMONY I'M ALSO AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS. THAT YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE PAULA A RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST IN A LARGE HOSPITAL
IN CINEMA COUNTY I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF SEIU YOU H. W. I
WITNESSED FIRSTHAND. THE RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST IN HEALTH CARE. A
MAJORITY OF MY PATIENTS WERE
SPANISH LATINO AND A MAJORITY
OF THEM WERE MIDDLE AGED
FARMWORKERS WITH. UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS- SUCH AS
HYPERTENSION UNDIAGNOSED
DIABETES PRE DIABETES- AND THAT
DEFINITELY PUT DOWN AT A HIGHER
RISK OF DEATH FROM CODED- IF
YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
NINETEEN PREFERRED PEOPLE WITH.
THEM DIABETES AND THESE
PATIENTS ARE MANY OF THEM
CONFIDED WITH ME THAT THEY HAD
NO ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE- EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE CITIZENS THESE
WERE NOT JUST ILLEGAL CITIZENS
THESE ARE CITIZENS THAT WERE
FARMWORKERS GIVING THE JOB THAT
MANY- ESSENTIAL WORKERS- HAVE.
BEEN HELD IN JAIL. I FOUND IT
VERY. THAT NOBODY WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT THIS- I WE SAW ON
THE MEDIA WHAT WAS COMING DOWN
THE PIPE- ESPECIALLY MY SISTER
WHO LIVES BACKIN MICHIGAN SHE
LIVES IN A PREDOMINANTLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY. AND
SHE WAS SEEING AT THE FACT HER
COMMUNITY- A- MUCH WORSE THAN
IT WAS THE CARD CASE COMMUNITY
I WAS SEEING PROBABLY THREE
HISPANIC PATIENTS FOR EVERYONE
CAUCASIAN- PATIENT IN MY
FACILITY. WE KNOW THAT THE
DEFENDANT THE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE ARE MULTIFACTORIAL
WE KNOW THAT. THE SOCIO
ECONOMICS ARE PROBABLY THE
LEADING FACTOR BUT IT'S ALSO
THAT THESE FAMILIES- ARE MULTI
GENERATIONAL LIVING AND SMALL
HOUSING UNITS- AND OTHER
FACTORS. BUT ALSO THE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS WERE- AT IT WAS A VERY
ARE YOU NOT BEING ABLE TO SPEAK
ENGLISH FOR MANY OF THESE
PATIENTS- ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
THESE NUMBERS OUT WHEN I TRIED
TO TALK ABOUT THIS. MY MANAGER
TOLD ME THAT I COULDN'T DISCUSS
IT ANY FURTHER I TOLD HIM I WAS
WELCOMED ON A RADIO SHOW HOPE
TO TALK ABOUT- THE
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNTS OF
LATINOS THAT WERE AFFECTED AND
I CONFIDED THAT I KNEW I COULD
NOT. TALK ABOUT HIPAA ANYTHING
CONFIDENTIAL AND. SOMEBODY UP
FROM QUALITY IS MOCKING ME
ABOUT IT AND SAID THAT IT WAS
PROPRIETARY DATA IT'S AN EXCUSE
ME. YEAH I THINK LIKE HOW BIG
HOW MANY BEDS WE HAVE LAST THAT
THE HOSPITAL IS FULL YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO TALK ABOUT ANY OF
THAT I SAID I GET THAT BUT I
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT BUT
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE HOSPITALS ARE FULL THAT'S
THE OBVIOUS. ALREADY HAD THAT
OUT THERE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO HIDE BUT THEN
THEY WERE VERY CLEAR THAT THEY
DIDN'T WANT ME TO GO TO THE
WHICH COMMUNITY AND GET THE
WORD OUT. I WENT HOME I DROVE
HOME CRYING ALMOST WRECKED MY
CAR I JUST COULDN'T BELIEVE
THAT PEOPLE. ARE PROPRIETARY
DATA THAT THAT THIS COMMUNITY
THAT I LOVE TO WORK WITH- HANG
OUT WITH. OUR PROPRIETARY DATA.
I THOUGHT THERE'S NO WAY TO
TALK BE LEAGUE. SO WHEN I HEARD
ABOUT THIS. RACE AND HEALTH
CARE TRANSPARENCY ACT I WAS SO
EXCITED. BECAUSE I THOUGHT.
WHEN I READ THROUGH IT I
COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF
THIS WAS AN ALREADY TRANSPARENT-
WE REALLY NEED IT WE REALLY
NEED TO GET THE NUMBERS OUT.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO TAKE THE
SERIOUS- THERE ARE TRYING TO
REACH ME THESE. THESE ARE. THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
AND I'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO THE
LANGUAGE BARRIER WE HAVE
COMPUTERS IN EVERY ROOM- ONE
COMPUTER FOR EVERY CHU- SHE
SAID THAT ARE IN A ROOM. SO
THAT WAS ONE ISSUE IF ONE
PATIENT DIDN'T SPEAK SPANISH
AND THE OTHER PATIENT DID IT
DID WE USUALLY CO WORDED OR
COPD PATIENTS TOGETHER BUT THEY
WORK TOWARD IT- PLEASE LEAVE
YOUR COMPUTER PLEASE PLEASE
WRAP WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WELL
PAST OUR TIME HERE SO OKAY AS
MEDICARE. PART IT WAS NOT. THE
YOU EVERYTHING ENOUGH OF THESE
CAN. WE HAD SOME IPAD THERE
WERE NOT ENOUGH OF. IF IT
WEREN'T FOR THE SPANISH
SPEAKING NURSING ASSISTANTS
THAT WERE THERE HELPING ME- I
DON'T KNOW HOW I WOULD HAVE
COMMUNICATED WITH MANY OF THESE
PATIENTS IN FACT IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT. SO THAT'S WHY PART
OF THIS BILL CALLS FOR- J. DATA
AS WELL AS A PLAN FOR IMPROVING
THE QUALITY AND DIVERSITY OF
THE STAFF. SO WE YOU NOTHING'S
BETTER THAN A HUMAN TOUCH AND-
YEAH I DID LEARN SOME SPANISH
FOR THIS BUT WITH THE- BUSINESS
YEAR. AND OFTEN VERY
TRAUMATIZED BY WATCHING MIDDLE
AGED HISPANIC MAN WHO WERE
FAIRLY HEALTHY DINING AT A
DISPROPORTIONATE RATE. AND I
REALLY HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
AND- WILL HELP US PASSED THIS
ACT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. I THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN. HELLO BARBARA HAD-
THANK YOU AARON MEMBERS THIS IS
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
AB TWELVE OH FOUR WOULD REQUIRE
HOSPITALS AND MEDICAL GROUPS TO
ANNUALLY SUBMIT AN EQUITY
REPORT THAT INCLUDES ANALYSES
OF HEALTH STATUS IN ACCESS TO
CARE DISPARITIES FOR PATIENTS
ON THE BASIS OF RACE ETHNICITY
AND PAIR. ADDITIONALLY THIS
REPORT WOULD INCLUDE EMPLOYMENT
DISPARITIES FOR EMPLOYEES ON
THE SAME DAY STREET IT WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE PLANS FOR
ADDRESSING THOSE DISPARITIES.
WELL HA. THE GOAL OF REDUCING
HEALTH DISPARITIES WE DO HAVE A
POSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED ON AB TWELVE OH FOUR.
IT'S A GREAT PLACE HA IS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
WITH REPORTING TO HEALTH
OUTCOMES RELATED TO THE AGENCY
FOR HEALTHCARE RESEARCH AND
QUALITY INDICATORS. HOSPITAL
CAN GENERATE INFORMATION ON
WHOM THEY SERVE WHERE THEY LIVE
IN THE HOSPITAL'S SERVICES
DELIVERED. HOWEVER WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOSPITAL'S
ABILITY TO COLLECT RELATED
OUTCOMES DEPENDING ON HOW THEY
WILL BE DEFINED BY OUR SPENT.
THERE ARE OVER SIXTY EIGHT HR
Q. INDICATORS. FOCUSED ON A
DAHLE PREVENTION PEDIATRIC
PREVENTION INPATIENT QUALITY
AND PATIENT SAFETY AND
HOSPITALS WILL NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE SPECIFIC
MEASURES AND RELATED. OUTCOMES
TO FOCUS THEIR REPORTING. IN
HOSPITAL REMAIN FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THEIR WORKPLACES ARE
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE. THESE
EFFORTS INCLUDE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE PAY POLICIES FOR ALL
OF THEIR WORKERS. HOWEVER AB
TWELVE OH FOUR REQUIRES THAT
HOSPITALS AND ONLY HOSPITAL'S
DIVULGE SENSITIVE PAID DATA
THAT ARE PROTECTED UNDER BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW WE DO NOT
BELIEVE REQUIRING HOSPITALS TO
REPORT HOSPITALS PAY DATA IS
THE APPROPRIATE PATH FORWARD.
C. H. A. RECOMMENDS THAT AUSTIN
HAD CONVENE AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE COMPRISED OF A
REPRESENTATIVE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO REVIEW
INDICATORS AND OUTCOMES THAT
INCLUDE A HR Q. INDICATORS.
CLAIM AND ENCOUNTER DATA THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE VIA THE
HEALTHCARE PAYMENTS DATA
PROGRAM AND OTHER INFORMATION
TO INFORM THE COLLECTION OF
SPECIFIC MEASURES AND OUTCOMES
FOR PROVIDER REPORTING. MARKET
COULD THEN DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK
FOR EQUITY REPORTING BASED ON
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE'S
FEEDBACK FOR HOSPITALS AND
PHYSICIAN GROUPS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
TEN MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION- I WANTED TO QUICKLY
THANK- THE AUTHOR HER STAFF THE
SPONSORS IN MR KERRIER STAFF AS
WELL AND WORKING WITH OUR
CONCERNS OVER ENSURING THAT
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT INFORMATION
THAT'S ALREADY BEING REPORTED
BY THE HOSPITALS WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENT THAT'S IN THE
ANALYSIS OUR FOLKS ARE TAKING A
LOOK AT IT AND IF WE HAVE ANY-
FUTURE CONCERNS WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WITH THAT WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR.
WITNESSES ACTUALLY BY A PUBLIC
COMMENT. JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER OPERATIVE.
AND WE START WITH LINE FOR
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE NINE TO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE ARE
FLOCKS REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK
DEPEND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHY NUMBER FOUR TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN STATISTIC NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY NUMBER FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HE ENTERED THE CHILDREN
OUT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE GOT A LINE
FOR FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING YES MEN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE GOT A
LINE FOR FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
MICHELLE GAYLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
HEY WE GOT A LINE FOR FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS PARAM NAPA P. AND
HIGHWAYS SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. OKAY
THAT WASN'T THE BILL WE WERE ON
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT- NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND THERE ARE NO
NO SECURITIES TIME OKAY THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE OF
THIS PROHIBITS AGUIAR-CURRY I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. PLEASE I
WOULD LOVE TO ADD USER AUTHOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE
HERE CURRY A SECOND BY MISS
BURKE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS OF
BILL TO CHOICES DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE
MYSTICS. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT MADAM CLERK
PLEASE REMAIN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
NOW BONTA BONTA I. BURKE BURKE
I. CARRILLO CARILLO FIVE FLORA.
FLOOR LOW MAIENSCHEIN MASON
HIGH MCCARTY. NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I TO. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON NOW. EIGHTY THREE THE
BILL WAS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANKS THANKS THANKS
MISS WEEKS BEFORE WE GO TO OUR
LAST BILL WOULD ASK THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH COMMITTE
TO PLEASE COME TO THE CHAMBERS
SO WE HAVE WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO WE HAVE WE HAVE BILLS
THAT HAVEN'T HAD A MOTION YET.
SO SOON AS A- YEAH WE WANNA.
PLEASE COME TO THE CHAMBER SO
WE CAN FINISH OUR WORK THIS
EVENING SO. WITH THAT- MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN YOU HAVE THE HONOR
OF THE LAST BILL OF THE EVENING.
THAT YOU'RE ANTICIPATING
GREATNESS AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FOURTEEN THE
RARE DISEASE SEQUENCING FOR
CRITICALLY ILL INFANTS ACT WHEN
WE THINK OF WELCOMING A NEWBORN
BABY. WE EXPECT THEM TO BE BORN
HEALTHY HAPPY AND READY TO LIVE
A FULL LIFE UNFORTUNATELY SOME
INFANTS ARE BORN WITH CRITICAL
ILLNESSES. THAT REQUIRE SERIOUS
MEDICAL ATTENTION AS SOON AS
THEIR LIVES BEGAN SOMETIMES THE
CAUSES OF THE INFANT INFANT
SYSTEM. SYMPTOMS IS NOT EASILY
DIAGNOSABLE AND DOCTORS OFTEN
HAVE TO RESORT TO INVASIVE
DIAGNOSTIC TESTS AND PROCEDURES
IN THE MOST CRITICAL CASES
DOCTORS HAVE TURNED A GENOME
SEQUENCING A REVOLUTIONARY AND
COMPREHENSIVE DIAGNOSTIC TOOL.
THAT EXAMINES THE STRUCTURE OF
A PATIENT'S DNA THE SIMPLE
BLOOD TEST CAN POINT TO
ABNORMALITIES ARE EXTREMELY
RARE DISEASES THAT MAY EXPLAIN
THE INFANT'S ILLNESSES. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS CO CHAIR THE
RARE DISEASE CAUCUS WE SECURE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE BUDGET. DEFINE PROJECT
BABY BEAR A PILOT PROJECT THAT
EXPLORED THE BENEFITS OF RAPID
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING. IF IT
WAS TREATED AS THE STANDARD OF
CARE RATHER THAN A LAST RESORT.
PROJECT BABY ARE SEQUENCED A
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
CRITICALLY ILL BABIES ON MEDIC
CAL AND THE RESULTS WERE
IMPRESSIVE. THIRTY FIVE RARE
CONDITIONS WERE DIAGNOSED
PATIENTS SPENT AN AVERAGE OF
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTEEN FEWER
DAYS IN THE HOSPITAL. AND
ELEVEN FEWER MAJOR SURGERIES
WERE PERFORMED RAPID WHOLE
GENOME SEQUENCING PRODUCED
RESULTS THAT HELP DOCTORS
DEVELOP A MORE TARGETED
MANAGEMENT OF PATIENT CARE. AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE THE STATE AN
ESTIMATED TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND HEALTH CARE
COSTS. UNFORTUNATELY THIS LIFE
CHANGING TOOL ISN'T EQUITABLY
ACCESSIBLE. PATIENTS ON MEDI
CAL HAVE NEEDED TO RELY ON
DONATIONS ARE CLINICAL TRIALS
IN ORDER TO COVER THE COSTS OF
THE SEQUENCING. AB ONE FOURTEEN
SIX TO CLOSE THIS DISPARITY IN
PROVIDE RAPID WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING AS A COVERED MEDICAL
BENEFIT. FOR CRITICALLY ILL
BABIES ONE YEAR YOUNGER
RECEIVING IN PATIENT CARE AND
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT. WITH THAT
WITH US HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OR TWO PIONEERS IN
THE FIELD. DR STEPHEN KING'S
MORE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF READY
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE FOR
GENOMIC MEDICINE. AND DR
PATRICK FREE AS PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF RADY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
AND HEALTH CENTER SAN DIEGO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MMHM
MISTRUST RAIDER PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND WHEN YOU'RE ON
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO GO AHEAD.
THE MORE YOU ARE. BOGHEAD GET
STARTED GOING FOR A FEW GOOD
EVENING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON BACK OF
PACKAGE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT'S WE
ALREADY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
HEALTH CENTER IN SAN DIEGO
WE'RE THE ONLY TEAM CARE%
HOSPITAL SERVING EXCLUSIVELY
CHILDREN THE SAN DIEGO REGION
AND THEY ALSO SERVE CHILDREN
FROM SOUTHERN RIVERSIDE
IMPERIAL COUNTY DEFAULT MANY
OTHER APPOINTED COUNTY. THE
BOSTON HALF OF THE CHILDREN
THAT WE SERVE A MEDIC CAL
ELIGIBLE BACHELOR KEENLY
FOCUSED ON HEALTH EQUITY
CAPITAL GENOME SEQUENCING AS
YOU JUST HEARD FROM SOMEWHERE
MAIENSCHEIN IS PROVING TO BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN DIAGNOSING
TREATING RARE DISEASES IN
CRITICALLY ILL INFANTS AND
CHILDREN AND INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT AT MULTIPLE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
QUALITY PRIVATE INSURANCE
COMPANIES COVER THE COST OF THE
JOBS IT IS NOT CURRENTLY A
MEDICARE COVERED BENEFITS
THEY'RE FOR CURRENT TIME RATE
CHILDREN SHE'S BEEN HELPING
SUBSIDIZE PAYMENT THE SECRET TO
MEDICAL PATIENTS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT IS NOT A SUSTAINABLE
LONG TERM SOLUTION OUR GOAL OF
AB ONE FOURTEEN IS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL BABIES WHO COULD
BENEFIT REGARDLESS OF A
FAMILY'S ABILITY TO PAY HAVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THIS
LIFESAVING AND LIFE CHANGING
CHANNELS. WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB. ONE FOURTEEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVING ON TO OUR WITNESS.
DR KING'S MORE. I DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND- IF DR
KING'S WORDS ABLE TO JOIN US
WILL ALLOW HIM TO TESTIFY- SO
DISTRAUGHT FREIGHTER PLEASE-
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY PLEASE SO. WHEN
YOU'RE READY MISTER OPERATOR.
OKAY WE'LL START WITH MY NUMBER
TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS NEAR MARTIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YEAH
LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KELLY
MCMILLAN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE
LINE FOR FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DOCTOR
STEPHEN KING'S MORE I HOPE YOU
CAN HEAR ME OKAY AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO. GO AHEAD
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD ON
THE PRESIDENT. I'M THE
PRESIDENCY OF RADY CHILDREN'S
INSTITUTE FOR GENOMICS MEDICINE
UNFORTUNATELY I GOT CUT OFF A
SECOND AGO- I I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- I'D
LIKE TO TELL YOU A PATIENT
STORY ONE OF THE PATIENTS THAT
WE- TREATED WITH RAPID WHOLE
GENOME SEQUENCING. RELATIVELY
RECENTLY IT'S A LITTLE BOY CALL
RYAN HE ARRIVED IN OUR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AT ELEVEN
PM ON A SUNDAY NIGHT. AND HE
HAD SIGNS SUGGESTING THAT HIS
BRAIN WAS NOT FUNCTIONING
NORMALLY HE WAS EXTREMELY
IRRITABLE. WE DID A BRAIN SCAN
WHICH SHOWED THAT HE HAD SEVERE
BRAIN ANOMALIES AND WE ADMITTED
THEM TO OUR INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT. THE NEXT DAY HIS
PHYSICIANS WHO WERE STUMPED TO
KNOW THE CAUSE OF HIS ILLNESS.
REQUESTED THAT WE PERFORM THIS
MIRACULOUS NEW TECHNOLOGY RAPID
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING. WE DID
THAT- WITHIN FOURTEEN HOURS
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE CAUSE
OF THE CHILD'S ILLNESS HE HAD A
GENETIC DISEASE. DID THESE WAS
TREATABLE BY TO OVER THE
COUNTER SUPPLEMENTS DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS BUTTON ON SIGN IN.
WE ARE ABLE TO START THOSE
MEDICINES WITHIN A COUPLE OF
HOURS IN BABY RYAN ON BY SIX PM
THAT EVENING HE WAS ALERT
ORIENTED AND BOTTLE FEEDING.
JUST A NORMAL HAPPY SIX WEEK
OLD BABY. HE WAS ABLE. TO GO
HOME JUST A COUPLE OF DAYS
LATER. CONTRAST THAT WITH HIS
OLD SISTER WHO HAD PRESENTED IS
EXACTLY THE SAME AGE OF LIFE
TEN YEARS EARLIER BEFORE THIS
TECHNOLOGY WAS AVAILABLE.
TRAGICALLY SHE SEES UNTIL. THE
END OF HER LIFE ABOUT ONE YEAR
OF AGE SHE WAS IN AND OUT OF
HOSPITAL THAT ENTIRE PERIOD OF
TIME. THIS CASE DRAMATICALLY
EXPLAINS WHY WE ARE IN FAVOR OF
RAPID WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING-
MAKING THIS A BENEFIT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BABIES. A
RESPECTIVE OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
POLICE- OF OPEN THE LINES AGAIN
OF MISTRUST RAIDER. AND WE HAVE
LINE FOR FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND THERE'S NO
OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
GREAT THANK YOU BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SIXTEEN SEEING NONE- WE- BUT WE
HAD A MOTION ALREADY OR YOU
HAVE COME- I'M SORRY I'M SORRY.
THIS REALLY QUICK- IN LIGHT OF
TIME BUT THIS IS AN AMAZING
PROGRAM THEY HAVE ALREADY
CHILDREN. AND ALSO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED TO
EXPAND IT. YOU KNOW FURTHER-
WHEN YOU LOOK AT NEONATAL OTHER
P. PDF AND PARENTS WITH
UNDIAGNOSED DISEASES. THAT OF
REMAIN UNDIAGNOSED OR- WITH
MULTIPLE INCORRECT DIAGNOSIS IS
AND THE SUFFERING THAT GOES ON-
THIS IS A WAY TO. REALLY TREAT
THEM EARLY AND GET THEM BACK ON
THEIR FEET- GINGIVAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR HIS AREA. I JUST
WANT TO COMMENT FIRST OF ALL
I'D LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL IN SUPPORT I'M JUST
FASCINATED BY THIS AREA IN BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE NINETY
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PUT MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND THEY'RE
ANTICIPATING THE CHEN KNOWN-
SEQUENCING TO BE DONE IN. ABOUT
A DECADE PERIOD OF TIME THAT
WAS THE FASTEST THAT THEY COULD
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AT THAT TIME
AND TO HEAR THE DOCTOR RIGHT
NOW TALK ABOUT A FOURTEEN HOUR
PERIOD AND IN MANY CASES EVEN
LESS THAN THAT IT IT IT'S
PHENOMENAL WHAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE
FUNDING AND FINANCING THESE
PROJECTS SO THAT WE CAN- OF
BETTER GET TO THE ROOT OF MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE STILL
GRAPPLING. WITH SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
I'D BE HONORED TO SUPPORT OTHER
SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO ONE OF THE
BILL DOES ENJOY IT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OR DO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER FOR A SECOND I
MISS BURKE. THE MOTION TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD LIKE THE
CLOSENESS RANGER I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I WANT TO THANK AGAIN- DR YES
AND DR KING'S MORE FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY THE GREAT WORK
THAT I READY CHILDREN'S OF SAN
DIEGO IS DONE ON THIS. THIS IS
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BILL AND
NOT JUST FOR SAN DIEGO BUT FOR
THE STATE AS A WHOLE WHAT THIS
WILL MEAN FOR BABIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES- AND FOR ALL OF US IN
THE STATE. I THINK IT'S
TREMENDOUS SO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I WITH THAT WILL
HAVE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. AND CALL THE
MEMBERS. THE MOTION AS THE PAST
TWO APPROPRIATIONS WHAT HI WHAT
I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW HI BONTA.
BONTA HI BURKE BURKE HI
CARRILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA
FLUORIDE MAJOR MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. THIS AREA NAZARIAN
HIGH TO TWO I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI WALDRON. WALDRON HIGH.
FOURTEEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY SO WE HAVE WE STILL
HAVE WORK TO DO HERE MEMBERS
IN. WITH SOMEBODY. C. OF MR
MCCARTY IS OUTSIDE THEIR. SO WE
COULD MAYBE JUST GO THROUGH
THIS ONE TIME. MR BONTA IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE TO COME IN
THAT WOULD BE GREAT AS WELL. SO
WE COULD MAYBE JUST DO THIS ONE
TIME. OKAY HERE WE GO WHERE ARE
WE ALL HERE ALL FIFTEEN OF US
IT OKAY ALL FIFTEEN OF US WE'RE
GONNA DO IS ONE TIME GOOD.
THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER ONE- IS
IN SEARCH OF A MOTION AB FOR
ARAMBULA- MOTION AND A CHORUS
OF SECONDS WE'LL GIVE IT TO MR
RODRIGUEZ- MADAM SECRETARY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT HI
WHEN I MAYES. MAYES NONVOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NARROW BONTA
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA NOW
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA
IN THIS AREA AND I CHU CHU AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON NO.
ELEVEN TO THREE OKAY THAT IS-
THAT BILLS 11-3 THANK YOU- ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB THREE SEVENTY- IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION- FLOOR MR
FLOOR MOTIONS- MISTER MCCARTY
SECONDS THE MOTION IS- DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WHAT I MAYES. MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW I. BONTA
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE CARRILLO.
I'M SORRY BURKE I CARILLO HI
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I A MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN THIS AREA AND I TO
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN ZERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF ITEMS
NUMBER THREE AB NETWORK TEN
NINETY FOUR ARAMBULA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE BERMAN ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN A. B. TEN FORTY SIX A
RUBIO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR A YEAR CURRY
AND ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX A.
B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SECOND BY MISTER HIS AREA.
PLEASE- MEDICAID PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WHAT I MAYES
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I. BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. HI FLORA
FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE CHU. CHU
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
WALDRON HIGH FIFTEEN ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY MISS CERVANTES IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION. MOTION BY
MISTER FLOOR MISTER MAYES
SECOND BY MISTAKE OF MISS
CARILLO- MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HI WHAT I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I. BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE. I CARRILLO CARRILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAJOR NINE MCCARTY. MCCARTY I
IN THIS AREA NAZARIAN AYE CHU
TO ARRIVE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON
WALDRON NINE FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER SIX- AB SIX
SIXTY SIX BY MISTER CHOOSE A
LOT OF SIX IS THERE- PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BIGELOW BIGELOW I.
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE. BURKE HI
CARILLO. I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN- PLEASE AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY MR CHIU PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. A UNIVERSAL IF THE
CALL ON THIS ONE- THANKS FOR
THE CALL I'M SORRY MY APOLOGIES.
BIGELOW BIGELOW NARROW BONTA. I
RIO HI MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
HAI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
WALDRON. WALDRON NOW. 11-3 THE
BILL WAS OUT ON A VOTE OF
ELEVEN TO THREE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT A. B. TEN NINETY EIGHT
FIVE MISTER DAILY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA BONTA AYE CORREO.
I MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I.
TWO TO ARRIVE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON WALDRON NINE
FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE IST BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
PLEASE OF LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES MAYES
NOT VOTING BONTA. BONTA I.
VETERANS. I MCCARTY MCCARTY I
TO TWO FIVE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
HI WALDRON. IDM NUMBER NINE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. WATER NOW.
ELEVEN TO ONE ELEVEN TO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT- ITEM NUMBER TEN A.
B. FOURTEEN RIGHT TO BE A E
FOUR FIFTY- BY MS GONZALEZ
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA I.
MAIENSCHEIN MEASURING HIGH
MCCARTY MCCARTY I TO AYE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I. FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU- ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB THREE EIGHTY NINE IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION. MOVE THE
BILL WAS THAT MR RODRIGUEZ IN
THE SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
PARDON AB THREE EIGHTY NINE BY
MISTER GRAYSON ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN. SO TO GET THE MOTION
WRITER BECAUSE IT. BECAUSE IT'S
CLOSE ENOUGH THERE WAS OF
COURSE OF MOTION SO- BUT I
THINK WE GOT IT RIGHT- MADAM
SECRETARY WITH THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS A MINUTE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
BONTA BONTA I BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. HI FLORA LAURA HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HAI
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN HIGH CHU CHU AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVING ON TO- ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TEN FORTY TWO- PLEASE
LET THE CALL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA I
CARILLO. CARILLO FIVE FLORA.
FOR NOW MAIENSCHEIN MAYES RAN
HIGH MCCARTY MCCARTY I TWO TWO
HI RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HIGH. TWELVE
TO AT POTUS WILL TOO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB SIX BY MR LEVINE
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CARILLO. CAREER
HIGH FOR LAURA HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
HI THIS AREA NAZARIAN I TWO TWO
I. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWO SEVENTY
NINE BY MISTER MURATSUCHI
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BIGELOW BIGELOW
NOW. CARILLO CAREER HIGH FLOOR
FOR NOW MAIENSCHEIN MISSION AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE CHU CHU AYE
WALDRON. FOR ELEVEN TO TWO.
ELEVEN TO. I ITEM NUMBER SIX HI.
SO WE COULD WE GET THERE. OKAY
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX BY MISTER O'DONNELL
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW. SIXTEEN
BIGELOW I AREA CAREER HIGH
MAIENSCHEIN MICHON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I TO ARRIVE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO FIVE FIFTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN- PLEASE LIFT OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW. YEAH BIGELOW I CARILLO
I MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS
AREA. IS THERE AND I TO ZERO
FIVE SANTIAGO SO ZERO FIVE
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN PLEASE LIFT AB TWELVE
OH FOUR BY MISS WICKS PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCCARTY MCCARTY I. TO
TWO FIVE ZERO PHOTO BY ELEVEN
THREE THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
I MISS AGUIAR-CURRY PLEASE WITH
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON. THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY MR
BONTA PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
CALL THE THAT LIFT THE CALL AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GIVES
ME CARILLO. CARILLO I MCCARTY
MCCARTY I TO HI FIFTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU AN ITEM NUMBER-
TWENTY THREE AB ONE ONE
PHARMACIST HERE SORRY. OKAY
OKAY. SO WE'RE WE'RE GOOD TO GO.
READY TO GO AB ONE ONE FOUR BY
MR MAIENSCHEIN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR. EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
TWO MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA. WHAT I CARILLO
HI LAURA. MAJOR A FRIEND I
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. TO TWO HI.
THIRTEENERS ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THE FINAL ITEM ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE THE B. EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE BY MISTER NAZARIAN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE SERVER
TWELVE TWENTY FIVE EIGHT THIRTY
FIVE OKAY. CARILLO HI FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES RAN HIGH
MCCARTY MCCARTY I TO. TWO FIVE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI. THIRTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.